DON'T YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT
THIS WILL GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. RACE THROUGH
THIS EXCITING SCRIPT. BECAUSE
IN RESPONSE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING YOUR
FACE KIND OF COVERAGE. AND
COMPLIANCE OF ITS ORDERS. THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESSIBLE IS A PROCESS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARING.
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH ONE OF
OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESERVING REMOTELY. I REMEMBER
ATTENDING REMOTELY TODAY IS
SENATOR STERN. WE ASK- AND WHEN
YOU CAN ON WE'RE GONNA ASK TO
SEE HE HAS PERSON WILL HIM TO
ITEM. THE STAFF. OBVIOUSLY OF.
AFTER ME TO PHONE OR CA. FULL A
IN L. ANY ACOUSTIC FEED. I
ASKED EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
WRECKED YOUR WAY YOUR HAND- THE
USE TO RAISE YOUR HAND FUTURE
IN THE PROGRAM AND WHEN YOU-
SO. BUT HE'S NOT HERE YET SO-
IN ORDER TO ALLOW FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THESE TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOWING WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHICH
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WANT OUTSIDE
NOW. CITIES PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO
SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS TWO NINE SEVEN
FIVE NINE EIGHT NINE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO
TALK PROVINCES TIME WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO ACCOUNT THE
SENATE. INDOOR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WE MOVED PUBLIC COMING
BE PROMPTED THE MODERATE TO
DIAL ONE THEN IS. FOUR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU. A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR
THEY'LL CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER
AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE UN
NEUTERED YOU WILL NOW BE READY
TO. ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AVOID WHOSE TO
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
I'LL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DESTRUCTIVE AB REMOVING THE
REMOTE HE MEETING SERVICE OR
RATHER CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESS A
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER AS A-
THERE MAY BE SOME TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW LINE- THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS ATTACK. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO CALL.
INTERESTED SO WE CAN ALL BE
HEARD SO WE'VE- ELEVEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S. WITH ONE BILL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- IN ORDER TO
GET THROUGH TO THESE CALDERON
ARE A LOT OF HEARING TIME
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL BE
LIMITED TO TEN MINUTES EACH.
WHICH INCLUDES THREE MINUTES
FOR LEAD WITNESS TESTIMONY IN
THE REMAINDER OF THE TIME FOR
ADDITIONAL CALLERS IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATIONS. ON THE BILLS-
WELL I'M SORRY WE DON'T YET
HAVE A QUORUM SO. LET'S JUST GO
AHEAD. IN START. WITH OUR- OUR
OUR ACCOUNT. WE ASK. THAT ARE
TO LET. WHO WE HEARD YOUR BILL.
ON MONDAY. BUT WE WERE A- TO
GET. CUP OF THE KIA- YOUR BILL.
THE AND I. WE'RE NOW IN A GOOD
PLACE. THE BILL AND APPRECIATE
YOUR- AND PATIENCE. WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND- ALSO PROJECT
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE FOR.
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU AND
RAISE THEIR CONCERNS TO MAKE
SURE THEY GET ADDRESSED. IN
YOUR BILL SO WITHOUT
UNDERSTANDING. I LOVE YOU TOO.
TO DO A I SHORTENED PRESS. OF A
SIX. TWO WILL NOT. BE MADE FOR
C. ONE RIGHT- THANK YOU. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF I WOULD
NOT BILL THE- SINCE WE HAD THE
BILL DISCUSS IN DEPTH- EARLIER
THIS WEEK. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE THE COMMITTEE BUT WE'RE
VOTING FOR. ON TODAY SENATE
BILL SIX SIX TWO ALLOWS FOR
INVESTOR OWNED GAS UTILITIES TO
INVEST. IN THE DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE HYDROGEN
TRANSPORTATION FUEL. IN ORDER
TO ACCELERATE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE TRANSPORTATION ONLY. IF
THOSE PROJECTS DID NOT RESULT
IN COST SHIFTS IN CUSTOMER
RATES. FOR RESULT IN A NET
INCREASE OF ENERGY SECTOR
EMISSIONS. IN ADDITION AS
MENTIONED BY THE CHAIR I HAVE
AGREED TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS. AS
REFERRED IN AND THE UPDATED
ANALYSIS ON PAGE SEVEN. THESE
AMENDMENTS ADD AN ADDITIONAL BY
METAL. GUARDRAIL AND ENSURE
THAT THE HYGIENE GOING INTO
THESE NEW INFRASTRUCTURE. MEET
OR EXCEED THE STATE'S CURRENT
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
AIR POLLUTION REDUCTION
STANDARDS. BY ALLOWING THE GAS
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES TO
BEGIN TO INVEST. IN HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE WE CAN BEGIN TO
ELECTRIFY SECTORS. THAT HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN HARD TO
ELECTRIFY FOR EXAMPLE THE
BUSES. THE TRUCKS THE FLEET
SUPPORT SHIPS. AND AVIATION AND
OTHER HEAVY DUTY SECTORS HAS
JUST NAME A FEW. SOME CONCERNS
WERE BROUGHT ON MONDAY AND I
WOULD LIKE TO. BRIEFLY ACT
ADDRESS THOSE. AS MEANT ON PAGE.
OF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS TWO
WEEKS AGO. IN THE SENATE ENERGY
COMMITTEE I ACCEPTED VERY AND-
AMENDMENTS. ONE APPROVAL WAS
ADDED THAT MANDATE. THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. COULD NOT APPROVE A
PROJECT THAT WOULD RESULT IN
COST SHIFT IN CUSTOMER RATES.
THIS NEW PROVISION ENSURES
THAT. ONLY TO PUT RATEPAYERS
WHOSE RAGE WOULD BE AFFECTED.
ARE THOSE WHO WOULD. DIRECTLY
BENEFIT FROM THE PROJECT.
ANOTHER ADDITIONAL PROVISION.
WAS ADDED THAT MANDATED THE CAL
PUBLIC YOU COMMISSION COULD
APPROVE ANY PROJECTS THAT
COVERS IN INCOME IN A- TO
ENERGY SECTOR. AND FINALLY AS I
MENTIONED IN MY OPENING TODAY.
I AM ACCEPTING THE FINAL
QUALITY COMMITTEE SO.
AMENDMENTS ON SEVEN OF THE-
WITH ALL THESE GUYS IN PLACE
FEEL WE- CRAFTED A BALANCE BILL
THAT WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA
START. ON A PATHWAY TO HYDROGEN
TRANSPORTATION FUTURE. IN AT
THE END OF THE DAY THIS BILL
ONLY- IS OPEN THE DOOR FOR THE
FUTURE WITH. I RESPECT ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR FIVE.
SO I THINK I THINK WE'RE WE'RE
JUST GONNA LET LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OKAY I DON'T SEE
ANYONE HERE OR IN TWENTY FORTY
WHO WANT TO. SPEAK IN PERSON
FOR THE PHONE LINES TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS
OR COMMENTS OF SUPPORTIVE AS
BEFORE NINETY FIVE. BUCKS RIGHT
SIX SIXTY TWO. MOTOR THANK YOU
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH SUPPORT FOR SB SIX SIX TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. AND ONCE CAN
AGENCY WANT TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SD SIX SIX TO PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND AT THIS TIME I
HAVE NO ONE IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU TO HAVE ANYONE- MODERATOR
YOU CAN CHECK. THAT FOR
OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL. I HI YES- AND THE
GERMAN IF YOU'LL SHOW TO OPPOSE
SB SIX TO PRESS ONE THAT THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME AND IF YOU
WANT TO OPPOSE SB SIX SIX TWO
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
TWENTY LINE NUMBER. EIGHT THE
STORE. MORE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MORNING
JIM CARMICHAEL ASSEMBLY. IN OF
SIX TWO. THE YOU. PFENEX. THE
NEXT TO GO TO LONDON SEVEN
EIGHT PLEASE AHEAD MR OFFICER
NINETY NINE ON THE OF THE AND
CAN ASSOCIATE AND I THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE NUMBER SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK WANTS TO MAKE
CLEAR ON BEHALF OF- JUSTICE IN
A MATCH BY CLUB TO REGISTER OUR-
WHAT AMEND. AND CONTINUE TO
COME THANK YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN
LAYS IN GERMAN IF YOU DO WISH.
OPPOSITION TO A. SIX SIX TWO.
PRESS ONE BUTTON AT THE. JUST
ONE MORE MOMENT. SUCH. PHOTOS
OF THE ONE. SORRY MOTOR. I
WOULD BE JUST ANOTHER. BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT. AND APART AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
LET'S FIRST ESTABLISH A QUORUM-
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HERE. ALLEN HERE.
BATES HERE BATES HERE DALLY
HERE DALLI HERE AND SALAS.
SKINNER SKINNER HERE STERN.
WHAT. THERE'S A QUORUM WELL AS
OKAY- SO WE DO HAVE A COURT
DATE YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH- WE
NOW HAVE THE ITEM BEFORE
COMMITTEE SO ME JUST OFF BY THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
COMMITMENT TO WITH THE KEY- THE
FLEXIBILITY. IN THE TIMING AT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE AS WE CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSION TODAY WE OBVIOUSLY
WANT TO BUDGET FOR THE- SO YOU
COULD. AND DO YOUR BUSINESS-
BUT- BOB ON MONDAY WE TALK
QUITE A BIT ABOUT HOW HIGH
ENERGY CAN BE A PART OF THE CAR
CAL IS A NO WORDS ARE DO THE
WORK ON THAT NUMBER OF A BILLS
OUR COLLEAGUE. CENTER SKINNER-
WE ALL TALKED ABOUT HOW THIS
BILL COULD CREE A ROLE FOR
COMPANY HELPING TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. I'M FROM THE DISCUSSION
ON MONDAY AT LEAST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE A FEW THINGS BECAME
CLEAR I WOULD LIKE TO PUSH THE
MARKET CALIFORNIA HOPEFULLY THE
WHOLE COUNTRY TOWARD THE
CLEANEST. AND LOWEST EMISSION
SOURCES OF HYDROGEN WHEREVER WE
CAN. AND YET OF COURSE OF.
EXACTLY WHAT THOSE CLEAN AND
BEST SOURCES. ARE IS STILL OVER
THE CONTENTIOUS TOPIC AND WE
ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PROJECTS ARE BEING FUNDED WITH
INAPPROPRIATE RATEPAYER
DOLLARS. THOUGH THAT YOU KNOW.
WE DID SOME FURTHER
INVESTIGATION IS REALLY WAS
ADDRESSING THE SENATE. ENERGY
COMMITTEE AS BELIEVES WITH
REGARDS TO RESIDENTIAL- SO WE A
REAL DISCUSS AROUND THE BILL. I
BELIEVE IN MY POINT- IN HOUSE
HAS BEEN- UPDATED TO A THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OF THE
AUTHORS AGREED TO. IN THE NEXT
MEMBER AYE I KNOW THAT ARE THAT
YOUR STAFF OF ADD THIS IN.
SHOULD WITH YOU. WE'RE ADDING
MORE. TO POSSIBLE REGRETTABLE.
IN THESE PARTS. ARE LIKE
TRANSPORTING HYDROGEN THE
DOESN'T MEET OUR CURRENT
CURRENT RENEWABLE AT EMISSION
STANDARDS. ARE WE KNOW THE
AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
DILIGENTLY ON THIS BILL GOING
FORWARD- ON ON BOTH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY CONCERNS
AND ALSO ON AFFORDABILITY
REPAIR CONCERNS- WE CERTAINLY
AFTER DEEP DIVE FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THE LANGUAGE
THAT THE ENERGY COMMITTEE. PUT
IN BUT I WE ARE ALREADY
ENGAGING IN CONVERSATION THIS
MORNING AND OBVIOUSLY THE OTHER
MAY WANT TO GO FURTHER- WITH
REGARDS TO. SOME OF THOSE SOME
OF THOSE ISSUES WITH REGARD TO
THE BILL- IF IT MOVES FORWARD
TODAY AND SO. AND ANYWAY WE-
NOT SURE. GUY I'VE COME TO
SUPPORTING THE BILL AFTER THE
WORK DAY WE'VE- DONE- I'M THEY
WERE GONNA DO YOUR OF THE
AUTHOR TO- TO TWO INCH THAT
WE'RE ALIGNING OUR STATE
HYDROGEN PLAN WILL OUR OVERALL
CLINICAL AND THAT'S. THAT'S
CERTAINLY OUR COMMITTEES BY
COURT. OF. WITH OVER TO THE
COMMITTEE GOT UNDERSTOOD- THANK
CHAIRED YOU- I WANTED TO JUST
CLARIFY QUICK IT DOES NOT
IMPACT RESIDENTIAL BUT IT DOES
IMPACT COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL- THE RATE PAYERS IS
THAT MY UNDERSTANDING I JUST
BILL'S BEEN SOMEWHAT CONFUSING
FOR ME TO FIGURE OUT- IF IT'S
ONLY APPLIES TO THE DEVELOPERS
AND THEY THEM AND THEIR FEES OR
IF IT DID IF IT APPLIES TO. THE
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL WHICH
HAPPENED UNDER THE ORIGINAL THE-
WHEN WE HAD THE BROWNOUTS
DURING THE GRAY DAVIS ARE THEY
THEY LEFT RESIDENTS ALONE BUT
THEY UP THE AMOUNT TO PAY OFF
THE DEBT. ON COMMERCIAL
RESIDENTIAL IS THIS BILL. NOT
TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO. PUT
RATES HIGHER FOR COMMERCIAL AND
INDUSTRIAL THIS IS LITERALLY
THE NEGOTIATION IS HAVING TO
THE AUTHOR AND THE PUBLIC AGAIN
SO I'M KIND OF CONFUSED ON
EXACTLY STUDIES OF A FIFTH
SENATE PLEASE SEND. PLEASE
RESPOND THANK YOU CENTER- I'M
I'D LIKE TO WORK AGAIN POINT
OUT THANK YOU FOR THE CHAIR
NUMBER ONE. FOR FOUR
PARTICIPATING WITH ME AND THE
REST THE COMMITTEE COULD MAKE
THIS THING. VIABLE AND GO
FORWARD THE DANCE YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR- AND I'VE GOT TO GIVE
YOU AN ILLUSTRATION ASSUMING
YOU KNOW THE INVESTMENT IS MADE
THE PIPES ARE LAID IN THE
HYDROGEN COMING THROUGH. WELL
YOU GOT TO SAY A SHELL STATION
ARE YOU HAVE A CHEVRON STATION
WHATEVER IT IS THAT'S GOING TO
PUT. THE PUMP THERE WELL THEN
YOU'VE CREATED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT THE
PROPRIETOR OF THAT STATION
ALONG WITH UTILITIES OVER JOINT
VENTURE. IN THE COST AND SO ON
OBVIOUSLY BUT IF YOU AND I
PURCHASED THE VEHICLE THEN WE
WILL BE PAYING AT THE PUMP. SO
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BECAUSE
IT NOW LET'S TAKE IT TO THE
NEXT LEVEL THEN WE'VE GOT
BECAUSE THE FUTURE IS TO GET
THESE TRUCKS AND BUSES AND- AND
DIESELS AND EVERYTHING. TO
START THINKING ABOUT HYDROGEN
SO WE HAVE THE PORTS OF LONG
BEACH HYPOTHETICALLY WELL IF
THEY WANTED TO HAVE THEIR PRIDE
XIN THEN YES HAT COMMERCIAL
ENTITY WOULD LIKE THE
PROPRIETOR WE TALK ABOUT WITH
JOINT VENTURE. TO PUT THOSE IN
SO THEY CAN CONSIDER A SUPPLY
OF THE MULTITUDE OF TRUCKS AND
SO ON. NOT NO NORMAL COMMERCIAL
NO RESIDENTIAL OR ANY WILL BE
INVOLVED ONLY THE RATE PAYER.
OR WHICH IS THE USER IN THIS.
CASE WILL BE THE ONE INVOLVED.
I FELT VERY. THE MILTON OUR
UNDER THAT A SHIP THERE IS ANY
SHIP ANYONE WHO'S NOT
BENEFITING RESIDENTIAL WORK BUT
BY IF WE NEED TO GET THIS THAT
WE MEAN TO BRING- ENVIRONMENT
THE ON ENERGY COMMITTEE BACK
IN- COME ALONG THE LINES OF IT
ARE YOU JUST DESCRIBE YOUR
RIGHT YOU CAN REMEMBER WHAT WE
IF YOU IF YOU'RE NOT USING THEN
YOU'RE NOT BENEFITING IF USING
YOUR BENEFITING AND IF YOU'RE
BENEFITING YOUR PAIN. THAT'S
THE DIFFERENCE. BOB THIS IS
GONNA PROBES AND- BUT I THINK I
THINK. I WOULD CERTAINLY
WELCOME AND THE PARTICIPATION
OF REPUBLICAN STAFF IN THAT
CONVERSATION W. AS WE- TRY TO
LOCK DOWN A LANGUAGE. BURKE BUT
I'M SORRY CENTER DOLLARS. IT'S
I'M LOOKING AT THE OPPOSITION
AND THAT'S THROUGH THE ROOM THE
IT WOULD ON I'VE TALKED
OPPOSITION THAT'S THE CONCERN
YEP THE ONLY CONCERN HERE I
DON'T I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THE BILL. UNLESS THERE'S
GOING TO BE THE ABILITY FOR
COMMERCIAL INDUSTRIAL WHICH IS
WHICH IS YOUR FARMER IT'S YOUR
THOSE ARE ENDED AND WE THEY'VE
BEEN PAYING THE BILL FOR THE
BAD DECISIONS AT THE STATE MADE
FOR A LONG TIME. AND THEN
RESIDENTIAL PEOPLE HAVE NOT HAD
TO PAY THAT BILL AND IT'S NOT
IT'S. IT'S NOT FAIR TO CONTINUE
TO. HELLO A BURDEN ON THEM WHEN
THEY DON'T GET ANYTHING BACK
FOR THE SERVICE THAT'S MY
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL SO I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IF IT IF
IT DOESN'T DO THAT. AND IT'S
REALLY ON THE DEVELOPER. THAT'S
WHAT I'M HEARING THE DEVELOPER
OF THIS PRODUCT WHICH I MEAN
FOR I LOVE HYDROGEN I THINK
THERE'S- A CLEAR NEED THE
PIPELINE FOR. BUT IT'S- PAYS
FOR AT THE END IF IT'S THE- IF
IT'S GOING TO BE. THE
INDUSTRIAL FOLKS AND ME SEAT
OPPOSITION IT'S TO AGRICULTURAL
AGRICULTURE ENERGY COMMISSION
BECAUSE THOSE FOLKS PAY. THAT
AMOUNT THEIR INDUSTRIAL- IN ANY
IS. SO ANYWAY I I'M GONNA. I
GOTTA GO CHECK INTO SO WE GET A
CORPSMAN SUB TO AND ALL TRY TO
GET A LITTLE BIT MORE
INFORMATION GO AHEAD AND- MOVE
FORWARD. GIVE HER A BATH YEAH I
WAS JUST GOING TO SAY I'M I'M
GONNA SUPPORT IT TODAY AGAIN
FURNITURE ARCHULETA BECAUSE I
KNOW I REALLY. THINK THAT THE
FUEL CELL HI IS A VERY
IMPORTANT CONCEPT TO BRING IN
TWO. THOUSAND JOBS BUT I DO
THINK THAT THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE IT KEEPS COMING BACK WE
ALMOST NEED A LIST OF WHO WOULD
HAVE TO PAY BECAUSE YOU'RE
GETTING THE PIPES TO THE GAS
STATION OR WHATEVER. HE HAD A
CHEVRON- YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENT
TOP COMPANY SO I THINK YOU
REALLY NEED TO WORK HARD ON
THAT AND SINCE I AM ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALSO. OF ALL BE
ASKING THAT QUESTION AND SEEING
IF THEY COUNT. GET A CLUE I
THINK A- OR- DURING. ANDERSON
OF WHO ARE HISPANIC AND THROUGH
THE WHAT THE IS AND I THINK I
THINK WE'LL GET THERE I GUESS
IS WHAT I'M SAYING SO I WAS I
MEAN TO SUPPORT IT AGAIN TODAY
THAT AS WE GET TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE NEED HAVE
MORE CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU
BUT I WANT TO HELP YOU MOVE IT
ALONG. YOUR OKAY- I HEARD THE
MAGIC WORD MOVES. ALONSO CENTER
VIEWER IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
HE OF IT THANK YOU MISTER IN AS
WE GO ALONG FOR OUR EDUCATION
ALL OF US REMEMBER THERE'S
GOING TO BE PRODUCTION- BILLS
ALONG THE WAY DISTRIBUTION OF
MISTER INFRASTRUCTURE AS THIS
ONE IS FUELING AND RETAIL THESE
ARE ALL SEGMENTS IT WILL BE
LOOKING AT IN THE FUTURE. THIS
ONE IS JUST A DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND I APPRECIATE
THE CHAIRS INVOLVEMENT ABOUT TO
MOVE THIS ALONG AND I
PERSONALLY ASK YOUR RIVAL. OKAY
GOOD SO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL IS
A PASSED FOR PRE. ITEM NO ONE
SB SIX SIX TWO BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALAN. TIME ALLEN
AYE BATES AYE AIDS AYE AND
GALLEY. GONZALEZ SKINNER. STERN
BY CAL SKI. THE TO READ THIRTY
RETROFITTING LEAVE IN A CALL.
THANK YOU MEDICARE I MEASURE
AND THANK YOU THIS HI HIGHS
THAT CALLS HERE. FOR TWO THIRDS
OF THE GROUP I DON'T VIEW OF
THE ROLAND SIX SIXTY TWO THAT
HI SALLY I. READ ZERO OKAY.
FIFTY SOME GRIEF. OKAY LET'S
NOW GO TO- TO SENATOR DODD
DISCUSSES CENTER DIED. TALK
ABOUT SOME MORE MOVING FROM
HIGH TO WALK SO IT'S A PER WERE
PUT IN THE R. FOR DOUBLING THE
HYDROGEN FOR IN THE OX SO HERE
WE ARE I'M A CHEMIST MACAM. ALL
RIGHT SO WAS DOG A PRESENT TO
BILLS SB TWO TWO TWO AND TWO TO
THREE. AND- YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN-
WHEN PERFECTLY SANITIZED. SURE
I FEEL PERFECTLY SANITIZED THIS
POINT TIED UP. WE TALK ABOUT
THAT LATER. THE YOU MAY RECEIVE
HONOR I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS- S. B. TWO TWO TWO
WOULD ESTABLISH THE WATER READ
ASSISTANCE FUND YEAH THE WATER
RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM TO HELP
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE FOR BOTH
DRINKING AND WASTEWATER
SERVICES TO LOW INCOME
RATEPAYERS EXPERIENCING
ECONOMIC HARDSHIPS. WELL BEGIN
BY ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT ON PAGE TWELVE OF THE
ANALYSIS. AS SOME OF YOU MAY
RECALL I AUTHORED LEGISLATION
AB FOUR ONE ASKING THE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD TO
STUDY THE LOGIN ISSUE OF LOW
INCOME WATER RESISTANCE I
PROGRAM LIRAS FOR SHORT BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. THE
BOARD'S DONE THAT YET SB TWO
TWO TAKES THE NEXT STEP OF
BELIEVE FOR TO ENACT A WATER
LITERATURE. IN ADDITION TO
COMPLETING THE WATER LABOR
STUDY THE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD RECENTLY SURVEYED
HUNDREDS COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS AROUND THE STATE TO
TURN TO DETERMINE JUST HOW MUCH
WATER DAD WATER SYSTEM
CUSTOMERS. WERE- ACCRUING. THE
SURVEY WE ARE SOBERING HERE ARE
SOME EXAMPLES OF HOW SERIOUS
THE PROBLEM WATER
UNAFFORDABILITY HAS BECOME.
OVER ONE AND A HALF MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS ARE BEHIND ON THEIR
WATER BILLS THAT'S OVER FIVE
BILLION PEOPLE STRUGGLING TO
PAY FOR CLEAN SAFE DRINKING AND
WASTEWATER. 12% OF CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE DEAD OF AT
LEAST FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS IT
MORE THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF THESE
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE DEBT GREATER
THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CUMULATIVELY CALIFORNIANS OF
ACCRUED ABOUT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN WATER DAD AND THAT
NUMBER IS INCREASING AT AROUND
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER
MONTH. IT TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
PRE PANDEMIC OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ALREADY
LOST THEIR WATER SERVICE DUE TO
AN INABILITY TO PAY THEIR WATER
BILLS. THAT NUMBER HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED DURING
THE PANDEMIC WATER RATES HAVE
BEEN RISING FASTER THAN ANY
OTHER UTILITY CHARGE FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT ANNOUNCES PLAN TO
RAISE ITS- RATES BY MORE THAN
9% EACH YEAR. FOR THE NEXT
EIGHT YEARS. GROWING WATER DEBT
IS ALSO A PROBLEM FOR WATER
SYSTEMS SOME WATER SYSTEMS HAS
LOST AS MUCH AS 30% OF THE
REVENUE. AND MORE THAN A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS ARE FACING
FINANCIAL COLLAPSE DUE TO THE
INABILITY OF THEIR CUSTOMERS TO
PAY THEIR WATER BILLS.
CALIFORNIA HAS LOW INCOME RATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
ELECTRICITY. AND NATURAL GAS
UTILITIES. NOT WITHSTANDING THE
STATE POLICY THAT AL ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE ACCESS TO
CLEAN AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER. THERE IS NO COMPARABLE
WATER RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
FOR PUBLICLY OWNED A COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS. IT'S ABOUT TIME
WE HAVE A STATE WIDE ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR PEOPLE WHO STRUGGLE
TO PAY FOR DRINKING AND
WASTEWATER S. B. TWO TWO TWO IS
A NARROW IT'S NARROWED ITS
FOCUS ON DIRECT WATER
RESISTANCE WATER CRISIS
ASSISTANCE AND RENTER'S
CREDITS. THE BILL REQUIRES THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES DEPARTMENT
TO DEVELOP AN EXPENDITURE PLAN
THAT WOULD IDENTIFY THE FUNDING
NEEDS FOR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES HAVE LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THIS BILL DOES NOT
IDENTIFY FUNDING SOURCE FOR THE
REDUCE SYSTEMS PROGRAM THAT IS
A PARALLEL CONVERSATION IT'S
BEGINNING TO TAKE PLACE. GOOD
FAITH NEGOTIATIONS WERE TAKING
PLACE BETWEEN THE STAKEHOLDERS
IN MY TEENS AND SEVERAL KEY
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN ALREADY
BEEN MADE SUCH AS NARROWING THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL NO LONGER
REQUIRING THE COLLECTION OF
WATERY DATA FOR EACH WATER
AGENCY. AND PLACING
ADMINISTRATIVE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THE WATER LARA PROGRAM WITH
THE COMMUNITY SERVICES
DEPARTMENT. WELL THE MEMBERS
HAVE ADDRESSED SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS RAISED BY STAKEHOLDERS
I KNOW THERE'S MORE TO WORK ON
AND I'M COMMITTED TO DOING
THAT. I'M ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE TO CONTINUE THE
DISCUSSIONS TO GET THIS LONG
OVERDUE PROGRAM ESTABLISHED ON
THE PHONE IS JONATHAN NELSON
FROM THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER. AND NIKITA KHARADI FROM
IN OUR DC I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
CRITICALLY NEEDED PROGRAM THANK
YOU. FOR THE SENATOR AND SO
IT'S GOING. TO YOUR NEARLY
WITNESSES. IT'S AND AN- WE KICK.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK
CERTAINLY. JONATHAN NELSON IT
WITHOUT WATER CENTER AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION THAT FIGHTS. WAS
MAKING THE POINT WATER CALL
CALIFORNIANS ALSO HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY WORKS HERE- IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB Q. TWO TWO
WHICH WOULD FINALLY PUT IN
PLACE A FRAMEWORK FOR A
STATEWIDE LOW INCOME WATER
REDUCES IN PROGRAM. THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL FOR US WE
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING TO ADDRESS
THIS LONG STANDING GAPS AROUND
THE LACK OF A PROGRAM THAT
REACHES ALL CALIFORNIANS THAT
NEED IT FOR SO MANY YEARS I
MEAN IT HAS MISTER DAUGHTER HE.
SHARED RIGHT WELL BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC JUST DRAWING ATTENTION
TO IT- AND- OUR WATER
PORTABILITY CRISIS- FOR YEARS.
WE WORK WITH FAMILIES THAT HAVE
TO CHIU THE- WATER AND OTHER
BASIC THAT SET. AT THE END BY
JOBS ORGANIZER- IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR US TO DRAW ATTENTION TO THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS THAT
THIS CRISIS BRING TO
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THE
CORRECT THAT THE MATTER BE
KICKED OUT THAT THE NEXT WEEK
BUT- THIS IS- ISSUE THAT
AFFECTS EVERY DISTRICT IN THE
STATE IT HURTS URBAN AND RURAL.
COMMUNITIES ALIKE WE APPRECIATE
ON THE TOP LEFT OF THE
FRAMEWORK ALSO THAT STRONG
PROVISION TO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION FROM ALL
STAKEHOLDERS CAN BE A PART OF
EVERY STEP OF THE PROCESS. WE
THANK SENATOR DR CAMPAIGN THAT
THAT YOU TAKE THE REALLY
IMPORTANT. STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. LET'S GO TO. THANK
YOU MR TRYING NUMBERS CROWDED
WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL I DON'T NEED TO
STAND WITH OUR PARTNERS AT THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO TO TWO
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK SENATOR
DODD FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
WATER PORTABILITY ISSUES OVER
THE YEARS. HAVE YOU ALREADY
HEARD THE NEED FOR THE PROGRAM
IS SIGNIFICANT AND WHILE THERE
ARE PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO ASSIST
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS THE
BRIDE UTILITY BELT THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO STATEWIDE PROGRAM
TO ENSURE THAT STRUGGLING
FAMILIES CAN STAY CURRENT ON
THEIR BELTS WERE CENTRAL
DRINKING WATER AND SANITATION
SERVICES. WELL BEFORE THE
ECONOMIC DISRUPTION OF THE
PANDEMIC MILLION THE
CALIFORNIANS STRUGGLE TO PAY
WATER AND WASTEWATER BILLS THAT
ARE BECOMING INCREASINGLY
UNAFFORDABLE AND THE REASON
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS ONLY MADE
MATTERS WORSE FOR SHORT TERM
WATER DEBT RELIEF IS CRITICAL
BUT LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY
WITHIN WILL BE NEEDED TO WALK
AFTER THE CONNECTICUT OAK. SB
TWO TO RESPOND TO THE URGENT
NEED FOR ACTION AND WE COMMEND
SENATOR DODD FOR ADVANCING THAT
SPRING MARC BUT IT MIGHT BOTH
THE CAN BE COLLECTIVELY
CONTINUE EXPLORING STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDING OPTIONS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS SIMILARLY
CONSIDERING LEGISLATION TO
CREATE A LONG TERM BILL AND
PROGRAM AND ENERGY THEATER AND
ARNOLD PARTNERS ARE ACTIVELY
ADVOCATING FOR BOTH EMERGENCY
AND LONG TERM WATER ASSISTANCE
FUNDING FROM CONGRESS. BUT
HAVING A SOLID PROGRAM
STRUCTURE IN PLACE WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TO GET HELP OUT THE
DOOR QUICKLY FOR THESE REASONS
WE SUPPORT SB TWO TO TWO AND-
DRIVER TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANKYOU TO THEM ALRIGHT
SO LET'S NOW GO TO. I DON'T SEE
ONE HERE IN PERSON TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OR IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY LET'S NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES IF IS ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
RAISE- IT ONCE OF EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR US. TO PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION.
THANK YOU. ONE CAN MADE GENERAL
IF YOU WANT. SO FOR S. TWO TWO
TWO. PRESS ONE YOUR THIS TIME.
GOING TO GO LINE AND SEVEN
PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DANIEL BROADER BEHALF OF SKERIK
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING HEARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO SECURE ACCESS TO
GREET THE STING OF THE
NONPROFIT COMMUTING THE TRUCKS
CAN HE A GROUP OF THIRTY FOUR
METRE CALIFORNIA BASED COMPANY-
CHAMPIONING VIRTUALLY. OF WATER
SOLUTIONS THE CALIFORNIA. SDG.
NEXAVAR LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBER SASHA
MARTIN WITH THE INNER CITY
LAWCENTER- WATER INSECURITY
DRIVES HOUSING INSECURITY AND
HOMELESSNESS MARK STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR GOING TO
GO TO LINE NUMBER EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AEAD ASCHAM. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBER YOU CAN
SEE ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER
LONG PROPERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MEXICO BORDER LINE NUMBER FIFTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KEY ON COLUSA ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA COULD KEEP
RELIANCE ON OUR TEN MEMBER
WATERKEEPER ORGANIZATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT TO A LINE
NUMBER ONE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JAMIE CALLING BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT QUICKLY WITH THE
OTHERS TO QUEUE UP. JUST A FEW
MORE MOMENTS. THE APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE BECAUSE YOU MORE
MOMENT NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER
ONE OH SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING RESEARCHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS
JOSE SIGALA AND I SERVE AS A
CITY COUNCILMEMBER IN THE CITY
OF TULARE INTERNET COUNTY. I'M
CALLING IN MY SO CAPACITY AS A
COUNCILMEMBER CAL IN MY STRONG
SUPPORT THE SENATE BILL TWO TWO
TWO. THANK YOU. IN THE NEXT
ROOM TO GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CONSERVING DOLLARS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF CLEAN
WATER ACTION A BILL CO SPONSOR
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
IN THE NEXT ROOM TO GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE OR THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF HIS ROGER
DICKINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FOR THE NEXT
ONE TO GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTEENTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS HE
BURGEONING K. ON THE OFFICE
CENTRAL COAST ENERGY SERVICES.
FOR EACH INSTRUMENT OF LETTER
FROM THE COALITION OF TERM LIFE
INSURANCE RIDERS INTO COURT
THANK YOU. THE NUMBER OF NUMBER.
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MISTER TURNER PLAN TRY
ON BEHALF OF COTTON PRICE FOR.
NEXT GEN AND WATER. THANKS FOR
THE COURT THANK YOU. HE. THE
NEXT ONE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AARON RODRIGUEZ AT
UNION OF CONCERNED SCIENTISTS
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE NEW
MEXICO LINE NUMBER FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF SE HA IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE NUMBER FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
NICOLE HEIL CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE LOS ANGELES ALLIANCE FOR
A NEW ECONOMY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB TWO TWO TWO THANK YOU.
TEN MEXICO LINE NUMBER SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS BERNIE CAN I'M S. SENATE
DISTRICTS TWENTY FOUR RESIDENT
I MEAN JOHN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE NEXT ONE NUMBER FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS RACHAEL SANTANA ON
BEHALF OF POLICY LINK RACIAL
EQUITY ORGANIZATION BASED OUT
OF OAKLAND AND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXT WHEN
YOU GO TO LINE NUMBER ONE CAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JIM
WEINBERG ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION THAT
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS. MEXICO WOULD LINE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BERNIE
DAVIS AND I AM A RESIDENT OF
SENATE DISTRICT THIRTY NINE AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF ASKED ME TO DO TO. MAXLINEAR
LINE NUMBER ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SOON ENOUGH TO DO NOT.
WHEN ANDREA NUMBER ANY ENTITY
AND A LACK OF MONEY THAT
DIVERSITY SO I MANDATE I WOULD
LIKE THE SUBWAY LAST WON THE
SAID IN A QUALITY ON THAT I ONE
YOU KEPT BUGGING IS LAST YOUNG
EIGHT SAID MANDEL CAN PREVENT
YOU KNOW IT'S SAID THEY IN THE
INTERVENTI DAY INSTEAD SEVERAL
POLITICAL TRANSCEND STANDING.
GASEOUS. ANNEX WOULD LINE UP
ONE TWO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU YEAH. KATE AND THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITY
AND ASSOCIATION JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY ANYWAY IF NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL LOOKING
FORWARD TO REVIEWING THE- AND I
APPRECIATE THE WORK WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO DO WHAT THE. THAT'S
HUGE. NEXT RENEWAL ONE NUMBER
ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH THIS I NEED THIS IS RACHEL
MOST AMERICA AND IN SUPPORT OF
REPEATING THE CLEAN AIR
COALITION. THANK YOU. IN THE
NEXT TWENTY ONE NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
UNDER WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NO RELY NUMBER TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
COMMITTEE CHAIR INCLUDING
MEMBERS- MY NAME IS DANIEL
DANIELS- WITH THE COMING OF THE
COMMUNITY WATER HEATERS NETWORK
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY SEVEN
MEMBERS FROM THE EQT'S CITY
COUNCIL SOMEONE BOARD OF
SUPERVISOR- IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND FULL SUPPORT. OUR
MODERATOR WE- THE SUPPORTS HAVE
NOW REACHED THEIR TIME LIMIT SO
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE NOW TO
THE- THE PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SIR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE KEEP THEM UP MODERATOR.
THANK YOU. AND LADIES IN GERMAN
JUST ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THIS
WILL TAKE ME JUST A FEW MORE.
MAYES JIM APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE THE TWO OFFICIALS OF
OPPOSE THE SPEECH TO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE FOR
WHAT ARE. KAREN THIS IS CINDY
TECH COME PREPARED TO SPEAK.
OUR MODERATOR DIDN'T WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES KEY WITNESSES WHO
WERE IN OPPOSITION YES JUST ONE
OKAY WILL YOU PLEASE ALLOW
THAT- WITNESS TO PROCEED AND
THEN WE'LL MOVE TO THE REGULAR
ME TO USE BUT THIS IS OUR LEGAL
MY OPPOSITION WITNESS. BY
POLICIES PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU ON. THIS IS CINDY TECH WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES AWKWARD HAS
IMPOSED UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON SB TWO TWO TWO WE THINK THAT
THERE CAN BE A GOOD LOW INCOME
RATE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
WATER. ILL US STILL NEEDS WORK
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT SENATOR DODD
MADE IN THE APRIL TWENTY
VERSION AND IN PARTICULAR THE
CONVOCATION IN ARTICLE ONE
REGARDING THE ALLOWED USES OF
THE FUND. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
THAT SENATOR DODD IS AMENDING
THE BILL TO DELETE THE PROPOSED
RATE DATA COLLECTION PROVISIONS.
WE DO THINK THAT ADDITIONAL
CHANGES ARE NEEDED OR JUST GIVE
TWO EXAMPLES TODAY. ONE IS THAT
THE BILL NEEDS AN APPROPRIATE
IN PROGRESSIVE FUNDING SOURCE.
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO FUNDING
SOURCE PROPOSED IN THE BILL.
AND THEN SECOND ALL RIGHT NOW
THE BILL PROPOSES THAT BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT IN THE
STATE WATER BOARD WITH APPROVED
THE FUND EXPENDITURE PLAN WE
SUGGEST THAT THE IMPLEMENTING
AGENCY THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
APPROVE THE PLAN. AND THAT
WOULD BE A CHANGE ON PAGE FIVE
ONE TEN. WE THINK THAT- WITH
MORE WORK SB TWO TWO TWO COULD
BE A GOOD LOW INCOME MODERATE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. AND WE DO-
IN MY FINAL COMMENT IS THAT WE
DO CONCUR WITH COMMON FOR IN
THE ANALYSIS THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AND WE THINK THAT THE
COMMITTEES CONTINUED
INVOLVEMENT WOULD BE HELPFUL.
AND ON A CLOSING. PARKWAY
APPRECIATE THE- OFF SENATORS
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT. THAT CONCLUDES
MY TESTIMONY AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND NOW OUR MODERATOR YOU CAN
ASK IF THERE ARE ANY- ME TOO
WITNESSES WHO WANT TO ADD ON TO
THEIR OPPOSITION. TO S. B. TWO
TWO TWO. THANK YOU AND ONCE
AGAIN THE GENERAL IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB ONE TWO TWO
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. TWENTY FOUR LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING SHARE A
MEMBERS LOUNGE JIM LEACH OF
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
SERVING A HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS IN SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY WE STAND OPPOSED
TO THE BILL OF LAST MINUTE
FURTHER. THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
I. NEVER GONNA OWN BOTTOM LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU JERRY MEMBERS
THIS IS ANTHONY TEMAS MELODY
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION ORALLY OR OPPOSE
THE MOST AMENDED OUTLINING OUR
COMMENTS WITH AQUA THANK YOU.
NOGGIN THE LINE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU TURN NUMBER ACTUALLY
WALKER ON BEHALF OF HYDRATE DAM
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT AND A
LEAVING HINA WATER DISTRICT.
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED AND
ALIGN OUR COMMON AQUA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE NUMBER ONE TWELVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME DENIS
ALBION IN REPRESENTING THE
QUALITY YOU TELL YOU KILL THESE
DISTRICTS. IN THE MESA WATER
DISTRICT PROPOSAL IS A MENACE
OF CEDAR COMMONS LAUGHLIN'S.
THANK YOU. I NUMBER LINE NUMBER
ONE THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS THOMAS CARS OVER THE
BALKAN GROUP ON BEHALF OF OUR
CLIENT THE CITY PRESS NOW WITH
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION. THANK YOU. NO GOOD
LINE NUMBER ONE THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
PAULA GALLAGHER WITH THE SAN
JUAN WATER DISTRICT AND WE HAVE
AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION CONSISTENT WITH
AWKWARD. WATER IT ARE THERE ANY
REMAINING. YES THERE ARE A FEW
STILL IN CUBA JUST A MOMENT
NEXT ONE LINE NUMBER ONE
FIFTEEN IS GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING REALLY LOCUSTS ON
BEHALF OF ONE OF OUR WATER
DESTRUCTION WE ARE OPPOSED TO
MY CEMENTED THANK YOU. AND NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
NUMBER ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS CITY HALL WITH A RESOLUTE ON
BEHALF OF THE IRVINE RANCH
WATER DISTRICT AND THE EAST
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO TWO TWO
UNLESS AMENDED. THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
HANNAH DAVIDSON ON BEHALF OF
THE HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE
COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT WE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED INTO LINE
WITH AQUA THANK YOU. MEXICO
LINE NUMBER SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DON CITY BUT I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE INDIAN WELLS
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN OUR
DISTRICT WHICH IS TO GO ON
RECORD AS OPPOSING S. B. TWO
TWENTY THREE AM OF SOME AND TO
MAKE YOU LAUGH POLICE- ALL
THOSE CALLERS PLEASE JUST NAME
ENTITY AND THAT YOU OPPOSE. OR
WILL RUN OUT OF TIME. GO AHEAD
MODERATOR. YES NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINETY
NINE TEN ON BEHALF OF AMONG THE
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION. NUMBER ONE NUMBER
ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL PROPER SENIOR I WAS SO
KIND OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
DISTRICT IN THE CENTRAL SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND I WILL. OKAY
MODERATOR NAKED HEALTH. WELL
THE LINE NUMBER FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
MARCUS BLACKLIST REAL ALTO
WATER DISTRICT- OUR AGENCY
OPPOSES ANALYZE SENTIMENT AT.
SENATE THIS TIME I HAVE NO
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU AND I
FEEL TO LOOK AND SEE IF THERE
WAS ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO
WANTED TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. OKAY SEEING NONE
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE- DECENT
ROOM SEEING NINE WITH THE NOW
HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION SO
LET ME TURN TO OUR MEMBERS OR
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS THAT
OUR MEMBERSHIP YES SENATOR
CONSULTS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
I JUST WANT TO THANK SENATOR
DODD FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I THINK THIS MAKES COMPLETE
SENSE LONG OVERDUE ESPECIALLY
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
WANT TO THANK YOU- AND OF
COURSE SOME- PROD CO AUTHOR AND
I HOPE THAT YOU KNOW WE CAN
CONTINUE WORKING TOGETHER TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
HAS AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
THANK YOU. THE BILL
INAPPROPRIATE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS- GO AHEAD
SENATOR DODD YOU MAY CLOSE I
JUST RECEIVED THE-
CONVERSATION- THE FIRST TIME
THIS THEY WANT TO KEEP- IT-
COMMITTEE- THERE WAS- PROBABLY-
MORE THAN TWENTY MINUTES-
OPPOSITION AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO REALLY WORK OUT WITH THE
GREAT HELP OF CONSULTANTS WHO-
TOOK A LOOK AT THIS BILL- IT
MADE SOME IMPROVEMENTS SO I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BOOK.
GREAT WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR GONZALEZ IT IS. BUT WE
DON'T HAVE QUORUM YOU'RE RIGHT
WE HAVE TO HOLD THE STAKES. WE
NEVER ESTABLISHED IT- AND WE
CAN'T. HELP BUT CAN'T EVEN IF
WE DON'T HAVE QUORUM WE CAN
TAKE A VOTE AND OUT ON RATE IF
WE ESTABLISH QUORUM INITIALLY.
AFTER OKAY GREAT SO WE
ESTABLISH FORM WE DON'T HAVE IT
NOW HOWEVER WE CAN TAKE A VOTE
BUT WE WILL THEN LEAVE IT ON
CALL. SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THIS IS- DO PASSED AS AMENDED
WITH THE COMMITTEES IMMENSE.
AND YOU'VE ACCEPTED THOSE. AND
SO WITH THAT WE WILL DO A ROLL
CALL. I KNOW NUMBER TWO SP TWO
TWO TWO BY SENATOR DODD THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ALLEN BATES
DALLY DALY NO GONZALEZ HI I WAS
AYE SKINNER ALL RIGHT INNER
THIGH STERN WHY CAO SKI. ALL
RIGHT THE BILL'S ON CALL AND-
BUT YOU HAVE ANOTHER BILL 2%
CORRECT SENATOR DODD ALL RIGHT
SO PLEASE PROCEED WITH-
PRESENTING S. B. TWO TO THREE-
MANAGER MEMBERS S. B. TWO TO
THREE STRENGTHENS. IT EXTENDS
EXISTING STATUTORILY REQUIRED
PROTOCOLS AND PROCEDURES TO
PROTECT LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
THAT ARE FACING WATER SERVICE
DISCONNECTIONS DUE TO THE WATER
CUSTOMERS INABILITY TO PAY THE
WATER BILL. ONCE AGAIN I'M
ACCEPTING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE TEN OF THE
ANALYSIS. ADDITIONALLY I WANT
TO KNOWLEDGE THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED ON PAGE ELEVEN
PERTAINING TO PROHIBITIONS ON
MULTI TENANT BUILDING SHUT
OFFS. I COMMIT TO WORKING WITH-
THE CHAIR IN YOUR CONSOLE TO
CRAFTED MA'AM IT'S THE PUT SOME
LIMITS ON THAT PROHIBITION.
STREAMLINED THE ABILITY OF
ATTENDED TO ASSUME
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE WATER
BILL FOCUS ON LOW INCOME
TENANTS IF POSSIBLE GIVE WATER
AGENCIES THAT ADDITIONAL
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISMS I GET TO
SCOFFLAW LANDLORD. I WILL
REPEAT THE SOBERING FINDINGS TO
THE WATER BOARD SURVEY ON WATER
DEBT I HIGHLIGHTED JUST. IN S.
B. TWO TWO TWO TWO LET'S JUST
SAY THOSE FINDINGS ILLUMINATED
A PROBLEM WHICH HAS BEEN
GETTING WORSE FOR YEARS. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I AUTHORED SB
NINE NINE EIGHT WHICH ADDRESSED
THE PROBLEM WATER SHUT OFFS.
SOME CRITICS OF SB TWO TO THREE
ARE ASKING WHY WE NEED THIS
BILL IN LIGHT OF S. B. NINE
NINE EIGHT. THE ANSWER IS TWO
FOLD. FIRST AS WATER DEBT IS
DEEP IN THE PROBLEM PEOPLE AT
LOSING ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER WASTEWATER. HAS REACHED
CRISIS PROPORTIONS. SECOND THE
FINAL VERSION OF SB NINE NINE
EIGHT REFLECTED MANY
COMPROMISES THAT I MADE TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS BY THE
OPPONENTS. SB TWO TO THREE IS
INTENDED TO FILL SOME GAPS LEFT
BY THE FINAL VERSION OF S. B.
NINE NINE EIGHT FOR EXAMPLE.
KERN SHUT OFF PROTECTION IS
LIMITED TO WATER SYSTEMS WITH
TWO HUNDRED OR MORE
CONNECTIONS. S. B. T. TWO THREE
PROPOSED TO INCLUDE SMALLER
WATER SYSTEMS IT PROTECTION
PROTOCOLS. CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
FOR BORDER AGENCIES TO SHUT OFF
THE WATER WHEN THE REPAIR IS
THE ONLY GOOD FOR SIXTY DAYS.
FRANKLY THAT'S A TIGHT TIMELINE
FOR A LOW INCOME WATER
HOUSEHOLD TRYING TO FIND ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR EVEN FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. TO CATCH UP ON
THEIR THEIR CURRENT BILL. YEAH
I WAS A PRIVATE CONTRACTOR- DID
IN IT IN THE WATER BUSINESS
AND- YOU KNOW JUST KNOWING. HE
SIXTY DAYS IS JUST NOT ENOUGH
FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO CATCH
UP REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE
PUBLIC WATER SUPPLY A PRIVATE
WATER SUPPLY OR EVEN A
COMMERCIAL VENTURE. YES BE TWO
TO THREE AS AMENDED GIVES A
WATER RATEPAYERS NINETY DAYS OR
WHEN THE RATEPAYERS ACCUMULATED
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS IN
DEBT. BEFORE SHUT OFFS COULD
COMMENCE. THERE ARE SEVERAL
OTHER SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO
CURRENT LAW MADE BY S. B. TWO
TWO THREE BUT I WANT TO ADDRESS
WHAT. MIGHT BE THE MOST
CONTROVERSY CONTROVERSY ALL
PROVISION. AND THAT IS DEBT
FORGIVENESS. THE INTRODUCED
VERSION OF THE BILL REQUIRED
WATER SYSTEMS TO OFFER INDEBTED
LOW WATER LOW INCOME RATEPAYERS
IN A REPAIR REAR H. MANAGEMENT
PLAN. SB TWO TO THREE AMENDED
THE RIG. OF ADS YES LET ME
START OVER ON THAT ONE SB TWO
TO THREE AS AMENDED REQUIRED
THE WATER SYSTEMS TO MAKE
FINDINGS ON THE RECORD THAT
THEY HAVE NO OTHER AVAILABLE
RESOURCES TO FORGIVE THE DEBT.
THERE IS NO LONGER MANDATE IN
THE BILL THE WATER AGENCY MUST
USE NOT REPAIR REVENUE FURTHER
RESEARCH MANAGER PLAN IF THE
AGENCY HAS A HIGHER PRIORITY
USE. WHERE NON REPAIR FUNDS ARE
AVAILABLE IN THE REAR. AND A
REAL RICH- MANAGEMENT PLAN
WOULD BE OFFERED. ONE FINAL
POINT SB TWO TO THREE NOT ONLY
PROTECTS STRUGGLING REPAIRS BUT
WHEN COMBINED WITH WATER
LITERATURE ALSO PROTECTS THE
SMALL WATER SYSTEMS THEMSELVES.
IN THE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS I
MENTIONED IT TO ARE IN A
PRECARIOUS FINANCIAL CONDITION-
BY PRESERVING THEIR REVENUE
FLOW. AS WE TO THERE'S MORE
WORK TO BE DONE ON THIS BILL
YEAH I'M COMMITTED TO DOING SO
WE'RE LISTENING TO THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN IMPROVING THE
BILL WITH EVERY WORKING SESSION
I ASK FOR AND I'VE VOTE ON THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILL. ON
THE PHONE IN MY KEY WITNESSES
MICHAEL CLAIBORNE AND LAURA
FEINSTEIN THANK YOU FOR OUR
MODERATOR LET'S START WITH
THOSE- WITNESSES LEAD WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF FOOTWEAR BORN AND
MISS FEINSTEIN. AND- THE T.
WHAT I'M TRYING TO CHOI WITH
OUR TIME LIMITED ON FOR AT
LEAST WITNESSES. FIVE THREE
MINUTES SO PLEASE INTERVIEW
MAKE SURE TO ACCOMMODATE SO
THAT YOU DON'T CUT OUT ANOTHER
STEIN GO AHEAD MOTOR. YOUR LINE
SHOULD BE ALL BUT. ACCORDING TO
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S MICHAEL
CLAIBORNE- DIRECTING ATTORNEY
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNSEL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE NONPROFIT WORKING
ALONGSIDE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN IT CONTROL OF ALEX.
CALIFORNIA DECLARED ACCESS TO
AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY OF SAFE
DRINKING WATER OR HUMAN RIGHT
IN TWENTY TWELVE BUT THE
REALITY REMAINS THE ACT THAT
THE TAP WATER IS NOT UNIVERSAL
IN THAT STATE. VERY
CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATE IS THAT
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE LOST ACCESS TO WATER IN
BOTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TO THE WATER SHOPS.
THE STATEWIDE PROBLEM BECAUSE
SOME AREAS ARE HIT HARDER THAN
OTHERS THE HIGHEST RATES OF
UTILITY DEBT PUTTING FAMILIES
AT RISK OF SHUT OFF ARE IN LOS
ANGELES SANTA MARIA RANCHO
CORDOVA HOLDEN BELL GARDENS.
NORWALK IN CYPRUS. THIS IS AN
INEQUITABLE SYSTEM PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE HIT HARDEST WITH
BLACK FAMILIES TWICE AS LIKELY
AS WHITE. WATER SHOP SHOP. SB
TWO TO THREE WOULD HELP BY
EXTENDING AND STRENGTHENING
WATER SHUT UP PROTECTIONS TO
ENSURE THAT SHOPS ARE USED ONLY
AS A LAST RESORT. SALI WHEN
APPLIED TO LOW INCOME AND
VULNERABLE HOUSEHOLDS. ONE
ISSUE FLAGGED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IS THE PROPOSED- A
PROHIBITION ON MULTI FAMILY
SHOPS AT PRACTICE THAT IMPACTED
AT MINIMUM SIXTY SEVEN HUNDRED
MULTI FAMILY BUILDINGS AND THE
STATE AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
DISASSEMBLE ATTENDANT SHOULD
NOT THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN LOSE ACCESS CENTRAL
DRINKING WATER SERVICE BECAUSE
THEIR LANDLORD FAILED TO PAY
WATER BILL. WATER SYSTEMS CAN
USE OTHER MECHANISMS TO COLLECT
FROM PROBLEM LANDLORDS
INCLUDING LEANS COLLECTIONS FOR
PROPERTY TAXES REFERRAL PRIVATE
COLLECTION AND COLLECTIONS ARE
THE COURTS. WATER SYSTEMS LIKE
YOU'VE BEEN UNIT WILL DISTRICT
ALREADY PRE PROHIBIT MULTI
FAMILY SHOPS AND OTHERS LIKE
LADWP SHUT UP MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS ONLY VERY RARELY.
PROTECTING TENANTS FROM SHUT
OFF AS POSSIBLE AND IT'S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. WE ASK. THAT
THE COMMITTEE ENSURE THAT THE
STATE IS DOING EVERYTHING IT
CAN TO ENSURE THAT CHILDREN DO
NOT GROW UP IN HOMES THAT HAVE
NO. OR ONLY SPORADIC ACT THAT
THE TAP WATER AND ESSENTIAL
SERVICES CRITICAL TO HEALTH
SANITATION AND CHILD
DEVELOPMENT. JUST A CLOSE LOOK
THANK THE SENATOR DODD FOR
LEADERSHIP. ON THAT ISSUE. AND
THE CHAIRING MANY STAFF FOR
WORKING TO IMPROVE THE BILL AND%
ASCARI BOAT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND- MS- FEINSTEIN YOU HAVE
A MINUTE TWENTY SECONDS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON TO
THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
EMBARKED FEINSTEIN
SUSTAINABILITY RESILIENCE
POLICY DIRECTOR AT HER. THANK
GOD HE WATER IS ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH AND HAVE
YOU HEARD FROM SENATOR DODD OF
ONE POINT SIX MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS ARE BEHIND ON THEIR
WATER VALVES CURRENTLY DURING
THE- RECESSION. UNDER CURRENT
POLICY MANY OF THOSE CUSTOMERS
WILL LOSE ACCESS TO WATER INTO
THE SHOP MARCH ARE IN THE LIST
AND- WE NEED TO ACT NOW TO A
CERTAIN EPIDEMIC WATER. SHUT
OFFS AMONG LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. MAN PLAN KILLER
HAVE BEEN USED WITH GREAT
SUCCESS BY UTILITIES IN OTHER
STATES THEY OFFER A BALANCED
APPROACH TO HANDLING CUSTOMER
UTILITY THAT. EVERY URGE
MANAGEMENT PLAN DOESN'T FORGET
THAT CONDITIONALLY RATHER FOR
QUALIFIED LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS
IT FORGET THE PORTION OF DEBT
IN EXCHANGE FOR ON TIME IN FULL
BILL PAYMENT. SHARES MANAGEMENT
PLANS WHEN TARGETED CUSTOMERS
WHO DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO REPAY THEIR DEBTS ARE IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF THE HOUSEHOLD
AND THE UTILITY THE CUSTOMER
GOING TO SHUT OFF AND THE
UTILITY RETAIN A PAYING
CUSTOMER. PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES
YOU COULD REPLICATE MANY
FINANCIAL OUTLOOK. BUT THERE'S
ONLY ONE ESSENTIAL PART OF
THEIR MISSION PROVIDING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
CALIFORNIANS WHO CANNOT PAY
THEIR WATER BILLS WHICH THEY
CANNOT PAY FOR OUT OF THE RACE
CARE ACT YEAH THIS BILL IS
ACTING WATER. IT'S REMARKABLE.
PLEASE WRAP UP OKAY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE COMMITTEE
FOR NINE THAT THANK YOU THANKS
SO MUCH ALL RIGHT MODERATOR
WILL NOW GO TO THE ME TOO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THAT MEANS
THAT THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
CALLING IN PLEASE JUST INDICATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
SUPPORT. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. EIGHTEEN
T. AFTER TO GIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE IN PLACE YOU
BACK INTO THE QUEUE. WE'LL
BEGIN- WITH FLYING SEVENTY
SEVEN MEN I'M SURE PLEASE GO
AHEAD SEVENTY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBER SASHA
HERNDON INNER CITY LAW CENTER
IN STRONG SUPPORT. BY TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'LL TRY
ONLINE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NUMBER OF SHARES TAX.
ECHO IN SHOCK SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MOVING ALONG WITH ONLINE
SEVENTY. GOOD MORNING DANIEL
BROUGHT IN THE APPS CARE CLUB
CALIFORNIA PART THANK YOU. PINE
EIGHTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN.
BECAUSE THE ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU LINE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MOVING
ALONG WITH A LINE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING
KISS ONE CLICK WELL ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S KEEPER LINES
AND A TEN MEMBER WATERKEEPER
ORGANIZATIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NINE FIFTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN.
FIFTY NINE PLEASE ON MUTE. NO
RESPONSE WILL TOTALING FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE MUTE YOUR LINE. ONE
SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS AT LEAST WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS SORRY
CANNOT NAME THE LEASE CONTRACT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ERIN ARE REJECTED UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE ZERO SIX
ONE OF SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JAMIE GOING TO
HAPPEN OUR MISSILE DEFENSE FUND
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY NINETY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WE ARE
ON THE PHONE OR WITH THE S. R.
NAY AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY WEARING SUPPORT.
BEGIN TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE FORTY NINE ONE
FORTY NINE YOUR OPEN. HELLO
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
BILLING- CALLING STRONG WORK.
THANK YOU ONE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FINANCIAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNSEL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
HUNDRED TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRENCH COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE ONE SEVENTEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
HELLO CHRIS HOLDEN LAWS ON
BEHALF OF HELLO WHERE DO SO AT.
YEAH THIS CONCLUDE DOLLARS ON
BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER ACTION
BILL COSPONSORED STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB TWO TWO TWO TWO TWO THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CAN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WELCOME FIND IN
EUROPE. WE CAN HEAR YOU LIKE
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SUPPORT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT
TEN. ASSEMBLY ALONG LITTLE
LINES FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LET'S NOW. BY FIFTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. LEVINE FIFTY FOUR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT. HOLDING ONE LITTLE
LINE ONE ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE ONE ELEVEN WE CAN HEAR YOU.
REALLY YEAH. FINAL ONE ELEVEN
YOU ARE OPEN. BUILDING ON WATER
ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY ONE TWENTY NINE. RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE TO. HELLO YES I WILL
BUY MORE FORTY SIX BY ONE TWO
NINE YEAR OLD. WE CAN HEAR YOU.
YEAH ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING BRITAIN
OKAY ON BEHALF OF CENTRAL COAST
ENERGY SERVICES AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE ONE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF SE HA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE ONE
FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS LAURA SAUNDERS I'M WITH
NOW SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE IN THE
CLEAN AIR COALITION IN SUPPORT.
ONE ONE FIFTY TWO YOUR OPEN.
NINE FIFTY ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE OH THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THREE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO SHOW PUBLIC SUPPORT.
BY. ONE OH THREE. BY ONE TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WANT
TWENTY NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SHOW YOUR SUPPORT. OKAY TO SHOW
OPPOSITION FOR SB TWO TO THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. A
SPECIAL OPPOSITION FOR S. B.
TWO TO THREE. BILLION THREE
HUNDRED IT'S ONE ZERO I'M SO
SORRY MODERATOR- WE NEED TO
FIRST YEAR THE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESS- THROUGHOUT THIS WOMAN
THIS IS DANIELLE BASSETT
HIDING. FROM CALIFORNIA MEAN
IT'S PRETTY CHILLY SUFFICIENT
AND ALSO CHRISTOPHER ANDERS
FROM THE SO CAL WATER. THANK
YOU- GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DANIEL HI BUT THE CALIFORNIA
UTILITIES GROUP AT THE CENTER
MAYOR RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED ON AT THE 223%
ONE I THINK THAT CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE THE AUTHOR IN THE- H.
METALWORKER. THE BILL HOWEVER
SEVERAL TROUBLING PROVISIONS
REMAIN AND I WILL FOCUS ON TO
TODAY. OUR FIRST WE CONTINUE TO
BE CONCERNED WITH THE LANGUAGE
REGARDING ARREARS MANAGEMENT
PLAN WHILE SOME OF THE
LANGUAGES ARE MENTIONED THAT
PROCESS DEVALUATION ON RATE
REVENUE AND OTHER REPORTS AND
SHOULD BE LEFT THE LOCAL
PROGRESSION. CANNOT BE A
REQUIREMENT AS PROPOSED IN SB
TWO TO THREE. BY CONTRAST THE
NEW VERSION OF THE BILL NO
LONGER REQUIRED HE ACTION TO BE
TAKEN BY TPC REGULATED
UTILITIES ONLY A REQUIREMENT
FOR THE- UC TO CONSIDER WHETHER
TO ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM.
IT WILL SEND SAID IF IT IS NOT
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF ALL
RATE PAYERS. IN ADDITION THIS
MORNING SENATE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE TO IS CONSIDERING A
PROPOSAL THAT INCLUDES ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR COVERT
NINETEEN RELATED WATER ELECTRIC
BILL OR AGENTS. THIS WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED RELIEF TO
RATEPAYERS NOTED IN IT IS A
BETTER APPROACH THAN THE
LANGUAGE AND HAVE BEAT YOU TO
THREE. SECOND JANUARY OF
NUMEROUS NUMBERS THAT ARE
COMBINED UTILITIES MEANING THAT
PROVIDE MULTIPLE SERVICES
INCLUDING WATER WASTE WATER AND
ELECTRICITY. OFTENTIMES BE
UTILITIES ARE ON ONE BILL WHICH
IS ATTENTION FOR BOTH THE
CUSTOMER AND THE UTILITY. S. B.
T. G. THREE INCLUDE THE
PROHIBITION. ON THE
DISCONTINUATION OF WATER
SERVICE IF THE CUSTOMER PAYS A
PARTIAL BILL EQUAL TO THE COST
OF THAT SERVICE. THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC AND UNNECESSARY IT
WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT IT MAY
BE LOGISTICALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO
SEPARATE OUT MULTIPLE SERVICES
AND IT IS UNFAIR TO OTHER
UTILITIES. IN FACT THIS COULD
MAKE PAYMENT FOR AT THE VERY
LEAST WASTEWATER SERVICE
OPTIONAL BECAUSE WASTEWATER
SERVICE CANNOT BE DISCONTINUED.
AND IMPORTANTLY ACCORDING TO
OUR MEMBERS IF A CUSTOMER
ENTERS INTO A PAYMENT PLAN FOR
OVER DEVELOP WITH MULTIPLE
COMPONENTS NO. SERVICES WILL BE
TERMINATED. BUSINESS SHOULD BE
DELAYED. AGAIN WE- AGAIN MY
RIGHT. THE GOVERNOR WORK AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WITH DODD AND-
ON BILL THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY. YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL
NEXT TO CHRIS FOR INTER. GREAT
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHRIS ANDERSON ON
pCALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES
RESPECT PROPOSITION OF THE BILL
FIRST JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
ANALYSIS TRIMMING ALLEN PERCH
THE TENSION YOU GIVEN TO THIS
BILL IN THE PUNCH THE DIALOGUE
AT THIS POINT. WATER AGENCIES
AND THEIR CUSTOMERS HAVE NOT
BEEN SPARED FROM THE AND
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP BROUGHT ON BY
THE TO THE NINETEEN CAMPAñA
CAN ALL PARTIES ON BOTH SIDES
OF THIS BILL YOU WANT TO FIND
WAYS TO HELP THOSE IN NEED. SB
TWO TO THREE IS NOT THE ANSWER
SB TWO TO THREE PROPOSALS THAT
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES SHOULD
USE ON REPAIR REVENUE TO GET
CUSTOMER THAT PUBLIC WATER
AGENCIES OR NOT FOR PROFIT
ENTITIES LARGELY FUNDED BY
REPAIR SERVICE RATES AQUA
MEMBERS WORK EXTENSIVELY WITH
CUSTOMERS THAT FALL BEHIND ON
THEIR BILLS. HOWEVER SINCE
PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES ARE NOT
FOR PROFIT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THEY CANNOT CREATE SENATE
STRUCTURES FOR PEOPLE TO NOT
PAY THEIR WATER BILLS. TO THE
EXTENT PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES
HAVE NON RATE PAIR REVENUE
SOURCES THIS REVENUES USED FOR
SAFE DRINKING WATER PROJECTS
REPAIRS AGING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND MUCH MORE. SB TWO TO THREE
PROPOSES THE PUBLIC WATER
AGENCY SHOULD ROB PETER TO PAY
PAUL BY SUGGESTING THIS
RECOGNITION THAT BEING IS
FORGET FORGET MOST NOTABLY
WASPI TWO TO THREE WOULD
REQUIRE THOUSANDS OF PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES UNDERTAKEN
EXHAUSTIVE DEBT FORGIVENESS
STUDY THE BILL PLACES NO SUCH
MANDATES ON PRIVATE WATER
AGENCIES FINALLY AS YOU JUST
HEARD. SENATE BUDGET SUB TWO IS
CONSIDERING A THREE POINT FOUR
ONE BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR DROUGHT RELIEF
WHICH INCLUDES ONE BILLION PER
TOKEN NINETEEN UTILITY BILL
WHICH IS THAT'S THE RIGHT
APPROACH TO DRESSING CODE WATER
DEBT NOT HAS TO BE TWO TO THREE
FOR THE REASONS STATED AQUA
SPENT RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
NO VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU OKAY. ALL RIGHT I
DON'T SEE ON HERE OR IN TWENTY
FORTY- LET'S GO TO PHONE LINES
pOPPOSITION CONCERNS RELATING TO
THIS BILL SB. TWO TO THREE.
THANK YOU TO SHOW UP. FOR S. B.
TO THREE PRESS FOLLOWED ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO
ONE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHY
DID YOU OPEN. BOB THANKS WE
WILL GO TO ONE FORTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I TO MAKE EMPLOYMENT
YOUR WITH RANCHER CALIFORNIA
WATER DISTRICT RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO MY CEMENTED. THANK
YOU. ONE FIFTY SIX. THANKS
FIFTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. WELL
WE'LL MOVE ALONG TO LINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONLY ONE
OVERLYING SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE ON
MUTE. BY EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. TWENTY FOUR PLEASE ON
MUTE. WHY NINETY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU HANNAH
DAVIDSON ON BEHALF OF THE
HIDDEN VALLEY LAKE COMMUNITY
SERVICES DISTRICT WE OPPOSE.
THANK YOU ONE ONE TWELVE YOU
ARE OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING THIS
IS DENNIS ALBION IN BEHALF OF
THE MESA WATER DISTRICT AND TO
ALL OF THE UTILITIES DISTRICT
AND WE ASSOCIATE ARE COMMON TO
SEE MUA AND AQUA CAN WE CLOSE.
THANK YOU LADIES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
AMPLY TERMINAL WITH CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
OUTLINING OUR COMMENTS WITH
AQUA AND STREAMLINE THANK. ONE
ONE HUNDRED FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REALLY LOCALES ON BEHALF
OF ONE OF OUR WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. ONE ONE
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO EUROPEN. CAN YOU MEET YES
IF WE CAN. I'M SORRY GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS THOMAS
CARGILL TO BLOCK A GROUP ON
BEHALF OF OUR CLIENT THE CITY
ROSEDALE IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. SIX OF THE
LINE ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU PAULA
GALLAGHER WITH THE SECOND ONE
WATER DISTRICT OPPOSED TO THE
BILL. ONE THIRTY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE ON
MUTE. I WILL MOVE ON TO ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS GREG
MORRISON WITH ELSEWHERE VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT. IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU ONE FORTY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE FORTY
EIGHT. FORTY ONE OVER. ONE
FIFTY TWO. ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE
ON MUTE. WHY ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MOREOVER
PRESENTING EACH MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT. STOCKLEY OPPOSED
THANK YOU. AND THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS CUED UP THIS
TIME MISTER THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH SOME MODERATOR OKAY
LET'S BRING THE ITEM BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS DISCUSSION CENTERS
CURRENT- I WANT TO THANK THE-
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL I
APPRECIATE FROM THE TESTIMONY
THAT THIS IS YOU KNOW TURKEY
OBVIOUSLY ARE AGENCIES CANNOT
OPERATE IF THEY DON'T HAVE
REVENUE. HOWEVER I DON'T
THERE'S NO PUBLIC BENEFIT TO
TURNING PEOPLE'S WATER OFF. SO
I APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMITTEE- THANK THIRTY YEARS
WHEN ASKED FOR SOME. WILL BE
CLEAR HOUSE THERE'S A MAN THAT
YOU HAVE ASKED FOR AND THAT
OBVIOUSLY THERE NEEDS TO BE
MORE WORK TO GET THE
STAKEHOLDERS ROOM CAMPING TRIP
TO TILDES- HOWEVER IT'S WE JUST
WE CANNOT HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE PEOPLE'S WATER TURN OFF
IT'S AN ESSENTIAL. ESSENTIAL
HUMAN NEEDS SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRING FORTH THE
BILL THESE THINGS ARE ALWAYS
STICKY WICKETS AND- WINS
PROPRIA HOME OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU CENTER. OKAY I HEAR A
MOTION FOR THE BILL- AND NEAR
THE EQUIPMENT MANUFACTURERS ARE
FINISHED REGARDING MISSED THE
FIRST PART OF YOUR PRESENTATION
BUT ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
WAS ASKED BY THOSE IN A WHO ARE
OPPOSING OFTEN BOUGHT IN MY
DISTRICT AS A MATTER OF FACT IT
WAS THE PRIVATE WATER SYSTEMS
ARE NOT GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO
THE MANDATE AND- IS THERE A DO
YOU HAVE YOU WANT TO. ANSWER
THAT ARE YOU WANT TO COVER THAT
IN YOUR CLOTHES. YOU KNOW THAT-
I'M NOT I'M NOT REALLY TO BE
HONEST WITH THE AT THE- ABLE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT- YEAH RICK
RIGHT HERE IT IS SOMETHING
THAT- IN I THINK WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS BECAUSE THE
PROHIBITION MAY BE ON THE- TO
EIGHTEEN- PROHIBITION AND THAT
THEY'RE NOT INCLUDED THAT
THAT'S THAT'S IN STATUTE TODAY-
MAY. YEAH THAT WAS A BALLOT
ISSUE SO THIS BILL IS NOT GOING
TO CHANGE- THE- THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THAT NOT WITHSTANDING-
STILL REMAINS AN ISSUE BUT-
THE- DOESN'T SEEM TO ME THAT-
THAT'S A GOOD ENOUGH REASON TO
ABANDON ARC OF MOVEMENT TO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT LOW INCOME-
WATER USERS- THAT- GET INERT IT
ARREARS SHOULD HAVE THEIR-
WATER SHUT OFF- WITHOUT HAVING
SOME SORT OF- WATER. A RICH
MANAGEMENT PLAN OFFERED TO THEM.
FIGURE FROM MY CONCERN IS THAT
OF KIND OF. THE COOKIE CUTTER
IN IT WOULD SEEM BETTER APPLIED
ON ON A MORE ON. DISTRICT BY
DISTRICT OR AGENCY BY AGENCY
SO- I JUST NEED TO HAVE A
LITTLE MORE. INFORMATION ON IT
AND SENATOR DODD AND LOOK AT
LITTLE CLOSER ON THE END OF I
WILL I WILL SUPPORT IT TODAY
BUT WE CAN TALK ABOUT IT
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A NOBLE
CONCEPT. THAT IF YOU'RE BEHIND
ON YOUR WATER AND YOUR FOOD THE
ESSENTIALS OF LIFE DATA THERE
SHOULD BE SOME SORT OF
FORGIVENESS OR PAYMENT PLAN OR
SOME WAY TO GET TO GET CAUGHT
UP. THAT TO DEFINE HOW TAKE OF
THOSE VERY OF. BASICS AWAY BUT
THIS IS LIKE GETTING ME THERE
TODAY ABOUT CALM HOW OF THE
OPPOSING IT BUT I WILL BE.
CONVERSING WITH YOU AFTERWARDS
THANK YOU. I'LL MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET THAT- INFORMATION TO YOU
THAT BECAUSE- OF. THAT
IMPORTANT QUESTION YEAH. TWENTY
OKAY. ARE THE I. HAS BEEN MOVED
BY CENTERS. ARE YOU MAY CLOSE
CENTER DODD. LOOK AT THIS THIS
IS- A TOUGH POLICY THE POLICY
ON ITS FACE IS NOT TOUGH AT ALL
I THINK- CENTER BATES THE
ANSWER SKINNER ARTICULATED VERY
WELL WHY THIS TYPE OF POLICY IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY THE STATE
CALIFORNIA. BUT THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT IT'S- THAT IT'S EASY
OR ALSO DOESN'T MEAN THAT
THERE'S NOT SOME- FAIRNESS
ISSUES MY COMMITMENT AND WE
HAVE REALLY MODIFIED THIS BILL
AMENDED THIS BILL AND SO MANY
AREAS UP TO THIS POINT MY
COMMITMENT IS- YOU KNOW AND I
WAS ALWAYS THE I WILL AGREE TO-
YOU KNOW WORK GOING FORWARD TO
TRY TO MAKE THIS A BETTER BILL
AND- BRING SOMETHING TO OUR
FLOOR THAT OUR MEMBERS. AT A
BIPARTISAN- YEAH EFFORT CAD CAN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOU PART
CONTROLLED FOLLOW. I AM NUMBER
pSENATOR DODD THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN HI ALLEN I BATES. BATES
NO DALLY. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ ICE
SKINNER. SKINNER AYE STERN WHY
CASKEY. OKAY PORTAL THAT OPENED
UP FOR FOLKS TO ADD ON. THANK
YOU AND I AND I AND I DO A- THE
PROCEDURE YOUR MOTHER COMMITTEE
TAKING AMENDMENTS AND WORKING
WITH US FOR THE FURTHER I MEAN
YOU KNOW. YOU'RE RIGHT THERE'S
SOME CORE PRINCIPLES AT STAKE
HERE- WE ALSO NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT DOING ANYTHING
TO- INCENTIVIZE- BAD ACTORS YOU
JUST DON'T WANT TO PAY THEIR
BILL AND- AND- WITH THE WITH NO
RECOURSE SO. THAT THAT'S THAT
THAT'S THAT THAT'S THE TRICK
CARE AND- I BUSINESS YEAR YOU
WORK YOU'RE NOT IN THE ROOM
WHEN THAT WE LET OFF HERE I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU- DEAL FOR
BRINGING. THE OPPONENTS
TOGETHER ON A SUNDAY AFTERNOON
THIS. SUNDAY TAKING TIME OUT OF
YOUR SCHEDULE YOUR CONSULTANT
SCHEDULE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS ON BOTH YOUR PARTS
THERE. FOR MORE WORK TO BE DONE
BUT IF A PROCEDURE YOUR GOOD
WORK AND THAT- AND SUFFERED.
OKAY LET'S- LET'S THANK YOU I
CENTER DIED AND WILL NOW TURN
TO SENATOR RUSSELL- WILL-
PRESENT. SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE.
WHILE WE- FIVE CLEANER DIES ONE
WEEK THAT ENTERTAIN A MOTION
FOR THE CONSENT CALENDAR. MOVE
BY SENATOR DOLLARS AS OF ITS
CULTURAL. CONSENT CALENDAR
CONSISTS OF ITEMS NUMBER SEVEN
ALLEN. ALLEN I'D BATES BATES BY
DALLY. GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
SKINNER SKINNER HI SORRY WILL
BE LIKE YOU KNOW SKI. WELL THE
ROLE OF AND NOT EVEN READY
CENTERED AROUND. OF COURSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. FOR PUBLIC
NOTICE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COLLEAGUES SB FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE AIMS TO ADDRESS
PROBLEMS WITH DTS SEES
VIOLATING SCORING PROCEDURE
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS B. S. B.
ACCURATE ACCURATELY ACCOUNT FOR
HAZARDOUS WASTE FACILITIES
REGULATIONS AND COMPLIANCE. BOB
BEFORE MOVING ON I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR VERY MUCH IN
THE COMMITTEE STUFF OFF FOR THE
DISCUSSION AND THE DEBATE THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING THE- IT'S
BEEN VERY IMPORTANT. FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES THAT LIVE NEAR THE
SEVENTY EIGHT HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
LARGELY UNSERVED LOW INCOME
LESS LIKELY TO HAVE ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR NEED GOVERNMENT TO
PROTECT THEM. SB SIX SEVENTY
THREE- INSTRUCTED DTS SEEK TO
DEVELOP A MECHANISM TO
IMPACTING ENVIRONMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AS PART OF CONSIDERING A
NEW MODIFIED OR PERMIT. RENEWAL
THE TSC DECIDED THE BSP MODEL
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT VS P.
MODEL HAS RESULTED IN
FACILITIES HAVING SCORES THAT
DO NOT REFLECT THE TRUE IMPACT
AND MAC MAGNITUDE. OF HARM
BROUGHT ON BY THEIR VIOLATIONS.
WITH P. IS A THREE STEP.
PROCESS OF INSPECTIONS
VIOLATIONS IDENTIFIED IS SCORED
WITH THOSE SCORES ADDED AND
DIVIDED BY THE NUMBER OF
INSPECTIONS TO COME UP WITH
THAT FACILITIES SCORING
COMPLIANCE TIER ASSIGNMENT. THE
PROBLEM IS THE VISION BY
INSPECTIONS HAS RESULTED IN
FACILITIES RECEIVING A LITTLE
B. S. PEACE CORPS AND TEAR
ASSIGNMENT THE JUST DOES NOT
ACCURATELY REFLECT THEIR
IMPACTS DESPITE HAVING A HIGH
NUMBER OF SERIOUS VIOLATIONS.
ALL DUE TO THE NUMBER OF
INSPECTIONS THIS INHIBITS VS P.
FROM ACCURATELY ACCURATELY
REFLECT THE NAY FACILITIES
COMPLIANCE HISTORY AND
COMMUNITY IMPACT WITH THE
NUMBER OF INSPECTIONS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTING THE VALUE
OF THE VIOLATIONS THEMSELVES.
SITE VISITS ARE BASED ON
SEVERAL FACTORS WITH SOME
FACILITIES RECEIVING ONE
INSPECTION AND OTHERS AS MANY
AS TWENTY SIX THERE ISN'T AN
EXPLANATION AS TO WHY DIVISION
BY INSPECTIONS WOULD HELP
ACCOUNT FOR COMPLIANCE IN THE
VSP FORMULA IN FACT. INCREASED
INSPECTIONS SHOULD BE RAISING
CONCERNS ABOUT A FACILITIES
COMPLIANCE WHICH IS WHY ANOTHER
REASON THIS STEP SHOULD BE
REMOVED ALL TOGETHER. SB FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE REMOVES THE
INSPECTION DIVISION FROM B. S.
B. AND WREAK CALIBRATES THE
BSP'S CORE AND TEAR RANKING
SYSTEM BASED ON THE TOTAL.
NUMBER AND TYPE OF BY.
COMMITTED TO BETTER BUT ENSURE
OVERSIGHT OF THESE FACILITIES
OUR INTENT IS TO NOT
AUTOMATICALLY SHUT DOWN THE
FACILITIES WE WANT THE
FACILITIES TO CARRY OUT THEIR
BUSINESS. BUT BECAUSE THE
FACILITY THAT HANDLES TOXIC
WASTE DOES NOT GIVE IT THE
AUTHORITY TO OPERATE OUTSIDE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH INTENDED OR NOT.
WITH P. WAS CREATED THROUGH THE
REGULATORY PROCESS AND WAS
PRESENTED S A- TOOL TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
OUR COMMUNITIES BUT IT HAS NOT
MET ITS INTENDED PURPOSE. WE
ARE NOT BY PASSING THE
REGULATORY PROCESS DTIC TOOK US
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND MADE
ITS DECISION. THE DEPARTMENT
DECIDED THAT SOME FACILITIES
ARE JUST TOO COMPLEX AND TOO
HARD TO REGULATE. ARE
CONSIDERED CONSTITUENTS
IDENTIFY PROBLEMS IN THE LOT
IMPACT THEIR HEALTH HEALTH AND
WELLBEING. ALL WE NEED CLEAR
VIA IT'S CLEAR VS P. NEEDS TO
BE FIXED. MY COMMUNITY AND
OTHERS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT BY
TOXIC WASTE POLLUTION AND IT
WAS RECENTLY HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
EXITE BURNED FACILITY
BANKRUPTCY CASE. MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS OF UNDER WHILE
MAIN STATE OVERSIGHT LED TO
DEVASTATING GENERATIONAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS IN SURROUNDING
NEIGHBORHOODS WE CANNOT ALLOW
THIS TO HAPPEN AGAIN. FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES CANNOT WAIT FOR
ANOTHER DRAG THAT PROCESS THE
DOES NOT GUARANTEE NEEDED
CHANGES. FACILITIES WITH BAD
COMPLIANCE HISTORIES NEED TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR. OTHER FACILITIES
ARE DOING THE RIGHT THING
SHOULD NOT BE DISADVANTAGED.
THIS PROPOSAL LINES VS P. WITH
THIS PURPOSE AS INTENDED BY SB
SIX SEVENTY THREE AND I FINALLY
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
TEAMSTERS UNION REGARDING THE
MANY WORKERS THAT THEY
REPRESENT. I HAVE TREMENDOUS
RESPECT FOR THOSE WORKERS I
SPENT MY LIFE AS A LABOR LEADER
I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO PICK BETWEEN
WORKERS EARNING GOOD WAGES GOOD
BENEFITS. AND THE HEALTH AND
THE WELL BEING OF THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY- I COMMIT
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
TSC COMMITTEE AND STAKEHOLDERS
TO DETERMINE POSSIBLE
ALTERNATIVES. BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS WE NEED TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM IMMEDIATELY AND
EFFECTIVELY MISTER CHAIR WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND
HELP ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. A. R. ANGELA JOHNSON
MESZAROS MANAGING ATTORNEY OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS PROGRAM
FOR IT JUSTICE AND REBEKAH
OVERMYER VELAZQUEZ OF THE CLEAN
AIR COALITION OF NORTH WOULD
YOUR AND OF ALL THE PEDAL
HEIGHTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU COULD YOU
WITNESSES. HELLO YES WE HEAR
YOU LOUD AND CLEAR. THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING SENATOR ALLEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
ANGELA JOHNSON MESZAROS THE
MANAGING ATTORNEY AT
EARTHJUSTICE. SB FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE IS BASED ON TWO VERY
SIMPLE IDEAS HAZARDOUS WASTE IS
HAZARDOUS AND SAFE HANDLING OF
HAZARDOUS WASTE IS IMPORTANT.
WE ALL SHOULD HAVE VISIBILITY
INTO WHICH FACILITIES ARE
VIOLATING THE LAW AND THEREFORE
PUTTING COMMUNITIES AT RISK OF
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES DEMANDED.
VISIBILITY ALLOWS REGULATORS TO
ACT TO STOP HARM BECAUSE BOTH
THE PRICE OF CLEAN UP AND THE
COST TO HEALTH FROM DELAYED
ACTION FOR WORSE NINE ACTION IS
ENORMOUSLY HIGH. AUTHORITIES
THAT BENEFIT FROM DTS HE'S
CURRENT SYSTEM ARGUE OTHERWISE
SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE SIMPLY
SEEKS TO ENSURE CLEAR ANSWERS
TO THE QUESTIONS THAT OUT SIX
SEVENTY THREE. WHICH FACILITIES
HAVE THE MOST CLASS WHEN
VIOLATIONS HOW SIGNIFICANTLY DO
THOSE VIOLATIONS IMPACT HEALTH
AND THE ENVIRONMENT AND WHEN IS
ENOUGH ENOUGH. PORTABILITY'S
WHICH SERIAL EXTENDED
COMPLIANCE PROBLEM SB FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE SEEKS TO CLOSE THE
LOOPHOLE WITH THE NUMBER OF
INSPECTIONS RATHER THAN THE
IMPACT OF THAT AND THE HARM
CAUSED BY PERMIT VIOLATIONS. DR
HOW FAR DO YOU DRIVE HOW TO
DRAW THE LINE BETWEEN ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH. SB SIX SEVENTY FIVE
APPROPRIATELY ACTION THIS BODY
TO TELL DGSE THAT OUR STATE
POLICY WILL BE THAT FRONTLINE
COMMUNITIES MATTER AND BSP
LET'S CLARIFY RATHER THAN MUDDY
THE WATERS OF WHICH FACILITIES
VIOLATIONS ARE CAUSING THE MOST
HARM. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR EYES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE SERVER BACK OF. LAST FROM.
PLEASE COLLISION NORTH WITHIN A
HIGH. AVOCADO HEIGHTS SOUNDS
LIKE THE WHERE THE NEXT DAY- WE
LOT OF MILLENNIALS WILL BE
MOVING SOON TO FIX THAT BUT TO
WONDERFUL MA'AM. ARE YOU THERE-
MISS OVERMYER VELAZQUEZ. MISTER
CHAIR- IT IS ON THE LINE IS
TEXTING ME TO SAY THAT SHE IS
ON HOLD AND I'M HERE NOW I'M
HERE NOW THANK YOU AND TASTIC.
SHOULD I GO AHEAD YES PLEASE.
OKAY GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN ALAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE SEVEN FIVE MY NAME IS
REBECCA OVERMYER VELAZQUEZ SIAM
THE COORDINATOR OF THE CLEAN
AIR COALITION OF NORTH READY OR
NOT A CUT HEIGHTS A GRASSROOTS
COMMUNITY ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION IN L. A. COUNTY.
WE ARE HERE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
MISSION AND I'M QUOTING TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S PEOPLE AND
ENVIRONMENT D. TNCS VISION IS
THAT AND I COULD AGAIN
CALIFORNIANS ENJOY A CLEAN AND
HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT AND AS A
RESULT OF OUR EFFORTS
COMMUNITIES ARE CONFIDENT THAT
WE CAN PROTECT THEM FROM TOXIC
HARM. MY COMMUNITY IS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
POLLUTION WE KNOW ABOUT THE
LEAD AND ARSENIC EMISSIONS THAT
WE FACE ON A DAILY BASIS AND WE
NEED MORE PROTECTION FROM THE-HARMS OF THAT WE CAN ENJOY A
CLEAN AND HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN WE HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH PTSD THERE
ARE GOOD PEOPLE IN THE AGENCY
WHO WANT TO FULFILL BE TNCS
MISSION BUT WE ARE COMING TO
YOU OUR ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
BECAUSE WHEN YOU SEND A STRONG
SIGNAL OF SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH YOU ARE LEADING THE
AGENCY TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE THE V. S. P.
SIX IS THE SUPPORT PTSD NEEDS
YOUR YES VOTE FOR THIS BILL IS
A VOTE FOR D. TNCS MISSION AND
FOR THE LONG TERM HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIA. COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE. THANK YOU. CAN ALLEN IF I
I'D LIKE TO READ THE NAME OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SUPPORT BY
SEVEN FIVE. BAYVIEW HUNTERS
POINT MOTHERS AND FATHERS
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE COMMITTEE
THE BAYVIEW HUNTERS POINT
MOTHERS AND FATHERS. LEAD
INSTITUTE TRI VALLEY CARES EL
PUEBLO BUT A LADY ALLENBY THE
KETTLEMAN CITY. AND CLEAN WATER
ACTION THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU OKAY I SEE
NO ONE IN PERSON HERE OR TWENTY
FORTY LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES TO SEE FIRST ONE IT TO
ADD IN THEIR VOICES IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL FIVE THIRTY FIVE
MODERATOR PLEASE Q. THE SUPPORT
LINE. THANK YOU TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SPF FIVE SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON CAME
DOWN ON BEHALF OF MY FOR THE
COURT THANK YOU. SCHED NINE ONE
SIX TWO NINE. FOR GOOD
AFTERNOON DONNA SITE YOU'RE
VISITING A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL MOVING ON WE WILL GO TO
LINE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I GET MORNING CLASS OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BYE NOW ONE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PRISCILLA KIDDER FROM BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL STEWARDSHIP ACTION
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE FIFTY FIVE. ONE MOMENT WE
HAVE A COMPUTER NOW. IF YOU'D
LIKE TO QUEUE UP PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. NO OVERLYING. THIRTY
EIGHT. NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUING
UP AT THIS TIME THANK YOU- BUT
KILEY OPPOSITION NOW WE'VE GOT
TO LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
FIRST TIME DOWN KEPT YOU FROM
AND WHO'S SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL ECONOMIC BALANCE
AND THEN NIACIN GROSSMAN- FROM
THE TEAMSTERS. WE'LL START WITH
YOU WITH DON. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN DON KHAKI WITH MCCUE
CALCULUS AT THE AT ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
TALENT EVEN LOOK RADICALLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE SEVENTY FIVE
BITES UNDERGONE. STEVEN IT'S
MEMBERS STRONGLY SUPPORT A FAIR
BALANCED AND EFFECTIVE OBJECTS
FOR EVALUATING HOW TO TWEET THE
LADIES AND ANY DIRECT IMPACTS
ENVIRONMENT AND SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
CONSIDERATION OF THEIR
COMPLAINT HISTORY. NOT THAT
DETAILED MATTER PARTICULARLY
GIVEN ABSOLUTELY PERMANENT MAY
BE ON THE LINE UP BEHIND THE S.
P. SCORE IS INSTITUTED. SB FIVE
SEVENTY FIVE IS OF GREAT
CONCERN AT THAT WOULD ELIMINATE
THE CAP OF CALCULATING THE
SCORE BY DIVIDING THE NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS EXPECT INSPECTIONS
ON ACTION THAT WOULD MAKE THE
NUMBER OF FACILITY INSPECTIONS
ONE OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
FACTORS IN CALCULATING THE
BSP'S CORE COLLECTIBILITY.
UNDER THE BILL A FACILITY WITH
A LARGE NUMBER OF INFECTION BUT
BUT LACKS THE GREETED BY ALICIA
COULD SEE OF THE F. P. SCORE
THAT DOES NOT CORRESPOND WITH
THE FACILITY DRESSED AS
COMPARED TO ANOTHER FACILITY
WITH INFECTIONS THAT MORE
EGREGIOUS VIOLATIONS. SUCH AN
APPROACH IS NOT FAIR MUCH LOVE
BALLENGER TACTIC PROCESS FOR
EVALUATING. AND SCORING HAS
USUALLY. FURTHER DETAILS HE
RECEIVED A TERM REQUEST FOR
MEASURE THE KEY. NOT OUT. BY
ONLY OR TO THE S. P. DURING THE
ROLE PROCESS BASED ON
ASSERTIONS THAT AVERAGE AND
WHAT IT HERE AND- THE TOTAL NOW.
AND SEVERE OF BY. BY RENDERING
THE- AND THE HERO AT. EACH
HOWEVER. THAT WAS ABOUT WAY TO
A FOR INSPECTION AND- WHICH MAY.
BASED A PATROL HI BETWEEN LOCAL
ACTION YEAR. TO ONE INFRACTION
THREE OF YEARS- DGFT NOTED THAT
HAVING A- SCORES THE DATA. OF
THAT ARE REQUIRED TO BE IN MOST
FREQUENTLY. AN INTEREST TO THE
RECOMMENDED EACH AND WITH A
POSTURE CURE MULTIPLE ONE
VIOLATION. IN A SINGLE
INSPECTION AND THAT
HISTORICALLY THE NUMBER OF
CLAFLIN VIOLATIONS RANGE FROM
ZERO TO A MAXIMUM OF FOURTEEN.
ADDITIONALLY AS YOU ARE AWARE
AND CITED BY DGFT AND THEIR SIX
SEVEN GREEN MORE MAKING PACKAGE
DGSE ALREADY HAS VERY GROUNDS
UPON WHICH TO REVOKE OR SUSPEND
A PERMIT. INCLUDING ONE OF
DISABILITY ACCOUNT CAREER MORE
INCIDENTS OF CLOCK ONE
VIOLATION TORTURE PERSON OR
ENTITY HAVE BEEN FOUND LIABLE
OR HAD BEEN CONVICTED WITH
RESPECT WITH. THE LEADING
WITHIN A FIVE YEAR PERIOD.
ULTIMATELY A NUMBER OF FACTORS
BEYOND JUST TO COMPLETE
COMPLIANCE DISTRICT BACK HEALTH
RECORD. WE HAVE THE ABILITY IS
INSPECTED. TERM WE BELIEVE ANY
JUST. WE ASK P. BE HERE THE
OTHER REGULAR PROP HE HAD EACH
YEAR THE HOSPITAL EACH MAN.
RATHER THAN BE ALLEGE. LIKE AT
FIVE SEVEN FIVE. THAT WOULD NOT
TAKE INTO A THE EXTRA CHEESE
THE YOU CAN'T BE MUCH LIKE
PROVIDE FOR A LOOK AT IT
BECAUSE THE PROCESS. PRETTY
DRIVEN MUCH RESPECT OPPOSE THAT
THE FACT FIVE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR. NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MCCARTY. BOB SMITH
NUMBER. MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBER SHANE DAWSON DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL THE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING ALL
OF THE TEAMSTER LOCAL SINGER
CALIFORNIA SH WE ARE OPPOSED TO
SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IT TARGETS VERY
SPECIFICALLY A FACILITY WHERE
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF TEAMSTER
MEMBERS WORKING. THE BILL WOULD
ARBITRARILY CHANGED THE FORMULA
FOR DETERMINING WHETHER ASK
THIS WASTE THE. REASON
COMPLIANCE RECORD TO COMBAT. IN
THIS CASE AT NIGHT SO I WAS
FACILITY MEMBERS WORK THIS NEW
FORMULA WHAT RESULT IN A
MATHEMATICAL ISSUE FINDING.
THAT THE FACILITY. ARE
ACCEPTABLE RANGE AND WE'RE
CERTAINLY RESULT IN ITS
CLOSURE. ALL OF THOSE HARD
WORKING TEACHERS WOULD LOSE OUR
JOBS HEALTHCARE PENSIONS AND OF
COURSE OUR FAMILIES WITH. A
SIGNIFICANT NEGATIVE IMPACTS.
MOREOVER ARBITRARY APPROACH
WOULD LIKELY PUT OPERATING
COMMITTEE OTHER HAZARDOUS WASTE
FACILITIES IN JEOPARDY. MANY OF
THESE FACILITIES ARE ALSO TEAMS
FROM PLAYERS AND SO THESE ARE
NECESSARY IN. A HOSPITAL IN THE
STATE OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
TO BE CLEAR WE ARE NOT HERE TO
DEFEND STOCKWELL POLLUTERS
PROBLEM NOBODY HAS MADE THE
CASE THAT OUR EMPLOYERS FALL
INTO THAT CATEGORY. WE HAVE TO
KEEP DISRESPECT FOR THE AUTHOR
AND A COMMITMENT TO WORKING
PEOPLE. UNFORTUNATELY AND ARGUE
WORKING PEOPLE WILL BE THE ONE
AT A COST OF THE CURRENT
ITERATION BUT STILL. WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO THIS BILL AND
LET THE REGULATORY PROCESS THAT
IS ONGOING. DGSE PLAY OUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FONTENEAUX ONE IN PERSON- OR
EITHER HERE TWENTY FORTY LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINES MOTOR
ANYONE ON THE CALL AND IN IN
OPPOSITION TO OR TO RAISE
CONCERNS ABOUT SB. FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE. CHAU OPPOSITION ON S. B.
BY SEVEN FIVE PLEASEPRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND WE WILL
START WITH LINE ONE SIXTY SIX
IT'S GOING TO. ONE SIXTY SIX
YOU ARE OPEN. WHY NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY NINETY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND ONE FORTY
TWO YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TERMINOLOGY AND
MEMBERS OF FREEDOM MEDINA WITH
MANATT PHELPS AND PHILLIPS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF COMMIT CO
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. THAT
COMMITTEE VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO CLARIFY
THAT WHILE THE BILL ANALYSIS
LIST NOT SUBSTANCE HELLO KEVIN
OPPOSING ENTITY TO THE BILL THE
FIRM DOES NOT HAVE A POSITION
ON THE BILL NOR DID WE SUBMIT A
LETTER OPPOSING THE STYLE. WE
WOULD SPECULATE ASSABET HE
CLARIFIED FOR FUTURE
CORRESPONDENCE THANK YOU. SEVEN
OR NINE TWENTY THREE WE WILL
WE'LL ADDRESS. AND LIKE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DIMITRI GAVE A LONGTIME
RESIDENT OF WOULD YOU
CALIFORNIA I AM IN A POSITION
TO FIVE SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU.
FIND ONE SIXTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ROLANDO
VAZQUEZ RESIDENT OF APPOINTING
CALIFORNIA NINE ONE SEVEN FOUR.
LIKE KERN EXPECTS OPPOSITION TO
SB. FIVE SEVEN. NINE ONE ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI EXISTENCE
MEDINA SHOVEL FROM CALIFORNIA
STATE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT FOR
SOME REASON I WAS NOT CALLED
UPON EARLIER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI YEAH- BECAUSE SISTER
HILLYER- BUT- RESIDENT WHAT
YEAR AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
BY ONE SIXTY YOU ARE OPEN. FIVE
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH I AM FROM
BACK BACK CALIFORNIA AND POST
THE BILL IS THE FOURTH CALL
MICHAEL. MY ONE SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
RACHEL TO THERE AND I'M ON THE
COMPUTER AND LONGTIME RESIDENT
OF NORTH WITTER AND MEMBERS OF
THE CLEAN AIR COALITION WE WERE
PRACTICAL WORK ON OUR ON OUR
NUMBERS BUT WE ARE DEFINITELY
IN SUPPORT. OF THEIR CHILD- IT
SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE PLEASE
LISTEN TO US AND ALL THE THINGS
THAT REBEKAH OVER MY
UNDERSTANDING. AND MARYLAND
COMING WHERE I PREVIOUSLY
REPRESENTS ALL OF THOSE OF US
WHO ARE SUFFERING- THE PROBLEM
A POOL IN THE AREA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPPOSITION WE'RE JUST
A MINISTER BUT WE DO PRE YOUR
YOUR- YOUR CARNAL I KNOW YOU DO
OPPOSITE BUT YOU. IN YOUR WHEN
HE WAS IN POINT TO WIN THE TWO
NEXT ONE COMES WE ARE IN. OKAY
THE THANK YOU SO MUCH. ALL
RIGHT LET'S LET'S NOW AS
CONTINUE- ANY OTHER CALL IN
OPPOSITE. OR OR REYES CAN. YEAH
YES TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB
FIVE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO WILL GO NINE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I
APOLOGIZE THAT THIS IS A LEASE
CONTRACT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
AND I DID PRESS SUPPORT- IN Q.
EARLIER BUT WASN'T CALLED SO.
FOR CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. BY NINETY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI HELLO THIS IS
FOLLOWED UP I PHYSICIANS THE
RESPONSIBILITY ATTENDANT AND
THIS SAME TO A SO ARE IN OF THE
FIVE CENTER THANK YOU. BY ONE
SIXTIES PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
WHAT. YOUR OPEN I STILL OKAY I
WOULD REPLACE ON EIGHTEEN NINE
IS MARYLAND MORE MEMBER OF
CLEAN AIR CORD I AM SUPPORT YES.
FIVE SEVENTY. THANK YOU. BY ONE
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ON FEBRUARY OTHER FOR TO KEY UP
WITH TIME. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH. FIVE FOUR THREE BACK THE
COMMITTEE FOR COM THOUGHTS.
THIRTY THANK. THANK YOU CARE- I
ONE OF IS AGAIN THE ON BY THE
AUTHOR I'M SORRY FOR BRINGING
THIS THIS PHONE- YOU KNOW SHE
AND I SHARE OF COURSE YOU'D IN
YOUR YOUR OPENING OF THE
HORRENDOUS FOR X. AND ARE BACK
SO WE COME FROM A UP WHERE WE
DON'T PAID. ANY. YOU HAVE COULD
EQUATE TO A LOWER SCORE AND SO
I THINK THAT WE'VE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO DO SOMETHING THAT IS
FAIR FIRST AND FOREMOST FOR THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF OUR
RESIDENTS- SO I KNOW YOU WILL
CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT AS
WELL AS THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF THE WORK FORCE- MY DAD THE
TEAMSTERS WELL I WOULD NOT WANT
HIM WORKING ON ANY OF THESE
SITES- IF THEY ARE DEEMED TO BE
IN VIOLATION. AND SO- I KNOW
ALL CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU
AS WELL- BUT WE CERTAINLY HAVE
TO DO TO MORE HERE AND I THINK
THIS TAKES A REALLY STRONG
APPROACH AND I'M HAPPY CO
AUTHOR BUT HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOU TO MAKE THIS
STRONGER FOR OUR RESIDENTS
THANK YOU. THANK AND I I'M I'M
CERTAINLY- RECOMMENDING AN AYE
VOTE. TODAY WITH THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF AND
STAKEHOLDERS THE MINISTRATION.
TO ENSURE THAT THE PROPOSED
CORE METHODOLOGY IS INDEED MORE
PROTECTIVE OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. AND THAT IT'S
DEFENSIBLE FIVE LEGALLY AND
OTHERWISE AND THAT IS NOT
DESIGNED WITH PREDETERMINED
OUTCOMES IN MIND THAT AND THAT-
THAT'S IN THE- ANALYSIS SO-
WITHOUT UNDERSTANDING- I'M
CERTAINLY- ARE HAPPY TO MOVE
FORWARD TODAY- BUT OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A LOT OF CHALLENGES ON
THE NUMBER OF WHICH WERE
BROUGHT UP IN THE OPPOSITION- A-
BUT ALSO BROUGHT UP IN THE- IN
THE- IN THE ANALYSIS I OF
COURSE I ALSO UNDERSTAND. YOUR
DEEP FRUSTRATIONS WITH THE- THE
PROGRAM IN THE EXTENT TO WHICH
THERE REALLY AND- DOING THE
WORK THAT WE ALL NEEDED TO DO
TO KEEP PEOPLE SAFE AND
PROTECTED SO. LET'S SEVEN FIVE
SENATORS OFFICES MOVED TO BILL.
AND THAT WITHOUT WILL WILL HAVE
A CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ARE APPRECIATE ALL
OF YOUR COMMENTS WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO OUR BEST. TO
REACH- ANY KIND OF CHANGES THAT
STILL CARRY OUT THE GOALS OF
GOOD PUBLIC HEALTH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND- GINGIVAL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR OKAY.
FIVE ASSEMBLY FEDERAL. ID
NUMBER FOR SB FIVE SEVEN FIVE
BY SENATOR ALSO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN HI. I
BATES. DALLY GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ
I SKINNER STERN MY CASCADE OKAY
REALLY EVEN OPEN LOTS OF PEOPLE
WITH. THREE DIFFERENT HEARINGS
HAVING RIGHT NOW AS YOU KNOW AS
CENTER SO THANK YOU DO A-
PROCEDURE WORK ON THIS OKAYBUT
SAYS THE LONG. PATIENT CENTERED
BAKER WHETHER IT IS NOW. NOW
LEARN WHAT HE'S GONNA DO ON
SEVERAL OF THESE EQ BILLS AS
THEY GET TO THE FOR. I GIVEN
HIS PRESENCE HERE HE'S HE'S-
GETTING INTO THE INTERESTING
AND- THE CARD ISSUE OF CEMENT.
CONCRETE SO- BUT WE'LL HEAR
FROM U. S. SENATE BAKER THIS IS
NASTY. FIVE NINETY SIX. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN NUMBER MEMBERS
OF. FIFTY FIVE NINETY SIX AS
YOU MENTIONED IS ABOUT REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
THE CEMENT AND CONCRETE SECTOR.
CONCRETE IS MOST WIDELY USED
BUILDING MATERIAL IN THE WORLD.
A LITTLE TRIVIA HE MADE OBJECTS
NOW OUTWEIGH ALL LIVING THINGS
ON EARTH. CRITICIZED CIVIC
MARKET. AND CONCRETE BECAUSE
50% OF ALL HUMAN BEINGS EVER
MADE. THE FOURTEENTH ALSO MAJOR
SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GASES.
COUNTY FOR ABOUT 7% OF GLOBAL
CO TWO EMISSIONS. IT'S THE
SECOND LARGEST INDUSTRIAL
SOURCE OF GHG EMISSIONS IN OUR
STATE. ISRAEL AGREED TO STOP
USING CONCRETE WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY. TO MAKE IT
WITH FAR LESS IMPACT ON OUR
CLIMATE. THIRD ENERGY
INNOVATION IDENTIFIED
ESTABLISHING A PERFORMANCE
STANDARD FOR MISSIONS FROM
CONCRETE AND CEMENT AS ONE OF
ITS TOP POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
TECHNOLOGIES AND PROCESSES
EXIST FOR KEEPING LARGE
REDUCTIONS IN EMISSIONS FROM
CONCRETE CEMENT. AS ONE OF OUR
WITNESSES WILL DESCRIBE. THESE
TECHNOLOGIES OF USUALLY NOT
BEEN DEPLOYED AT SCALE. THE
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
DEMAND FOR LOW CARBON PRODUCTS
FROM CUSTOMERS. I DO NOT BEEN
ENOUGH REGULATORY INCENTIVES TO
DRIVE CHANGE. PICKUP TRUCK
MARKET BELOW TWENTY DOLLARS A
TONNE MANY EMISSIONS REDUCTION
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THERE HAVE
NOT BEEN COST EFFECTIVE. IF YOU
WERE TO THE BILL WITHOUT THE
CEMENT INDUSTRY TO BE WILLING
PARTNER AND SHIPPING THESE
GOALS BECAUSE THEY CAN PROVIDE
A SUPPORTIVE POLICY ENVIRONMENT
AND ADDRESS BARRIERS THAT EXIST
TODAY. IN FACT THE CALIFORNIA
NEVADA CEMENT ASSOCIATION
PUBLISHED A PAPER IN MARCH OF
THIS YEAR. FROM AN INTEREST
COMMITMENT TO ACHIEVING CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. AND IDENTIFYING PATHWAYS
FOR GPS. BUT ALSO POINT OUT
AREAS WERE LEGISLATIVE AND
REGULATORY CHANGES ARE NEEDED
TO UNLOCK THOSE PATHWAYS. THIS
BILL AIMS TO CREATE THE RIGHT
SUPPORTER FRAMEWORK. TO CHECK
OF COURTNEY CHARLIE BY TWENTY
FORTY FIVE AND SAID INTERM
TARGET A 40% REDUCTION
EMISSIONS. INTENSITY BY TWENTY
THIRTY TO SPUR NEAR TERM
ACTION. DISTRICT COURT TO DO
NUMBER THINGS INCLUDE HELP WITH
STRATEGY FOR ACHIEVING THESE
TARGETS AND DR NASSAR
REGULATIONS DRIVE DEMAND. FOR
LOW COST MATERIALS TO CREATE
INCENTIVES. FOR REDUCING
EMISSIONS WHILE PROTECTING
PRODUCERS PRODUCERS FROM UNFAIR
COMPETITION. TRAVESTY PRODUCERS.
WERE NOT SUBJECT TO THE SAME
RULES. THIS IS A LOT. TO PUT
WHATEVER HARD TO DECARBONISE
INDUSTRIES BUT A PATH. TO
CARBON NEUTRAL FUTURE. AND
ESPECIALLY HIS TASK FOR EITHER.
WE TO ASSIST ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. DR BOB ABSTAINED THE
CO FOUNDER PROJECT TWENTY
THIRTY. INTERVIEW TO. IN TOUCH
OF COURSE ON THE DIRECTOR OF
THE UCLA INSTITUTE FOR CARBON
MANAGEMENT. AND RECENT CARBON
X. PRIZE WINNER FIRST TEAMS
WORK ON STORING CO TWO IN
CONCRETE THANK YOU. OKAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR- SENATOR. SPECTER
LET'S NOT TO BOB DEAN FROM
PROBABLY TWENTY THIRTY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR BACKER IN
COMMITTEE PURSUING OUR GOALS
OUR CLIMATE GOALS WE NEED TO
CHALLENGE OUR THINKING BEYOND
EMISSIONS FROM ENERGY SOURCES
AND WE NEED TO INCLUDE
INDUSTRIAL SOURCES. CALIFORNIA
CURRENTLY HAS NO INDUSTRIAL
POLICY PLAN FOR CEMENT CONCRETE
AND WHAT THAT SEVEN ACTIVE
DOMESTIC CEMENT FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE SUBJECT TO
LIMITS IMPOSED BY CAP AND TRADE
CEMENT IMPORTS HAVE NO
LIMITATIONS CONCRETE SUPPLIERS
ALSO KNOW HOW TO PRODUCE
CONCRETE WITH GLASS EMBEDDED
EMISSIONS. BUT THERE'S LITTLE
TO NO ECONOMIC INCENTIVE TO DO
SO THE SITUATION REMINDS ME OF
THE PEOPLE'S MARKET IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT R. TO THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD THERE IS
NO TARGETED ECONOMIC STRUCTURE
TO ENCOURAGE AND REWARD
INNOVATION TODAY. THE ECONOMIC
VALUE OF THE OSTEOPATHS CREDITS
HIS PRODUCT INNOVATION AND
BILLIONS OF GALLON EQUIVALENT
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION FUEL
THE MARKET. WHAT ELSE HE
AFFECTED PER PEOPLE'S SB FIVE
NINETY SIX CAN DO CHRISTIAN MAN
IN CONCRETE INDUSTRIES BY
TELLING CARP TO TREAT DOMESTIC
AND IMPORTED CEMENT WITH HE
SAME RULES AND CREATE ECONOMIC
VALUE FOR THE CEMENT AND
CONCRETE- SUPPLIERS WITH THE
LOWEST EMISSIONS. CALIFORNIA
HAS THE INDUSTRY'S THE PEOPLE
THE MOTIVATION TO EXECUTE A LOW
CARBON CONCRETE CEMENT STRTEGY
MOVING SB FIVE NINETY SIX
FORWARD WILL NOT ONLY MAKE
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION MORE
SECURE AND CLEAN TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD TO REDUCE EMISSIONS FROM
A MAJOR SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE
GASES ARE ASKED FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
NOW IT'S GONNA DOCUSIGN I FOR
YOU. SCHOOL SOME SCHOOLS. THANK
FROM THE BACK ON COMMITTEE- OUT
OF MY THEM UP OF CIVIL
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING AND
FIELD AT UCLA I MIGHT BE AS
WHERE YOU LIVE IN THE MATERIALS
AMONG CONSTRUCTION YOU KNOW
THANKS AMANDA CONCRETE IM SPIEL
I'VE GOT ANOTHER MISSION THEN
GOT BACK THOSE. I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT TWO MAIN POINTS TODAY
ON THE FIRST POINT ABOUT THAT
EXIST NUMEROUS POCKETS TO CHEAT
MEANINGFUL AND LARGE COMPANIES
AND OPTIONS IMPLEMENTED. POCKET
PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA. YOU
DON'T BAKIT BUT BIG YOU. WITH
HELPING REDUCE THE PROBLEM. OF
CEMENT AND CON. AND THIS CAN TO
COME IN A BUT OF WHERE
INCLUDING THE EXPANDED USE OF
INDUSTRIAL BY PRODUCTS CONCRETE.
IMPROVING HOW EFFECTIVE VIEWS.
ON UTILIZING GOVERNOR OPTIMIST
IN THE PRODUCTION OF CONCRETE.
AND FINALLY EXPANDING THE USE
OF ALTERNATIVE. FUELS IN THE
PRODUCTION OF CEMENT. BOB IS A
ALLOWS ACHIEVE COMMON SENSE
REDUCTION OF CONCRETE A FORTY
MORE BY TWENTY AND POSSIBLY
SOONER. MAKE USE OF CURRENT
MANUFACTURING PROFIT THAT THE
BLACK GENE AND OPTICAL PROPERTY.
JOE THE PRODUCTION OF LOOK I'M
CONCRETE. SECOND ACHIEVING NET
ZERO CEMENTED BUT AND CAL BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE IS INDEED BE
DOUBLE. HOWEVER REQUIRES A SORT
OF ACTION TO DELIVER SCALABLE
AND COST EFFECTIVE ENOUGH TO
TALK NATION. AND HERE WE NEED
TO PAY PARTICULAR FOCUS THE
DEVELOPMENT CHAU UNDER DOC
PROPAGATION SOLUTIONS WITH A
FOCUS ON CARBON DIOXIDE YOU'D
LIKE PATIENT. COMING OUT THAT
SEQUESTRATION AND EXPANDING
RENEWABLE ENERGY INTEGRATION AN.
INVENTIVE MOCK AND BOXES. IN
BIG THIS A MULTIPLE. BOB REDUCE
THE PROBLEM OF CEMENT CONCRETE
PRODUCTION AND IMPORT WHILE
MANY OF THESE IT CAN THE IN THE
IN THE ALTHOUGH THE CHOIR BONTA
BLIND AND FOLLOW DEVELOP. I'VE
BEEN IN SB FIVE NINETY SIX TO
OVERCOME BARRIERS AMPLE PUBLIC
YOU NOT. PUT CONCERTED FOCUS
BAKER ADMISSION AND SIGNIFICANT.
THE CALIFORNIA CEMENT CONCRETE
AND- REDUCE YOUR BUT BY PERCENT
BY TWENTY. MENDOCINO CO IMAGE
BY FORTY BY. WELL THAT THAT
WOULD SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH DOCTOR BRIDGES- OKAY LET'S
A LET'S GO TO THE- BUT I DON'T
SEE ONE HERE IN PERSON OR
TWENTY FORTY- LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES ARE FOR ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL SB FIVE NINETY
SIX. MARIA THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
SB FIVE NINE SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT FOR SB. FIVE NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS VINCENT
MODULAR CONCENTRATE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE EIGHTY YOU
ARE OPEN. AND DINNER BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT DR JIM
STEWART AND THIS IS VERY VERY
EXCITING AND- A KEY NEWS SHOW
GLOBAL EXPENDITURES THIS IS. A
BIG OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE THE
PLANET. NINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
BARBOSA THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT. BY
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHY NINETY NINE PLEASE ON MUTE.
THIS IS BILL MURPHY WITH ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTION NOR CAL IN SO
CAL CHAPTERS AS WELL AS
REPRESENTING THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND AGAIN TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
ALEX JACKSON ON BEHALF OF AN
RTC THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR
AND BLUE PLANET COULD SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ONE SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
WILL GREATER ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
ONE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT'S THE SAME WAY WITH
THE COALITION FOR RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS SUPPORT. LINE ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AT LEAST SANDRA QUIT
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT.
TWENTY SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SURE AND MEMBERS-
BRIDGEMAN YANNI- HE'S TOO MANY
I MEAN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA NEVADA CEMENT
ASSOCIATION REFERENCED BY THE
AUTHOR I REPRESENT ALL CEMENT
MANUFACTURING CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T HAVE A SUPPORT POSITION
BUT WE WANT TO THANK THE
OCCUPANTS STOPPED. IN THE
SPONSORSHIP OPEN COLLABORATIVE
DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE HELD YOU
BELIEVE THERE IS A SOLUTION TO
BE REACHED AT LOWER CARBON
EMISSIONS IMPLEMENT
MANUFACTURING WILL HELP ACHIEVE
THE STATE CARBON GOLDEN
ASSISTING INDUSTRY REACHING
COMMITMENT TO BECOME NET
NEUTRAL BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
OFFICE OF THE BILL. MOVES
THROUGH THE PROCESS THANK YOU.
WHY ONE EIGHTY YOU ARE OPEN.
THE LION IN A POINT I MEAN
FAVOR AT RISK CONTACT SIX. AND
AGAIN TO SHOW FOR FIVE NINETY
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AND
WE WERE ONE SIXTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MARIA'S FAMILY WITH
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION IN
THE COURT. BY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
YOU ARE UP. HI THIS IS DEBBIE
MY TELEPHONE WITH PENINSULA
INTERFACE CLIMATE ACTUALLY
REPRESENT EIGHTEEN
CONGREGATIONS BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND SUNNYVALE NOW WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE. SIX
FIVE NINETY SIX THANK YOU. ONE
ONE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHERYL FINALLY
THE GREENTOWN LOS ALTOS AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
NINETY SIX AND THANK SENATOR
PACKARD. ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SURELY THE GROUND
ELDER I'M AN ACTION BROADEN
SUPPORT. ONE ONE NINETY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AFTERNOON
HEARING MEMBERS AND YOU WONDER
WHAT THE TO CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE NINE SIX ON BEHALF
OF OUR TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP. THANK
YOU SO MUCH OKAY WILL BRING
THE- FIVE BUT WHAT I DON'T
BELIEVE WE HAVE ANY- RICHARD
OPPOSITION- BY THE EARLY
TESTIMONY OR IN THE ANALYSIS-
BUT IF THERE'S ANYBODY
INITIALLY NO ONE IN PERSON IN
EITHER LOCATION BUT IS ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINES YOU WANT TO
RAISE CONCERNS ARE OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL THIS IS NOW THEIR
TIME. THIS SB FIVE NINETY SIX.
TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB FIVE
NINETY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. I KNOW
BUT WHAT WHAT DO WE DO THAT ONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE WE
WILL GO LINE FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL
INVOLVED ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. BECAUSE
THE COMMITTEE HAS TAKEN AN
INTERIM POSITION OF OPPOSING
WHAT THE MEN DID- WE SIMPLY
JUST WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
AND HIS STAFF FOR THEIR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS
OUR CONCERNS WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR. IF YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT MODERATOR OKAY
WE BRING THEM. I DON'T KNOW
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THAT
SENATORS OUGHT. YEAH THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER FOR BRINGING THIS
TOWARDS THE- LONG OVERDUE I
MEAN I'M LOOKING AT YOU KNOW-THE FEDERAL EPA AND THEY'VE-
HAD- CASE STUDIES FROM. TALKING
ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AGO. AND WE
STILL HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING SO.
THIS IS GREAT. BUT MY QUESTION
WAS ACTUALLY JUST. REGARDING
THE LAST CALLER IN HMD'S
POSITION. CAN YOU ENLIGHTEN US
AND GIVE US SOME MORE INSIGHT
ON ON- WHY THEY'RE SUPPORTIVE
OR ANY QUESTIONS THEY HAD.
QUESTION AROUND- AIR QUALITY
AND WE CERTAINLY DO YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE AIR QUALITY CONCERNS
ARE CONSIDERED- AS WE REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES. I THINK THERE
IS SOME CONCERN ABOUT THE EXACT
WAY THAT WE IMPLEMENT THAT IN
THIS IN THIS BILL. AND WE HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE WITH STAKEHOLDERS- AND
ARE LOOKING AT THEIR REQUEST I
THINK THAT WAS THE SPIRIT OF
THE COMMENT WE JUST HEARD GREAT
SO IT'S JUST ON THE TARGETS
THAT YOU'VE OUTLINED THE NOT
THE TARGET PER SE BUT- IT'S IN
THE WAY THAT WE ADDRESS AIR
QUALITY. AND WE BASE TO ALLOW.
IT TOO OFTEN ONE OF THIS NEARBY
CITIES TO OPT INTO THE ONE OF
THOSE CARBS OR TARGET AIR
QUALITY CITIES. AND AND SO
WE'RE JUST DISCUSSING THAT
MECHANISM SO IT'S REALLY HOW
WE- HOW WE TRY TO ENSURE THAT
AIR QUALITY IS CONSIDERED AS
REDUCE GHGS ARE NOT ABOUT THE
TARGETS PER SE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND- YOU KNOW WHAT TO THAT
POINT COULD BE GREAT AS AS
MOVES ALONG TO CONTINUE TO
ENGAGE IN IF IT IF THE SHOULD
PASS TO BE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE
IN THESE- LOCAL STAKEHOLDER
REGIONAL GROUPS AND AIR QUALITY
DISTRICTS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
HAVE- AN OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH
IN AS WELL AS I KNOW YOU WELL
BUT- THANK YOU SENATOR BACK.
THANK YOU FOR POINT I WILL
CERTAINLY DO SO. THANK YOU- I
THINK I HEARD A MOTION FROM
CENTER IT'S ALL SAID AND
SOMEWHERE IN THERE. SO WITH
THAT THAT YOU EVEN CLOSE AS AN
AND APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR A
MINUTE YOU THAT REALLY NEEDS
TO. DESERVES MORE ATTENTION
QUITE FRANKLY FROM OUR ENTIRE.
REGULATORY SYSTEM. SO WITH THAT
PLEASE- PLEASE FOR THANK FOR
THAT THE COMMENTS THE COMMITTEE
I APPRECIATE ONE WHO CALLED IN
AND APPRECIATE AGAIN THE WOULD
BE ABLE TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING INDUSTRY
ON THIS A SOLUTION AND OF
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
OKAY THE ITEMS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DOLLARS. ACCOMPLISH
COLORADO ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB
FIVE NIGHTS SIX BY SENATOR
BAKER THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN HI HI BATES DALY AND
SALAS GONZALEZ I SKINNER. STERN
MARK OWSKI. OKAY ARE THAT THAT
BILL IS SAID TO BE ON CALL. AND
WE APPRECIATE YOU. APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE
SENATOR- I'M I'M I'M FEDERAL
CAPITAL GET THE VOTES BUT TO. I
WAS REACTIVE MORE MEMBERS COME
ON DOWN THANK YOU FOR THE
SENATE. OKAY SENATE LEADERS ON
HIS WAY ARE IT'S WEIRD NEXT
GOING TO HEAR FROM CENTER
LAYERED AND WE CAN GET THAT.
DIS WHITE DOWN SO HE CAN BE
READY. TO PRESENT THIS. YES I
KNOW YOU'RE FOR SOLICITING A-
VOTERS CENTER SKINNER SHOULD WE
HAVE SINISTER PRISON. YEAH
THERE IS OKAY GREAT SENATOR
LAYERED IS GOING TO PRESENT. SB
SIX NINETEEN THIS IS THE WITH
ORGANIC WASTE REGULATIONS- SO
THIS ITEM SIX IN YOUR AGENDA
PACKETS MEMBERS AND YOU MAY
BEGIN WHEN READY SENT EARLIER.
BECAUSE OUR- PROPERTY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I ONLY DO
BILLS THAT ARE CALIFORNIA AREA
CODES SORRY YES YES WELL THE
PROGRAM WILL APPRECIATE THIS
ONE PARTICULAR YEAH YOU KNOW
SO- THE FIRST. HELLO MY COMMENT
SAID GOOD MORNING THAT WAS
APPARENTLY OPTIMISTIC SEPT GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND HIS COMMITTEE OF FOR
WORKING WITH ME AND MY STAFF.
ON THIS PROPOSAL AND THIS BILL
HAS BEEN AMENDED AND I THINK
SOME PEOPLE ARE OPERATING ON
WHERE IT WAS BEFORE AS AMENDED
SO LET ME BE REALLY CLEAR.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETEEN
SUPPORTS CONTINUED EFFORTS BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO ACHIEVE
STATEWIDE ORGANIC WASTE
RECYCLING TARGETS AND CLIMATE
GOALS. S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE BY THEN SENATOR RICARDO
LARA. ESTABLISHED AN AMBITIOUS
PROGRAM AND SCHEDULE FOR
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS LAW AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT ITS
IMPLEMENTATION. THIS BILL WHICH
HAS BEEN AMENDED SINCE FIRST
INTRODUCED NOW KEEPS THE
IMPLEMENTATION DEADLINE. BUT
GIVES LOCAL JURISDICTIONS A
BREAK ON ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES
FOR ONE YEAR. IT FURTHER MY
GOAL TO ADD TO THIS BILL
ADDITIONAL TOOLS THAT WILL HELP
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MEET THE
GOALS WITHIN SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
AND I'M CURRENTLY WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND HAVE HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH CAL RECYCLE
TO ESTABLISH WHAT FORM THAT
HELP MIGHT TAKE RISKS SO IT IS
MY HOPE. THAT A FINAL BILL WILL
HAVE TWO PIECES OF REASONABLE
STEPS TOWARD IMPLEMENTATION
THAT WARRANT A ONE YEAR OLD TO
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES BUT NOT
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION. AND A
LATER SECTION WHICH WILL HAVE
ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH
IMPLEMENTATION I WAS GOING TO
PRESENT A LONG. A DESCRIPTION
OF WHAT THE ORIGINAL BILL DOES
AND WHY IT'S IMPORTANT TO
DIVERT ORGANIC WASTE BUT IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME I'M GOING TO
SAY THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO DO
THAT- BUT WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS TIM CONTRA RAFI THE
ZERO WASTE MANAGER FOR SANTA
CRUZ CUNTY. AND ADRIAN
FIGUEROA THE PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF
PARAMOUNT. AGAIN I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HELP ON THIS BILL AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
IPHONE THANK YOU BRICKYARDS
LET'S GO OVER TO TEN WITH SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAROLINE AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
IN FAVOR OF. SB SIX NINETEEN.
EVERYONE KNOWS IT'S AN INCREASE
COUNTY IS VERY PROACTIVE WHEN
IT COMES TO THE BY MENTAL
PROTECTION A WASTE REDUCTION.
BUT EVEN FOR US MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS TOUGH.
THERE ARE THREE MAIN CHALLENGES.
FIRST THE COST IS ENORMOUS
COVERAGE ESTIMATES THAT WE WILL
NEED THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN
NEW FACILITIES ALONE. THAT MUCH
MORE FOR STAFFING VEHICLES
ANOTHER PROGRAM COSTS. BETTER
TIME LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH THE CONSERVE
AND PRESIDENT OF NATURAL
DISASTERS. LOCAL PANDEMIC
PERSUADING VOTERS ON ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO RAISE RATES ARE
TAXES FOR COMPOSTING IT IS
DIFFICULT TO SAY THE LEAST. THE
SECOND GREATEST CHALLENGES
PERMITTED WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
SEVEN DIFFERENT AGENCIES WHICH
MONTHS MUST SIGN OFF ON OUR
PLANS. SOME OF WHICH ARE QUITE
HOSTILE TO SUCH FACILITIES. ARE
LESS GREAT CHALLENGES TIME.
INTEL CARRIED CYNICAL FINALIZED
THE REGULATIONS TO IMPLEMENT S.
B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH DEVELOPING ORDINANCES.
IMPLEMENTING TAX RATE INCREASES
AMENDING WASTE HAULING
CONTRACTS. FINALIZING PLANS FOR
NEW FACILITIES AND PROGRAMS ALL
OF THESE EFFORTS REQUIRE A
GREAT DEAL OF TIME AND EXPENSE
LOLS WERE ONLY FINALIZED. LESS
THAN A YEAR AGO. YOU MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO HELP TODAY WITH THE OR
THE PERMANENT. BUT YOU CAN BUY
US A LITTLE TIME BY DELAYING
ENFORCEMENT OF THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE IT SEEMS AT LEAST THAT
OUR STATE CAN DO TO EASE THE
BURDEN ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. YEAH THERE'S A NEXT
WITNESS. YES AUDIBLE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON ADRIANA
FIGUEROA ON THE PUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR FOR THE CITY OF
PARAMOUNT. TO THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY LOCATED IN THE
SOUTHEAST AREA OF ALLENTOWN
ALSO KNOWN AS THE GAME WILL BE
JAN OUR CITY IS ABOUT FOUR AND
A HALF FOUR MILES AND IT'S A
FULLY BUILT OUT AND THEN
COMMUNITY WITH APPROXIMATELY.
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND MEDICAL. I
TO THINK ARE OFFERED TO BRING
MOMENT THANK NAY IT'S A YOU SEE
THAT THEY'LL TO. THEM WITH THE
NECESSARY TO COMPLY WITH
ATHLETES NINETY FOUR. PERSONS I
LIKE THE CLARA THAT THESE ARE
NEED WHICH THE GOING HOW GAS
AND AGAIN IT A VERY CO. WE JUST
NEED AT THE KIND EFFECTIVE TO
COMPLY WITH MECHANIC DIVERSIONS
LIKE SHE FASHION. GIVEN THE
IMPACT OF THE CAMP. OF THE CITY
OF PARAMOUNT CURRENTLY THE
PROCESS THE FINAL. WITH VERY
FIND ACTION. THAT THAT'S FOR
THE WORLD TO WHICH SIMILAR
GOALS IT COMES GREENHOUSE GASES.
WE HAVE BEEN ONE PRIOR TO FROM
THE OF THE GOALS. FOR THE
LIMITED WE HAVE ENOUGH DONE A
PRETTY GOOD JOB SO FAR. THIS IS
EVIDENT BY THE FEDERAL BEACON
AWARDS WE HAVE RECEIVED TO DATE
FROM THE INSTITUTE FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. A PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR SOLID WASTE
HAULER GFL ARE- AND ALSO WITH
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL CONSULTING ON
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. I
PROBABLY FIVE OR WEAKENED-
FINALIZES THESE REGULATIONS IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
STONE WOULDN'T PROVIDE MUCH
MORE INFORMATION. THAN THE
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TO
MANDATE. IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THE BULK OF THE COSTS
FOR IMPLEMENTATION WILL FALL ON
A RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES.
THESE ARE THE NUMBER ONE
RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES THAT
ARE CURRENTLY STRUGGLING TO
SURVIVE THE PANDEMIC. WE HAVE
INVESTMENT THE CLOTHING AND
RESIDENTS LOSING THEIR JOBS.
AND OF COURSE THE ONLY SOURCE
OF INCOME SO SB SIX ONE NINE IS
NOT ROLLING BACK OR REPEATING
THE SAME ORGANIC WASTE
DIVERSION. REGULATIONS THE BILL
IS A WORK IN PROGRESS BEFORE
THEN WILL PROVIDE ALL RESIDENTS
AND BUSINESSES SOME BREATHING
ROOM TO IMPLEMENT THESE
REGULATIONS PROPERLY IF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING AND
FLEXIBILITY IN. SPANISH WHY
WITH THE POINT AND CLICK
NINETEEN AND URGE YOU TO VOTE
ON THE BILL THANK YOU TO MOVE
THIS LEGISLATION FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
OKAY LET'S GO TO THE FOR THE-
NOT SEEN ONE IN PERSON. IN
EITHER ROOM LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. IT'S NOT COUNTY
ACCORDING TO POLICY AND I
REALLY WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND IN FACT THEIR TIRELESS WORK
ON THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
BY NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SPEAK CALMLY WITH THE L. A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
THAT ARE ACTIVELY ENGAGED WITH
THE AUTHOR I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IT MOVE FORWARD WANT TO THANK
HIM PROFUSELY FOR BRINGING
OFFICIALLY FORD. ONE ONE NINETY
SEVEN EUROPE. THE FAN ON BEHALF
OF THE TOWN OF APPLE VALLEY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
NINETY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEMBERS PER
THOUGHT HE TALK ON BEHALF OF
STOP WAIT WAIT AT THE STATION
OF NORTH AMERICA LEGISLATIVE
TASK FORCE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WESTERN AFTER WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY ALL OF THE BRAIN
CONTACT AND THINK THE OPERATE
FASTBALL. THEIR WORK ON THE
FILM YOU. ONE ONE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR MEMBERS DIRECT OFTEN HAVE
TO LEAD CALIFORNIA CITIES I
WANT TO THANK GOD FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD WE'RE
SUPPORTING CONCEPT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH. AS A
REMINDER SHOW SUPPORT FOR- SB
SIX NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE TWO ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
MODERATORS ARE WHAT WE KNOW.
HE'S STILL WAITING FOR CALLS.
MODERATOR HELLO HELLO YOU MAY
GO AHEAD WHO'S THAT. OKAY WE I
AM BACK I WAS SOMEHOW I GOT.
YOU DID THERE FOR A MINUTE I
APOLOGIZE MISTER JR OKAY. ARE
WE ALL SET TO GO TO LINE YES
WE'RE ALL SET LIGHT TO A TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD- I'M IN.
OPPOSITION AND I'M IN THE
WRONG- LINE UP HERE BUT I'VE
BEEN OPPOSITION MY NAME IS BILL
LANE FROM DANA POINT AND I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE. OKAY THANK
YOU WE WILL NOTE HI SO NOTED.
ANYONE ELSE- AND- ONE ON THE
LINE SMALLER. YES AND TO SHOW
FOR YOUR SUPPORT RIGHT NOW AT-
FOR SB SIX NINETEEN ONE FILED
BY ZERO AND WE WILL LIKE TO A
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. WORK
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND
COMMITTEE ON THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE IMPLEMENTATION GOING
FORWARD AND HELPING LOCALS
IMPLEMENT THIS MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR. BUYING TOOL FOR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI AUDREY RETIRED
CHECK FROM CRUISE STRATEGIES ON
BEHALF OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. BY TWO
HUNDRED YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS BRIDGET
MCHALE ME OFF AND WE ARE IN OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICE SUPPORT
AND COMMENDED AND ALSO ON THE
OFFICE WE THINK WE- ARE IN
CONTACT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT. THANK YOU. TWENTY
TWO OH FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YOU ARE OPEN TO ALL FIVE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN.
THANK YOU HI THIS IS A LEASE
CONTRACT WITH A CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL BUT WE WANTED TO CALL INTO
A PRE EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
FOR THE AUTHOR WORKING WITH US
TO ADDRESS OUR INITIAL CONCERNS
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH STAFF.
THANK YOU. SURE THAT ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WE HAVE
MICHAEL BASS FROM THE YELLOW
FOOD BANK FOLLOWED BY. IT THE
SALUTES GO TO MICHAEL FIRST.
GREETINGS MY NAME IS MICHAEL
BISH I'MTHE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF YELLOW CREEPING ON SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
NINETEEN AS AMENDED. AND IT'S
DELAYING AND WEAKENING OF
PENALTIES FOR NONCOMPLIANCE
WITH EDIBLE COOPER COVERAGE
MANDATES. WE ARE ALL FAMILIAR
WITH THE LEGAL MAXIM JUSTICE
DELAYED IS JUSTICE DENIED. MAKE
NO MISTAKE THIS BILL REPRESENTS
JUSTICE TONIGHT. INDEED THIS
BILL ACTUALLY PERPETUATE
SYSTEMIC INJUSTICE. REALLY IN
THIS AGE OF RACIAL RECKONING
WHERE IS THE EQUITY INCLUSION
THE COMPASSION. THEY ARE
COMPLETELY ABSENT. I AM NOT A
LOBBYIST I AM NOT AN EXPERT ON
LEGISLATIVE MATTERS I HAVE NO
KNOWLEDGE OF THE MACHINATIONS
OF POLITICAL OR STRATEGIC GOING
ON AROUND THIS BILL. BUT I KNOW
A LOT ABOUT FEEDING MY
STRUGGLING NEIGHBORS IN YOUR
LOCALITY. I LEAD A SMALL ROLE
FOOD BANK FEEDING SIXTY
THOUSAND PLUS INDIVIDUALS MONTH
AFTER MONTH AFTER MONTH. THIS
BILL DOES THE EXACT OPPOSITE IT
FEEDS THE LANDFILL THE DELAYS
MEETING THE NUTRITIONAL NEEDS
OF THOSE LIVING IN POVERTY AND
NEAR POVERTY. IT DELAYS NURSING
TEN MILLION CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLING WITH POVERTY AND
NEAR POVERTY INCLUDING CHILDREN
SENIORS VETERANS FARMWORKERS
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS. AND
HARD WORKING FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
IT'S BEEN NICE TO ARM OF OUR
NEIGHBORS IN THE MIDST OF AN ON
CARILLO PUBLIC HEALTH. ISSUE
ECONOMIC CRISIS. IT DOES SO IN
THE MIDST OF A CLIMATE CRISIS
IMPERILING THE WELL BEING OF
EVERY MAN WOMAN AND CHILD.
PLANET EARTH. AS A COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS MAKES CLEAR THE EDIBLE
FOOD RECOVERY MANDATE HAS BEEN
QUOTE A LONG TIME COMING. THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES HAVE HAD
FIVE YEARS LATER THEIR
PROGRAMS. FIVE YEARS WHAT HAVE
THEY DONE IN THAT TIME.
LOBBYING THE LADY AND
OBFUSCATE. THEIR ARGUMENTS EVEN
NOW ARE DIVORCED FROM THE FAX.
THE CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE A DUTY TO THEIR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS THEY
MUST NOT BE ALLOWED TO SHIRK
THEIR DUTY. APATHY AND
INDIFFERENCE TO SUFFERING AND
DISPARITIES MUST END. NOW AT
THIS TIME AND JUSTICE MUST
BEGIN ALL END WITH A QUOTE FROM
NOBLE PEACE LAUREATE NORMAN
BULLOCK. WITHOUT FOOD MAN CAN
LIVE AT MOST BUT A FEW WEEKS.
WITHOUT IT ALL OTHER COMPONENTS
OF SOCIAL JUSTICE ARE
MEANINGLESS. HELLO WHO THINKING
COURSE YOU TO OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. FOR CONSIDERING OUR
APPEAL FOR COMPASSION. I THINK
YOU SOME THAT'S GOING TO IT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M HIDING IT.
I'M NOT EXPERIENCING FOOD
INSECURITY AT ALL BUT I OPPOSE
SB SIX NINETEEN I'M A CLEAN UP
VOLUNTEER I GO TO CITY COUNCIL
OR THE TIME TO TALK ABOUT THE
PLASTICS. I THINK IT IS JUST
LONG ENOUGH TO CONCLUDE THAT
EVERYTHING WAS DOWN TO
ACCOUNTABILITY. FOR POLITICAL
WELL. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN I
STUMBLED UPON SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE. IN THE NEXT TWO
YEARS OR MORE I WOULD FINISH
CITIES LACK ALL. REASONABLE
EFFORTS. I GOT INCREASINGLY
CURIOUS HOW DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE STATE WE'RE DEALING THANK
YOU DON'T BUY NOW I'VE TALKED
TO AGENCIES FROM THE LAW
BECAUSE FOCAL FROM COLD TO EASE
AND- INCLUDING SOME OF THOSE
ESSENTIAL SUPPORT LETTER. WHY
SEE BUILD HAVE A GREEN BEANS
FOR REPAIR. I WOULD THAT HE
WISEMAN COMP WE- ARE THE CITY
TO SIGN ON AGAIN WASTE TRICOR
CONTRACT BUT WEALTHY. WHAT THE
SHOP AROUND EVEN COMPUTER
TALKING ORGANIC TO ANOTHER
STATE BECAUSE WILL BE CHEAPER.
FINALLY THIS YEAR THEY SAY A
CONTRACT WITH THE SAY COMPANY.
THIS YEAR CITIES ARE ON THE
MOVE THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE
FINES FOR NON COMPLIANCE BUT I
ALSO HEARD THAT THE CITY
COUNCIL THAT WHOLE RECYCLES
FOCUSES ON COMPLIANCE. AND
BIRDS THEY ARE VERY COOPERATIVE
BIG BILL RUSH OUT TO EASE YOU
FINE. THE MOST OBVIOUS PROBLEM
IS THE POLITICAL SPHERE TO
WASTE COLLECTION FEES FOR
ORGANIC WASTE RECYCLING HOW WE
CYCLE ESTIMATED THREE TO FIVE
DOLLAR AMOUNT. INCREASE THE
HOUSEHOLD. EVERY TIME REPORTED
THAT THE TYPICAL AWAITS ABOUT
THREE DOLLARS FIFTY THREE WORTH
OF FOOD. EVERY DAY SO WE HAVE A
LITTLE AGAIN WAY THROUGH. ALL
RIGHT. I'M SEEING GAP BETWEEN.
WELL AND THE POLITICAL
POLITICAL WELL AND PUBLIC IF
I'M I'M I'M SO SCARED NOW IF WE
REACH THE CUT OFF TIME FOR
OPPOSITION STATEMENTS- BUT IF
YOU BUT CERTAINLY. WE'RE VERY
INTERESTED IN AND THEN- AND YOU
SUBMITTING WRITTEN STATEMENTS
BEYOND WHAT YOU'VE ALREADY
STATED THAT WE DO APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION IN YOUR
STATEMENTS AND. AND ENCOURAGE
YOU TO BE IN TOUCH WITH THE
COMMITTEE IS THIS. CLOSE THE
DISK OF THIS BILL CONTINUE. I'M
LET'S GO. I DON'T SEE ONE IN.
BY THE ROOM LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES- TO SEE IF ANYONE
WANTS TO RAISE CONCERNS OR
OPPOSITION TO SB. SIX NINETEEN.
TO OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
NINETEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AND THE
STRUCTURE WILL BEGIN WITH LINE
ONE EIGHTY PLEASE CALL AT. GOOD
AFTERNOON DANIEL BRYAN TO THEY
HAVE THEIR CLUB CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THE BALLOT BUT WE HAD
CONCERNS WITHOUT WITH THE
NATIONALLY CRAFTED. EVERYONE TO
THINK BEYOND BURKE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING TO
IMPROVE THAT SPELL- AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT'S
WORK THANK YOU. PINE THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAPTION
INSURANCE MANY MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE PAPPAS OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE AND I'VE ALSO
BEEN ASKED TO CONVEY COMMENTS
FOR THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL AND THE
MORTGAGE SIERRA CLUB EITHER OF
OUR ORGANIZATIONS HAVE THAT
POSITION ON THE BILL IMPRINT
ALTHOUGH WE DID HAVE STRONG
CONCERNS WITH THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THE BILL. HOWEVER
OFFENDER WHERE'D MENTIONED- THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL HAS BEEN
PLUMMETED AND HE IS COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THEM CAN YOU
CAN OTHER STAKE. TO HELP THE
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ACHIEVE THE GOALS OF. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WITHOUT DELAYING
IMPLEMENTATION. THIRTY ONE
EXPRESS FUTURE TO ALL AND FROM
WITH US I'M NOT CAN TO
CONVERSATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ANYONE ELSE WATER. YES
THERE'S A COUPLE MORE CUED UP-
AS A REMINDER FOR SB SIX
NINETEEN TO SHOW OPPOSITION
ONLY AT THIS TIME- LINE EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE OF
EVERYTHING THAT- THE- OF. BANK
SAID. YOU NEED FROM NOW. FIND
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME IS KIM FLORIDA LIVE
IN PALM DESERT AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL IS CURRENTLY UP PUT
TOGETHER IT NEEDS FURTHER
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. ONE ONE
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU SHARON
SENATORS REMAINS TO BE SEEN
WITH THE WHITEMAN GROUP ON
BEHALF OF TRUE NORTH RENEWABLE
ENERGY OR NATURAL THE BILL AT
THIS TIME BUT CONCERNED ABOUT
THE SIGNAL IT SENDS TO THE
MARKET AND THE MESSAGE IT SENDS
ON CLIMATE CHANGE WE CAN'T
REALLY ACTION TO ADDRESS SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE OSCAR AND HIS STAFF
UNDERFRAME WITH THE AUXILIARY
PROGRESS REDUCE PEOPLE
POLLUTANTS LIKE METHANE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. MR SURE THEY'RE
KNOW THE PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP.
OKAY ARE YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU THANK YOU I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS
MADE BY EVERYBODY INCLUDING
OPPOSITION- JUST WANTING TO
CLARIFY FOR MISS AB FIVE. SHE
TALKED ABOUT HOW I CITIES SHE
RECEIVED MADE REFERENCE THE
CITY'S LACK OF A REASONABLE
EFFORT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THE POINT THAT IF CALIFORNIANS
POWER CYCLE- FINDS IN A
JURISDICTION DID NOT MAKE A
REASONABLE EFFORT TO COMPLY
WITH A THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
AND CARMICHAEL CAN IMPOSE FINES
AND THEY SHOULD. SO THERE'S A
PROTECTION THERE LET ME LET ME
JUST START BY BY SAYING HOW
IMPORTANT THAT SB THIRTY THREE
REGULATIONS ARE FOR ME AND FOR
THIS COMMITTEE. WHEN IT COMES
TO ACHIEVING OUR SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANT GOALS AND- I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE NEW
DIRECTION OF THE AUTHOR'S TECH
AND WE YOU KNOW QUITE FRANKLY
WE ARE NOT COMFORTABLE. WITH
WHERE THE BILL WAS WHEN
ORIGINALLY SUBMITTED- I'M I DO
THINK IN THE END OF THE DAY-
THE AUTHOR WITH THIS NEW
DIRECTION HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO
RELIEVE ANXIETY- NOTED THAT
SOME OF OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
HAVE BEEN FEELING WITHOUT
COMPROMISING OUR CLIMATE GOALS
AND- I WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT
I THINK- YOU KNOW WHAT'S
AWESOME IT. WAS ALSO NEEDED BY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WHAT WHAT
WE WILL REALLY GET THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO START
IMPLEMENTING THE ORGANIC WASTE
REDUCTION PROGRAMS IS A FUNDING
MECHANISM IN THE AUTHOR AND I
HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT THIS ON THE
FLOOR. SOME SOME SORT OF ONE
TIME APPROPRIATION FOR THE
GENERAL FUND OR G. G. OR F. TO
HELP COVER THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS START UP COSTS.
THIS REALLY YOU COMPLIANCE IN
WITH WITH THIRTY THREE IS NOT
EASY. WE ALWAYS KNEW THAT AND-
AND YEAH WE'VE NEVER REALLY
INTERESTED- BUDGETARY EARLY AND
SO IT'S A SOME SORT OF FUNDING
MECHANISM I WOULD IN THURSDAY'S
YES WE SUPPORT AYE AYE I KNOW.
EITHER THE AUTHOR SHARES THAT
THAT SENTIMENT- YOU KNOW FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE WE REALLY WANT
TO HELP JURISDICTIONS COMPLY
WITH THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE THIS
IS- THAT'S THE THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT STEP IN. AND OF
COURSE THE COMPLIANCE MEANS
HELPING US ALL ACHIEVE OUR- OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. SO I UNDERSTAND
YOU MAY ALREADY BE.
CONTEMPLATING INSERTING SOME
SORT OF FUNDING INTO THE BILL
I'M VERY INTERESTED IN SEEING
WHAT DEVELOPS THERE I DO WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE FOR HEARING OUR
CONCERNS FOR HEARING OPPOSITION
CONCERNS AS YOU CAN AS YOU
CONTINUE O WORK ON GETTING
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS FUNDING
ASSISTANCE I DO THINK THAT THE
DIRECTION YOU'VE TAKEN. HIM AND
MAYBE SOME OF THE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL ISN'T FULLY AWARE OF
THE DIRECTION YOU'VE TAKEN WITH
THE BILL I THINK IT. IT'S
CERTAINLY GOING TO GO A LONG
WAY TOWARD. TOWARD ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE CORE CONCERNS HE
HEARD ON THE OPPOSITION SIDE
IT'S REALLY SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WE HAD OVER HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE. SO I DO VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE. AND ENGINEERS
WOULD LOVE TO OPEN UP THE FLOOR
TO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS THOUGHTS FROM.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IF THEY ARE
IF THEY HAVE ANY. OKAY PARTISAN
GONZALEZ IS MOVE THE BILL. I'M
SEEING NO OTHER SUBSTANTIVE
COMMENTS- WILL BRING IT BACK TO
YOU- AUTHORED TO. ADD TOOK TO
CLOSE I KNOW IT'S LATE BUT
JUST. LET ME APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF THE CHAIR. BECAUSE
OF THIS IS NOT THE ORIGINAL
BILL. THIS REALLY IS. CENTRALLY
ABOUT FACILITATING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS LAW.
BOTH WITH A SLIGHT BREAK TO
CITIES BUT NOT IN THE
REQUIREMENT NOT IN MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS OF IMPLEMENTATION
BUT I THE END FOR SMITH FOUR
YEAR. RIGHT AND I AM REALLY
COMMITTED THEIR MEETINGS NEXT
WEEK. A WITH STAKEHOLDERS. AND
OUR HAPPY TO INCLUDE THE
COMMITTEE. AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT THAT SECOND HALF OF
THE BILL IS. A AND IT. AND BOTH
THOSE THINGS SPEAK TO THE
OPPOSITION FROM THE YOLO FOOD
BANK PERSON AT AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY IT SUBMITS WORKED WITH
MY FOOD BANK FOR FORTY. YEARS I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK HE
DOES AND THE DAY HE'S DOING THE
FOOD. TO SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN YOLO COUNTY BUT HE'S WRONG
ON THIS BILL. BECAUSE BASICALLY
THIS IS COMMITTED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION. AND THIS MIGHT
WELL WITH A FINANCIAL SOURCE
FOR OTHER TOOLS. AND TOGETHER
WITH. JUST THE RIGHT ON
ENFORCEMENT NOT A DELAY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL
BECAUSE EVERYBODY DIDN'T KNOW
THIS IS COMING BUT NOBODY KNEW
COVERED WAS COMING. THIS WILL
GET US THERE SO I'M COMMITTED
TO DO THAT TONIGHT PROPITIATED.
SOME OF THE COMMENTS. IN THE
OPPOSITION SECTION WITH WANTING
PHOTO WILL CONTINUE TO WORK.
NOT OPPOSED TO THIS VERSION OF
THE BILL FOR WHERE THEY WORK TO
THE FIRST. AND SO. I'M REALLY
COMMITTED TO MAKING THIS A
WINNING SITUATION AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR YOUR I.
PHONE CURRENT. THANK YOU ARE A
CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE TO MOVE
SENATORS ARE. BY THE NUMBERS SB
SIX ONE NINE SENATOR TO THE MO
IS PASS FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE A PER. ALLEN FIVE. I
BATES. DALLY GONZALEZ AND SALAS
HI SKINNER- SKINNER AYE STERN I
CASTING. BARCLAYS CENTER- WILL
LEAVE THAT OPEN- FOR FOLKS THAT
ON THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK
YOU WILL LOOK FOR TO WORK
COMMUTER AND THAT. OKAY ARE WE
NEXT HAVE OUR FRIEND CENTER
WEST SO- WHO'S HERE. AND DONE
FOR YOU KNOW THAT I WAS SO
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE SIX TWENTY
FOUR- YOU KNOW ENVIRONMENT
EQUITY AND I'M DOCTOR ACCESS
ACT WAS PUT ON CONSENT AND IS
ALREADY HAS A LOT TO GET OUT-
BUT YOU'RE HERE PRESENTING SB
SIX NINETY SEVEN. NOT WHICH
WHICH HAS TO DO WITH THEM GREEN
URGING PROGRAM UNDER CAP AND
TRADE. AND THE FORTY YEAR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS ARE REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY PERCENT S. B.
SIX NINE. SEVEN THIS BILL A SIX
TWO X. SIX SALARIED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF BURKE- AND
PRODUCTION AND DEPLOYMENT OF
CLEAN HYDROGEN BY REQUIRING THE
CALIFORNIA REESE'S REPAIR.
RESOURCES BOARD TO CONSIDER
DEVELOPING AND IMPLEMENTING A
GREEN GIANT GREEN HYDROGEN
CREDIT PROGRAM ON OR BEFORE
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF
TWENTY. TWENTY THREE AND OF
COURSE- I DO WANT TO STATE OR
WILL BE TAKING THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE STAFF I KNOW WE WERE.
WORKING ON THOSE AMENDMENTS TO
THIS MORNING AND- AND- I STILL
FEEL THE SOME AREAS WHERE I
THINK WE JUST TO WORK BUT- BY.
WE WANT WORK ON THE BILL I
THINK GENERALLY WERE WERE WERE
WORKING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR
BEEN ACCESSIBLE MEAN OPEN TO
REALLY DISCUSS IN THIS. BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GO
SOMEWHERE WITH THIS- THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM WE
DIDN'T DO NEED TO. DIVERSIFY
CALIFORNIA'S ENERGY PORTFOLIO
AND WE ARE REALLY GETTING THAT-
SOLVE IN THE CLIMATE CRISIS
RELATED TO CUT CLIMATE
POLLUTION. HOW MANY OF YOU
KNOW- THE UNITED NATIONS SAID
AS- RECENTLY AS THIS YEAR
FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AT
THE CURRENT LEVELS OF. CLIMATE
POLLUTION ARE VERY VERY FAR
FROM PUTTING US. ON ANY REAL
PATHWAY TO MEET OUR PARIS
AGREEMENT GOALS. LAST NIGHT'S
SPEECH BY THE PRESIDENT LAST AT
LEAST GIVE ME SOME HOPE THAT
WERE WERE WE'RE GONNA
XCELERATED NATIONWIDE AND WE
REALLY NEED. THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY- WORKING TOGETHER
TOWARD THIS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THAT IT IS TAKEN AN ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO CHANGE
CALIFORNIA'S PATHWAY TO. GREET
KANEMI UP WE WOULD BE THERE
MUCH EASIER IF IT WASN'T SO
EXPENSIVE TO. TO DEVELOP THESE
ENERGIES AND MAKE HIM. YOU
BRING THEM TO A POINT. WHERE
CONSUMERS CAN AFFORD THEM SO WE
YOU KNOW WE CAN'T PUT. OUR RATE
PAYERS OUT OF BUSINESS IN AN
ADVOCATING FOR CLIMATE POLICY I
THINK THERE'S A BALANCE. WE
HAVE TO FIND THAT RIGHT BALANCE
AND IT'S VERY HARD TO DO AND UP
TO NOW CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
LEADER. AT FINDING THAT BALANCE.
AND IT'S ALWAYS A FIGHT HERE IN
THE FLOOD LEGISLATURE CAN ARE
MOVING FORWARD WITH THE GREEN
ECONOMY AND FINDING A WAY TO.
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT ON
RATEPAYERS AND TAXPAYERS. THAT
AND IT'S VERY HARD THING TO DO
SO WE REALLY LOOKED AT THIS
BILL AS A MEANS OF TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT AND- ATTRACTING
INVESTMENT. TO CALIFORNIA IN
THE MILLIONS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND ALSO- DIVERSIFYING
OUR PORTFOLIO SO. I DID IN THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THE OF THE COMMITTEE
AND STUFF AND THE CHAIR WORKING
WITH US BECAUSE WE WEREN'T
REALLY WANT TO GET A TO
POSITION WHERE THIS PROGRAM.
COULD TAKE OFF BECAUSE GREEN
HYDROGEN IS THE GREENEST OF. OF
THE- HYDROGEN TECHNOLOGIES IT
ALSO. CAN HELP US- THE-
TRANSITION FROM OTHER KIND OF
FUELS INTO MORE RENEWABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE FUEL TO VERY
EXCITING. INDUSTRY THAT WE CAN
REALLY. DEVELOP HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND IN AND OUT AGAIN
SEND IT TO OTHER PARTS OF THE
WORLD IN. CALIFORNIA COULD BE A
LEADER REALLY ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE LIKE WE HAVE
BEEN. AND THROUGH THIS BILL WE
CAN REALLY DO THAT SO. I WANNA
THANK EVERYONE- WORKING WITH ME
ON THIS WE HAVE SOME WITNESSES
TODAY- STEPHANIE WILLIAMS. WITH
INNERGEX RENEWABLE DEVELOPMENT
USA AND WE ALSO HAVE BILLS SO
WILL HE SEE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
BUSINESS COUNCILS AND THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT HAD SOME COMMENTS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AND I
WANNA TO PUT THE SUPPORT IN THE
DIRECTION OF THE CHAIR ASKED
THAT THEY BE ALLOWED TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE ABSOLUTELY. THE
FIRST OPENING. IF. DEPUTY
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I WORK FOR- MY NAME
IS STEPHANIE WILLIAMS I WORK
FOR INTERJECTION NOBLES USA AND
WE ARE A RENEWABLE ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT COMPANY. WITH
ELEVEN HUNDRED- MAKE A LOTS OF
OPERATING- FACILITIES IN THE
UNITED STATES M. FIRST I'D LIKE
TO THINK I'M SENATE HUESO FOR
ANYTHING ABOUT AND ALSO I'D
LIKE TO THINK CENTER ALLEN FOR
SPENDING THE TIME AND EFFORT
WITH THE STAFF TO HELP. THE
BILL GET TO A BETTER PLACE-
GIVEN THAT THE MEMBERS CAME
TOGETHER SO QUICKLY AND AT THE
LAST MINUTE WE WANT TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF TO MAKE
SURE THAT IT THIS IS A GOOD
BILL FOR EVERYONE WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR IS THE MARKET
SIGNAL AND THAT'S WHAT WHAT IT
TAKES TO TAKE PROJECTS THAT ARE
A HUNDRED MILLION TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND BRING THEM TO CALIFORNIA
AND WE WANT TO DO THAT- AND BUT
WE NEED TO MARKET SIGNALS THERE
SO THAT WHEN WE WANT TO GET TAX
EQUITY CREDIT. THAT PEOPLE WILL
COME ALONG AND SUPPORT PROJECTS
LIKE THIS- WEEK WE BELIEVE
WE'RE GOING TO GET TO A CARBON.
FREE FUTURE AND THESE REALLY
HARD INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES.
OPTIMUM PLACE TO LEAD TO GET
GREEN HYDROGEN A LITTLE BIT
AGREED HYDROGEN THAT'S A REALLY
LONG WAY. WE WILL WE BELIEVE WE
CAN. MAKE THESE CHANGES WITH
THE GREEN HYDROGEN IN A WAY THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND THE
BATTERY MARKETS MOVE FORWARD.
AND STARTING IN IN THIS AREA
WHETHER TRADE EXPOSED PEOPLE.
IT'S JUST THE PERFECT PLACE TO
KEEP COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
BUILDING. LARGE COMMERCIAL
FACILITIES HERE AND- THANK YOU
AND THIS IS. A REALLY GREAT
DIRECTION. THANK YOU. SO MUCH.
OKAY- YOUR NEXT I GUESS WE- WE
HAVE SIERRA. THIS HERE IS THERE
IS THERE A- OKAY. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SERVICE
SOMEONE ELSE AND FOR CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX NINE SEVEN
BECAUSE THIS BILL PROVIDES A
POLICY STRUCTURE THAT PROMOTES
INVESTMENT. IN A GREEN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION THREE HUNDRED
PRODUCTION AND USE WILL BE
NEEDED TO RETAIN CALIFORNIA'S
HEAVY MANUFACTURING BASE THAT
IS MADE OF HARD TO DECARBONISE
INDUSTRIES. SB SIX NINE SEVEN
INVITES INVESTORS TO HELP
FOSTER NEW GREEN HYDROGEN
PROJECTS WHILE RETAINING GOOD
PAYING JOBS AND LEAD TO THE
CREATION OF NEW JOBS. THE STATE
NEEDS TO SEND A SIGNAL TO THE
MARKET THAT WE WANT TO RETAIN
OR HEAVY INDUSTRIES. GOOD
PAYING JOBS IN THE TAX BASE
THAT COMES WITH IT ALL MAKING
THE SECTOR CLEANER IN CARBON
FREE. THIS BILL PROVIDES A STEP
IN THAT DIRECTION. WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE THE CENTER PLAN IN
THIS BILL FOR THESE REASONS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTES THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OKAY I
DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE IN PERSON
EITHER ROOM LET'S GO TO THE
PHONE LINES TO- TO JUST
EVERYTHING WE WANT TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SB SIX NINETY
SEVEN PHONE LINES MODERATOR.
THANK YOU TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SB SIX NINETY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
HELLO AGAIN TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR
SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BUT
WE DO HAVE ONE PARTICIPANT
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT.
TO BE
WITH US MOMENTARILY EVERYBODY
ELSE COULD HIT. ONE ZERO.
BAILABLE REPLYING TO A WEAPON
PLEASE GO AHEAD TO ELEVEN. SH
CALTRAIN HOUSTON UNITED
STEELWORKERS DISTRICT TWELVE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU. BY NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BILL MURPHY
WITH ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION NOR
COUNSEL CAL CHAPTER OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED ARE CONCERNED
AND WILL WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
ON THIS IS THAT GREEN SHOULD
ONLY APPLY TO ELECTROLYTIC
PRODUCED HYDROGEN AGAIN THE USE
OF WATER I ONLY WATER THE
FEEDSTOCK AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
AS ANY SO FOR. THE PROCESSING
ENERGY GREAT HYDROGEN WOULD
LIKE TO FIND A WAY TO DEFINE
THAT INTO THE BILL IS THAT
WHICH USES FOSSIL FUEL
FEEDSTOCKS BIOMASS BIO WASTE IN
AND ALSO USER- PROSECUTORS FOR
THE POWER SOURCE WE'D LIKE TO
SEE THOSE DEFINITIONS IN OF MY
WORK WORK WITH THE AUTOMATIC
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR YOU
I'M WHAT WILL YOU KNOW I DIDN'T
GET THAT OFF BECAUSE THERE IS
NO OTHER- THAT. OPPOSITION WITH
THIS SO I WILL TAKE THAT AS
SOME OPPOSITION TESTIMONY BY
ANYONE. ELSE ON THE CALL-
MODERATOR. NOT AT THIS TIME
OKAY- HOW ABOUT ON THE UP. SIDE
FOLKS- ON THE FOR. MYERS I
DON'T SEE HERE PER. A TO SHOW
OPPOSITE AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PUT OUT FOR SB SIX NINE SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
WE ARE HAVING ALL PARTICIPANTS
QUEUE UP AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH A PART OF- PERSONAL
THANK YOU SENATOR HI HI I DO
AND I WILL SAY I WANT TO THANK
CENTER WAS SO CENTER SKINNER
CENTER ARCHULETA FOR- YOU KNOW
BRINGING UP. ALL OF THESE
ISSUES RELATED TO HYDROGEN I
REALLY IT MAKES ME THINK THAT
THIS COMMITTEE I TO HAVE-
INFORMATIONAL HEARING AT SOME%
POINT- VIA PERHAPS THIS YEAR ON
THIS TOPIC BECAUSE THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY GENERATE A LOT OF
INTEREST AMONGST MEMBERS AND- I
THINK AND WE'VE ALL BEEN TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT IF. A SMART PATH
MOVING FORWARD ON THIS TOPIC.
AND SO I THINK THE I THINK THAT
OF THE CRUX OF THE CONCERN AND
YOU KNOW THAT THAT WAS FROM
THIS COMMITTEE ON THIS ISSUE
AND I KNOW THE AUTHOR AND I
TALKED ABOUT THIS. WAS THE
MECHANISM OF DIRECT ALLOWANCE
ALLOCATION BEING USED- I HAD A
YOU KNOW- OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW
WE'RE TALKING A LOT THIS WEEK
ABOUT GREEN HYDROGEN WHAT IT IS
WHAT STANDARDS NEED TO BE
APPLIED TO PRODUCING IT WHAT'S
HOLDING IT BACK NOW WHAT ROLE
TO PLAY IN CALIFORNIA THE LIST
GOES ON AND ON WE'RE GONNA TALK
ABOUT A FURTHER TODAY. ON VERY
IMPORTANT NEW ONES
CONVERSATIONS- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY LOOKING VERY MUCH
FORWARD TO WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE STAKEHOLDERS.
DOT IN THERE IS COMMITTEE ON
THIS TOPIC I'M I'VE WHEN I VERY
MUCH WELCOME THE INPUT FROM MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE AS
WELL ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE. SO
I THINK THE STICKING POINT FOR
US. HAS NOT BEEN GREEN HYDROGEN
IT'S BEEN ON THE ALLOWANCE
ALLOCATION- YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW.
WE'VE WE'VE VERY BEEN VERY
COMMITTED IS COMMITTED TO
UPHOLDING THE GOALS OF SB
THIRTY TWO IN CAP AND TRADE.
AND YOU KNOW I RECOGNIZE THE
FACT THAT THE ORIGINAL SB TWO
SB THIRTY TWO MACINNES AND AB
THIRTY MECHANISM HAD- SOME
DIRECTION AS OPPOSED IT WITH
REGARDS TO ALLOWANCES. SINCE
THEN THERE HAVE BEEN THERE
HASN'T BEEN ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
BOB AND THE ACTIVE ALLOWANCES
TO PRODUCERS AT DIRECTLY IS A
DEPARTURE FROM HOW WE'VE DONE
THINGS AND I THINK- YOU KNOW
THE ISSUE OF COURSE IS. HOW DO
WE BALANCE THE INCENTIVE
POSITION OF USING OF TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZE. AGREED HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION EVEN TALKING ABOUT-
SENATOR. WITH WITH OUR GOALS TO
TRULY CAP EMISSIONS AND CHIEF
CAP AND TRADE SCHOOLS AND GIVE
THE AIRPORT THE- YOU KNOW THE
KIND OF IMPROVE POWER THEM TO
DO THE WORK THEY NEED TO DO TO.
TO GET THERE. SO WE OBVIOUSLY
RECOGNIZE THE BILL'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN
WILLING TO WORK WITH US TO
COMMIT SOME AMENDMENTS THAT WE
SOME OF THESE CONCERNS. BOB
SPECIFICALLY THE AUTHOR WILL BE
AMENDING THE BILL TO INSTEAD OF-
DIRECTING AIR BE TO CREATE THIS
GREEN HYDROGEN CREDIT PROGRAM
HAVE THEM FIRST CONSIDER IT
MAKING A DETERMINATION THAT
DOING SO WOULD BE INEFFECTIVE
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM. I KNOW ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY I THINK THE
SPONSORS WERE- YOU'RE
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS IS
BECAUSE- IT WOULD IT WOULD IT
WOULD CREATE A- BY DOING WHAT
WE'RE DOING HERE IT WOULD IT
WOULD. IT WOULD- AREA FIFTY
YEAR BE DOES DECIDE TO ADOPT
THIS IT WOULD MAKE IT A FASTER
PROCESS. THAN THAN THE LONG
PROCESS IS ASSOCIATED WITH.
THEIR ADOPTION NOW WITHOUT THIS
BILL- BUT I CERTAINLY I THINK
BY THE COMMITTEE ULTIMATELY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE BE
REALLY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CONSIDER THE IMPACTS OF
CREATING A PROGRAM THAT WE GIVE
THEM SPACE EITHER GO FORWARD
WITH THAT OR NOT BASED ON
THEIR- THEIR OWN JUDGMENT. SO
ANYWAY WE FIGURE THIS PATH FOR
THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS. SO
WHILE UNFORTUNATELY ANALYSIS
DOESN'T REFLECT. THESE CHANGES
WE DO HAVE COPIES OF THE MARKUP
THAT'S BEING SUBMITTED TO
COUNCIL TO PASS AROUND I DO
THINK- ONCE AGAIN I DO THINK IT
WILL LAY- THE OPPOSITION
CONCERN. THAT WE HEARD ON THE
PHONE LINES. COTTON AND SOME OF
THE CONCERNS- YOU KNOW THAT
SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO'VE GOT
NEUTRAL SO I DO APPRECIATE ONCE
FLEXIBILITY AS WE CONTEMPLATE
THESE- THESE CHANGES I LOOK FOR
IT OR DISCUSSION TODAY AND ALSO
WITH THE SKINNER BILL- AND WITH.
THOSE COMMENTS LIKE TO OPEN THE
FLOOR TO. QUESTIONS CONCERNS
DISCUSSED FROM COMMITTEE.
SENATE AND HOUSE. YES THANK YOU
SENATOR WESSEL FOR BRINGING
THIS WHERE I WAS ACTUALLY JUST
TALKING TO MY CHIEF AS WELL
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE DO
ABSOLUTELY NEED AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
HYDROGEN AND WOULD LOVE TO AND
INCLUDE A LOT OF THAT-
STAKEHOLDERS SO WE CAN HAVE A
REALLY ROBUST DISCUSSION ON HOW
TO I WAS JUST SAYING THAT I WAS
JUST TALKING TO MY CHIEF ABOUT
THAT SAME EXACT THING SOME ON
THE SAME- SPACE MIND SPACES
YOU- YOU KNOW. HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THIS GIVEN THE FACT THAT THIS
IS NOW- SOMETHING THAT THE AIR
IF YOU CAN CONSIDER- AND I KNOW
THAT THEY WILL CERTAINLY I HOPE
THAT THEY DO. FROM CONSIDER
THIS- AS WELL AND THEN I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY I KNOW IT'S
IN HERE FOR JUST TO PUT ON
RECORD BECAUSE I THINK ONE OF
THE- ONE OF THE CALLERS HAD
MENTIONED- DEFINING. GREEN
HYDROGEN AS ELECTROLYTIC AND IT
IS SO I JUST WANT TO CONFIRM
THAT BECAUSE I THINK THERE WAS
SOME CONFUSION THERE BUT- AS
WELL MAKE SURE YOU. OKAY GREAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUSSELL. I
KNOW. OKAY. GREAT CENTERS CAN-
YES THE A IN INFORMATIONAL
HEARING WOULD BE GREAT BECAUSE
WE'RE OBVIOUSLY IN A PRECIPICE
WE APPRECIATE I THINK WE ALL IN
THE MOVING ALL THESE BILLS
APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S A REAL
ROLE FOR HYDROGEN IN SO MANY
ASPECTS OF. NOT ONLY OUR
CLIMATE GOALS BUT ALSO OUR AIR
QUALITY GOALS AND WE WANT TO
GET IT RIGHT SO I AM SUPPORTING
THE BILL OUT AND- GLAD THAT
THE- COMMITTEE WORKED WITH YOU
AND YOU TOOK THE AMENDMENTS AND
I THINK WORK YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY- THERE'S- A AS- AS WE
GIVE AGENCIES YOU KNOW IF. IF
ALL THE DIFFERENT BILLS GET
SIGNED OR YOU KNOW THEN
AGENCIES ARE GOING TO BE
LOOKING FOR THEY'RE GOING TO
DEVELOP BREAKS OBVIOUSLY AND WE
GET IT'S GOOD FOR US NOT TO BE
TOO OVER PRESCRIPTIVE PREZ.
CLEARLY THE DAY WILL DO
ANALYSIS AND RESEARCH IN
SECTION ADD TO YOU KNOW OUR
THINKING AND- HELP US GET IT
RIGHT BUT I THINK AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING TO GREAT
IDEA BUT ALSO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND APPRECIATE AS I SAID. THE
AUTHORS WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND TAKING.
MEASUREMENTS THANK YOU. WELL
THANK YOU ARE SAY I HEARD A
MOTION SENATE SKINNER. SAID IT
WAS A HALF. FIVE FIVE SEVEN.
WE'VE EVEN. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE CALL VERY SPUR
OF COMMON AND JUST- GENERALLY
DOES STATE THAT- I THINK THIS
IS. OUR REALLY POOR BILL ON ON-
IN IN SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE BY- CENTER SKINNER
INCIDENT AS A GONZALEZ I
COMPLETELY AGREE AND THAT'S
KIND OF TURN THE DIRECTION WE
WANT TO MOVE SEPARATE SHARE
YOUR SUPPORT YOUR COMMENTS AND
MASS FOR NOVEL. I THINK YOU'RE
SEEING I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THIS
THIS TOPIC IS GENERATING A LOT
OF INTEREST FROM MEMBERS AND-
IF I COULD JUST ADD JUST.
WANTED A STATE CENTER ARCHULETA
DID START A SELECT COMMITTEE ON
ON- YES I UNDERSTAND THAT YEAH
ON HYDROGEN AND- THE GOAL IS TO
GET US AND I UNDERSTAND CENTER
SKINNER SITS ON THAT COMMITTEE
I'LL BE WORKING ON THAT
COMMITTEE TO AND WE WILL BE
HAPPY PUBLIC HEARINGS THIS
YEAR. AND HOPEFULLY NEXT YEAR
AS WELL TO TALK ABOUT THIS
INDUSTRY ANNOUNCES CRONY CITING
AND I GUESS THERE'S A LOT A LOT
OF THINGS FOR US TO UNDERSTAND
IT'S VERY TECHNICAL AND HOW IT
RELATES TO THE- OVERALL PROGRAM.
OF GREEN ENERGY SO. I LOOK
FORWARD TO. WITH OF YOU TO THAT
CA. WERE AS HE THAT CAN CAN
HELP EDUCATE A- WE WILL AB
REACH OUT TO THE COMMITTEE AND
AM AND WORK ON AND- SOMETHING
TOGETHER WITH THEM HUSBY FIVE
TESTS AGAIN. GREAT OKAY. AS A
MOVED BY CENTER SKINNER- STATUS
KADAMBAS KALRA. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB SIX NINE SEVEN BY
SENATOR HUESO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ALAN HI ALAN I BATES. DALLY
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I SKINNER
SKINNER AYE STERN Y. CASKEY.
OKAY REGULAR BASIS BRADFORD
CENTER WITH A- ALRIGHT LET'S GO
OVER TO- CENTER SKINNER'S BILL
NOW CENTER DOLLIES STAND OVER
AND SAID TO SO WILL WILL WILL
CUT S. B. EIGHTEEN YOU COULD
PRESENT FROM YOUR DESK IF YOU
WANT OR WHAT IT'S UP TO YOU
IT'S ENTIRELY UP TO OKAY. OKAY
YOU MAY PURSUE. WHEN REASON
THIS. THANK THANKS VERY MUCH TO
HEAR AND THINK YOU YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS BECAUSE WE
ABSOLUTELY WE DO WANT TO GET
THIS RIGHT AND SO THE-
AMENDMENTS I'M ACCEPTING OR
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING OUT
THE DEFINITION OF GREEN
HYDROGEN AND THE CLARIFICATION
OF OUR PS ELIGIBILITY OUT OF
THE BILL SO THAT WE CAN WORK
WITH NOT ONLY STAKEHOLDERS BUT
ALSO CLEARLY THE- OUR COMMITTEE
STAFF AND OTHERS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- THAT WE DO OUR BEST TO
GET IT RIGHT I MEAN WE NOTE
BOOK THERE'S- A THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE THAT WE EVER WILL GET
SOMETHING PERFECT HOWEVER WE'RE
GONNA DO OUR BEST TO IMPROVE
IT. AND SO I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
THOSE MEASUREMENTS- THE VERY
INTERESTING THING ABOUT
HYDROGEN. HI- YOU KNOW I CAME
INTO THE LEGISLATURE WHEN
SCHWARZENEGGER WAS GOVERNOR AND
HE WAS THE BIG ADVOCATE AND I
AS NOT A SUPPORTER OF HYDROGEN
AT THAT TIME. I MEAN THE
INTERESTING THING IS HYDROGEN
THE MOST BASIC AND MOST- IT'S
AN ABOVE ONE OF THE MOST
ABUNDANT ELEMENTS IN THE ENTIRE
UNIVERSE SO. YOU KNOW IF YOU
CAN HARNESS IT CORRECTLY YES
YOU WANT TO USE IT HOWEVER.
THAT THE POINT THAT GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER WAS ADVOCATING
FOR HYDROGEN WE WERE NOT
ANYWHERE NEAR THE PLACE WHERE
WE COULD PRODUCE IT FROM
RENEWABLE SOURCES. IN IN FACT
THE HYDROGEN THAT WE'RE
PRODUCING WAS EVEN MORE CARBON
IN TESTS. BECAUSE OF THE
QUANTITY OF FOSSIL FUELS THAT
WAS USED TO PRODUCE IT SO IN
EFFECT IT WAS NOT A BENEFIT IT
WAS A BENEFITTED FROM A TAIL
PIPE IN TERMS OF. TAIL PIPE
EMISSIONS BUT YOU YOU KNOW WAS
NOT USEFUL FOR. MANY OF OUR
GOALS HOWEVER. TECHNOLOGIES
HAVE ADVANCED MORE RESEARCH HAS
BEEN DONE AND WE ARE PRODUCING
SO MUCH RENEWABLE ENERGY THAT
WE HAVE THE CAPACITY. TO
PRODUCE HYDROGEN AND THEN YOU
IT'S A VERY FLEXIBLE BECAUSE IT
CAN BE UTILIZED FOR FUEL OR
UTILIZED FOR STORAGE ENERGY
STORAGE ELECTRICITY STORAGE. OR
UTILIZED IMAGE JUST HAS A LOT
F CAPABILITIES SO- THERE ALSO
WHEN I SAY RENEWABLE ENERGY I.
ALSO REFER REFERENCE THINGS
LIKE WASTE THAT. OUR BIO GASSER
ACQUISTARE FORCE WASTE THAT
THOSE THINGS COULD ALSO BE
PRODUCTIVELY USED TO PRODUCE
HYDROGEN. ARMS AND MUCH OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE WITHIN THE FOSSIL FUEL
SYSTEM COULD POTENTIALLY BE
USED FOR HYDROGEN WHICH WOULD
HELP US RETAIN SOME OF THE JOBS
IN THAT SECTOR AS WE MOVE OFF
OF FOSSIL FUELS. SO WHILE THE
BILL DOES NOT- GUARANTEE ANY
THAT IT POSITIONS CALIFORNIA TO
BEGIN PLANNING IN THAT WAY SO
THAT WE CAN TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE
AND IT SENDS A MARKET SIGNAL
SO. IT VANCE'S GREEN HYDROGEN
BY REQUIRING OUR AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES
TO START PLANNING FOR THIS. MAN
TO- INCLUDED IN THE SCOPING
PLAN AND IT CLARIFIES THAT
GREEN ELECTRIC CHARGING SHOULD
BE INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S
PLANNING FOR RESOURCE ADEQUACY
BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE A
STATUTORY DEFINITION FOR GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN. AND IT
REQUIRES THE PC TO ADD GREEN
ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN INTO ANY
FUTURE STORAGE PROCUREMENT
MANDATES AND I'D LIKE TO HAVE
MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT JANICE
LAND. FROM THE GREEN HYDROGEN
COALITION AND MARIAN BERGESON
FROM IN OUR DC. THANK YOU
MICHAEL SERVICES. THANK
SENATORS THANK YOU CARE ALLEN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS JANET PLAN AND I'M THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF THE
GREEN HYDROGEN COALITION WERE
FIVE OH ONE C. THREE NONPROFIT
MISSION IS TO ADVANCE GREEN
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION AND USE AT
SCALE TO ACCELERATE MULTI
SECTORAL DECARBONISATION. IN
HYDROGEN GAME CHANGE ARE FIVE
AGAINST CLIMATE CHANGE BECAUSE
IT WILL ENABLE THE- OF HARD
WOULD BE ACTORS THAT ARE NOT
EASILY ELECTRIFY. AND MAINTAIN
GOOD PAYING JOBS IN THE STATE
WE REALIZE THAT DEFINING GREEN
HYDROGEN IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND WE'RE WORKING WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS TO DETERMINE THE
RIGHT DEFINITION FOR GREEN
HYDROGEN. THAT DOES NOT EXCLUDE
TECHNOLOGY AND HER CLIMATE
INTEGRITY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IDOL FOR SENATE BILLIE
JEAN AND THE PROVINCIAL CARE
ACT ABOLITION INAPPROPRIATE
VISION AND LEGAL AND REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK FOR CALIFORNIA TO
REALIZE THE BENEFITS OF GREEN
HYDROGEN. NAMELY IT'S A GREAT
WAY TO ELECTRIFY INTO CARBONITE
THEIR FUEL SUPPLY WE CAN
CONVERT ARE ABUNDANT LOW COST
WIND AND SOLAR RESOURCES INTO A
FLEXIBLE NERO CARBON FUEL THAT
CAN DISPLACE. MANY POSSIBLE
APPLICATIONS INCREASING
RELIABILITY AND RESILIENCY.
SECOND RAINBIRD GREEN HYDROGEN
WE CAN REPURPOSE VALUABLE
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE CLING
AFFORDABLE ENERGY TRANSITION.
AND THEN EXAMPLE LED W. P. AS
IN THE PROCESS OF CONVERTING
LAST REMAINING COAL PLANT IN
CENTRAL UTAH. COMBINED CYCLE
1100% GREEN HYDROGEN GAS
TURBINE. AND FINALLY GREEN
HYDROGEN IS A TREMENDOUS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ANDJOB
CREATION. OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA. GROWING GLOBALLY
COME WITH LARGE EXPORT. ALREADY
MANY COUNTRIES THE IRVINE TO
BECOME THE LEAD GREEN PRODUCERS.
INCLUDING ASSURE. SHE RANKS
BEING FORTY ARABIA AND OTHER.
GREEN HEIDI THE NEW OR HER
GENERAL. WITH MEDICALLY.
CALIFORNIA GET RID OF BY
GLOBALLY. I RESPECTFULLY YOUR
IDOL SB EIGHTEEN TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS CONTINUED GLOBAL
LEADERSHIP IN THE CLEAN ENERGY
TRANSITION. THANK YOU LET'S GO
OVER TO MEMBERS AND. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ALAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
MERION VARGAS AND JUNIOR
SCIENTIST WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL BEGIN
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB
EIGHTEEN. I'M SO THE CURRENT U.
S. PRODUCTION OF HYDROGEN- AND
IT'S AT NEARLY AS MUCH CLIMATE
POLLUTION AT ALL OF ILLINOIS
POWER PLANTS COMBINE. ISSUED
SOURCE OF POLLUTION IN BOTH THE
U. S. WIDE AND GLOBALLY AND
ENERGY CC SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL
FOR CLEANING UP EXISTING
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION AS WELL AS
NEW USES FOR HYDROGEN IT
DIFFICULT TO DECARBONISE
SECTORS SUCH AS AVIATION.
MARINE SHIPPING LONG DISTANCE
TRUCKING AND HEAVY INDUSTRY.
AND GREEN ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
MADE BY SPLITTING WATER USING
RENEWABLE ELECTRICITY IS ALSO
ONE OF THE MOST PROMISING
OPTIONS FOR LONG DURATION
STORAGE OF POWER AND FOR
MANAGING THE SEASONAL
FLUCTUATIONS IN THE APPEAL L.
BELLAVIA FOR NEW ELECTRICITY
FROM SOLAR AND WIND- BUT
IMPORTANTLY HYDROGEN'S ABILITY
TO PLAY A ROLE IN CLEANING UP
THE CON YOU TRULY. ON ITS
PRODUCTION I'M SO SORRY MERRY
WE'RE WE'RE MUCH WE'RE RUNNING
UP AGAINST THAT THE TIME FOR
THE FOR TESTIMONY PROSECUTORS
WANT. TO FINISH YOUR YOUR YOUR
YOUR POINT. I'M SORRY. SHORT
YET BUT WE STRONGLY THE
APPROACH AND ASK EIGHTEEN I'M
AN IT'S REALLY HAVING CAR. AND
DEVELOP THIS PLAN. THERE'S A
LOT THAT WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THE- AND PATHWAY. FOR FORM
HYDROGEN. WE APPRECIATE THIS
AMOUNT LOOKING THE COST AND BY
ISSUE HEALTH AND- OF THE VERY.
WHICH WILL HELP ELIMINATE THE
PATH FOR. I'M SO WITH THAT I
WILL. ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
SB EIGHTEEN THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU SEE THAT OKAY BUT I
SEE SOMEONE HERE IN PERSON.
WHILE I LOVE IT. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBER SERVICE AND THEY'LL SEND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
BUSINESS COUNCIL WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTEEN BECAUSE
IT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO EXPAND
DECARBONISATION ENSURING OF OUR
MENTAL INTEGRITY AND SPUR
INVESTMENT BY UTILIZING A
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL SCIENCE
BASED APPROACH TO ACCURATELY
QUANTIFY CARBON EMISSIONS FROM
ALL SOURCES OF HYDROGEN. WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE CENTER
SKINNER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTES THANK
YOU FOR YOU CENTER THE SAVINGS
THANK. THANK YOU FUTURE SENATOR
PERHAPS OKAY- SO LET'S NOW GO
TO THE PHONE LINE SEE IF
ANYONE- WANTS TO ADD AND
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL SB.
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR- SB EIGHTEEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
ZERO TO SHOW YOUR SUPPORT FOR
SB EIGHTEEN. WILL BEGIN TODAY
WITH LINE NINETY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR-
ALLEN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS OMAR GONZALEZ. I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE GLOBE
CORPORATION- WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE S. B. EIGHTEEN F.
AMENDED. NOW WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORED
INTRODUCED HELPFUL AMENDMENTS
AND REFER YOU TO OUR LETTER
THAT WE- RECENTLY SUBMITTED
SHARING OUR CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. KERN ELSE FORTY
EIGHT. YES WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CUED UP- MISTER. LANE FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
HI THIS IS TIM CARMICHAEL WAS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY
IN STRONG SUPPORT. FIND. SIXTY
NINE. HI KEVIN MURPHY FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE LEAGUE
WHERE IN STRONG SUPPORT. NINE
NINE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. JIM
LINDBERG FRENCH COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. WANT TO THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ILEANA'S AND
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE SUPPORTED
AMENDED TO EXPLICITLY INCLUDE
ORGANIC WASTE BASED HYDROGEN
WHICH CAN PROVIDE CARBON
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS WHILE
REDUCING SHORTER CLINICALLY
LANDFILLING AND OPEN BURNING OF
AGRICULTURAL AND FORESTRY.
THANK YOU. BURGER REASONABLE AN
EXCELLENT. EXCLU GO TO LINE.
TWO SEVENTEEN- ANYMORE
REPRESENTING MPS PATTERSON
CONTRA COSTA NAPA MARIN AND
SOLANO AND SUPPORT. TWO FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS JAMES FEDERAL
ACTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS IN HOUSE SUPPORT.
BLIND TO NINETEEN YOU ARE OPEN.
THANK YOU OPERATOR GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS TREAT
THE CAR COMING UP IN THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
WITH AN IMPORTANT CONCEPT IS
ACTION TODAY THIS IS GONNA BE
INTEGRAL FOR THE WAY THAT
TRANSPORTATION AND ENERGY IS
GOING TO ALLOW. YOU TO TEAMSTER
CAREFULLY RECOGNIZING THAT
MAJOR INVESTMENTS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN MADE. WHERE NO ONE HUNDRED
SILVA FORWARD TO OUR WITH THE
SENATE COMMITTEE MOVING THANK
YOUNG. FIND TO TWENTY FIVE YOU
ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS BRIAN I'M LOOKING WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY- ALONG WITH THE
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA WE
ACTUALLY HAD- WE ACTUALLY HAD
SUBMITTED A PROPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED- THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
GREAT WORK DONE ON THIS BILL
IT'S NOT AND PRINT IT AND BOTH
OF OUR ABOUT THE BILL'S
ORGANIZATIONS EXPECT. THAT-
WITHOUT CONTINUED DISCUSSIONS
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO REMEMBER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LAST
TUESDAY WITH THE VITAMINGROUP
ON BEHALF OF MITSUBISHI POWERS
AMERICA MAGNUM DEVELOPMENT AND
SCHUMER TO RENEWABLE ENERGY
WHICH INCLUDE AQUA HIGH TRICKS
ALL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS JASON
BARBAROUS WITH THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS WE HAVE A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS BEING
TAKEN TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING THROUGH SOME FURTHER
CHANGES. BY TWO OH NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. ASSEMBLY WITH THE
COALITION HEARD ABOUT YOUR GAS
IN SUPPORT WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE IDEA OF TAKING
MORE TIME TO BE INCLUSIVE OF
ALL LOW CARBON METHODS MAKING
HYDROGEN. FIND TO TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TWO
TWENTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN.
BUILDING ALONG WE WILL GO TO
LINE TWO TWENTY EIGHT.
CATHERINE HOUSTON UNITED
STEELWORKERS DISTRICT TWELVE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
MARK PENSION MAKER FOR
EARTHJUSTICE WE HAD REGISTERED
SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
COMMITTEE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THE AMENDMENTS COMING
OUT OF COMMITTEES AND BELIEVE
THAT THEY MAY RESOLVE THE
CONCERNS ARE AT THE BILL SO
FAR. ALL THE WORK OF THE AUTHOR.
AND HER STAFF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TWO THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ARIEL LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES BUSINESS COUNCIL AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. TWENTY TWO THIRTY TWO
EUROPE. BARROWS ON BEHALF OF
THE INDEPENDENT ENERGY
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SURE THERE
ARE NO THE PARTICIPANTS CUED UP.
THANK YOU. OKAY NUMBER OF CARE
PART SO LET'S GO TO THE
OPPOSITION- WE DON'T HAVE ANY
REGISTERED OPPOSITION ON THE
LEASE THAT THERE'S NO- NO AND
SCHEDULED TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION BUT LET'S OPEN UP
THE FRONT LINES ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES HE WANTS TO RAISE
CONCERNS- MODERATOR. THANK YOU
TO SHOW OUR OPPOSITION TO
EXPRESS YOUR OPPOSITION ON ITS
THE EIGHTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
TWO TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I THANK YOU SO MUCH THIS IS
JENNY COUNTS WITH LEADERSHIP
COUNSEL FOR JUSTICE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY REGISTERED AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS ABOUT
HYDROGEN GENERATED FROM DERRY
NOTHING- WE LOOK FORWARD TO
REVIEWING THE AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS WHICH WHICH EMAIL
ADDRESS SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
AND TO LOOK FOR TRIBUNE MOST AN
OPENNESS TO CHANGING
ARCHITECTURE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TWENTY NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS BILL MURPHY WITH
ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION SO
KALANAUR CAL- CHAPTERS OF OUR
EARLIER LETTER OF SUPPORT IS
SUPERSEDED NOW WITH OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND ESSENTIALLY
OUR REGION REASONS ARE OUTLINED
IN THE APRIL NINETEENTH LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU SEE
TO THE BILL'S AUTHOR-
ESSENTIALLY WE'RE SAYING.
OPPOSITION IS BASED ON- WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE GREENWASHING
WHERE GRAY HYDROGEN IS ALLOWED
TO START ADDRESSING THE
ATMOSPHERICS OF GREEN GREEN
GREEN THANK YOU. AND I LOOK. AT
THE FINE REMINDER PLEASE
PROPOSAL ZERO TO UP. TO S. B.
EIGHTEEN. STRUCTURE NOBODY
ELSE'S QUEUING UP DIRTY SO MUCH
WILL BRING THIS BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR DISCUSSION I DO
BELIEVE THAT- SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED HAVE
BEEN ADDRESSED- I AND I AND I
KNOW THAT THE TO THE CENTERS
VERY COMMITTED TO WORKING HARD
TO. TO GET THIS RIGHT SO I'M
I'M VERY IMPRESSED WITH THEIR
WORK SO FAR IS NOT AN EASY
ISSUE WHEN THE WORLD FOR TO GET
OUR HEADS AROUND TO BE HONEST-
BUT- BUT I'M- REALLY HAPPY FOR
THE BILL TODAY SO. DOT
QUESTIONS CONCERNS AND ISSUES
THE MOTION. MOVED BY SENATOR
AND SALAS- THREE MAY CLOSE R.
THANK YOU- A GOOD DISCUSSION
AND APPRECIATE AGAIN AS I
INDICATED THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND ELSEVIER ABOUT.
EIGHTEEN MY SENATOR SKINNER THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
ALLEN BY ALAN I BATES DOLLY.
DALY AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
SKINNER ALL RIGHT SKINNER AYE
STERN. STERN AYE STERN AYE
WIECKOWSKI. PART FOR ALL THE
ROLE OPEN AND I WANT TO WELCOME
OUR FRIENDS INSTEAD TO BACK IN-
THANK YOU FOR FIGHTING THE GOOD
FIGHT OVER THERE AND YOU'RE
GONNA BE OVER HERE. PLUS WE
WELCOME UNIVERSITY CHIU AND-
HOPEFULLY CINEMATOGRAFIA MAKE
IT OVER SOON TOO SO LET'S GO TO
YOU SENATE DOLLY TO PRESENT AS
BEFORE NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WANT
TO START OUT BY SAYING. FIVE
I'VE SAT ON NOT TO RESOURCES IN
THE ASSEMBLY I SAT ON EQ. IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND I WAS THEIR
FOR THEIR SPUR SCOPING PERIOD
OF- WITH- MEETING WITH MARY
NICHOLS WITH SENATOR HUESO
SENATOR- CHESBRO AND MYSELF AND
I ASKED FOR. ARE WE DON'T WE
CALCULATE OR WE ACCESS WHAT THE
IMPACTS OF CARBON ARE FROM
WILDFIRE IN THE ANSWER WAS THAT
IT WAS JUST IT'S A NATURAL
OCCURRENCE AND WE REALLY- AND
IT SO HAPPENED THEY AND THEY
HAVEN'T. COUNTED CARBON OR EVEN
ASSESSED HOW MUCH CARBON
RELEASING DUE TO WILDFIRE. SO
HOUSE FORWARD. IF YOU YEARS AND
WE DID SB NINE OH ONE IN SB
NINE ON WE AFFECTS BE TESTING
ON A ONE WE ACTUALLY PUT
LANGUAGE IN THAT BILL. THE SAID.
TWO A. R. B. YOU WILL ASSESS
THE MOUNT OF CARBON THAT IS
RELEASED FROM FOREST FIRE. THAT
MIND YOU. WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IN
OUR ECOSYSTEM BEFORE WE SETTLED
HERE IN THE SEEK IT BEFORE WE
SETTLED FIRE NATURALLY BURNED
IN CALIFORNIA. OUR LANDSCAPES
IN MOST PLACES EVERY TEN YEARS
IN SOME PLACES MORE OFTEN IN
SOME PLACES NOT SO OFTEN. BUT
WHAT DID THAT DO THE FIRE
BASICALLY FIT AND ARE FOR OUR
FORCE LANDS IN OUR BRUSH LANDS
AND GAVE US A ECOSYSTEM THAT
WAS BALANCED. WE CAME ALONG AND
WHAT DID WE DO WE SUPPRESSED
FIRE FOR ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS
NOW SO. ARE FORCED AND OUR OUR
RANGELANDS ARE NOT IN THE SAME.
PLACE THEY WERE BEFORE WE CAME
ALONG AND SETTLED THIS LAND IS
STARTED MANAGER LANCE. SO THE
ECOSYSTEM IS OUT OF BALANCE AND
QUITE FRANKLY. WE'VE SEEN
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AND THE
FIREFIGHTERS THAT ARE SO
DEVASTATING THAT THIS IS
BECAUSE THERE'S TOO MUCH FUEL
OUT THERE AND WHAT AND WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN WE HAVE ALL THIS
FUEL LOAD. WE HAVE TOO MANY
TREES PER ACRE IN AND. THE
CASCADES THE TRINITY ALPS THE
COASTLINES PARKS CARBON
SEQUESTERS WE ALL LEARNED IN
FIFTH GRADE THAT WHEN WE
BREATHE OUT CARBON MONOXIDE.
THE TREES BREATHE IT IN AND
THEY FILTER IT IS THE BIGGEST
FILTER SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA.
AND IT IS IMPAIRED AND I AM
SOMEWHAT FRUSTRATED I I'VE READ
THE ANALYSIS ON THIS. ON THIS
BILL AND YOU KNOW NOBODY WANTS
TO TACKLE THE BIG ISSUES IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN WE HAVE TOO
MANY TREES PER ACRE. WHEN THE
SNOW ACTUALLY FALLS. IT DOESN'T
TOUCH THE GROUND BECAUSE IT
LANDS ON THE BRANCHES OF THE
TREES. AND THAT CAUSES A DAPPER
TRANSPIRATION. THAT MEANS WHEN
THE WIND BLOWS IT EVAPORATES
AND IT GOES AWAY IT DOESN'T
LAND ON THE FOURTH FLOOR
BECAUSE IT'S TOO THICK. IN
WE'VE SEEN CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE WE'VE LOST MILLIONS OF
ACRES. IANS. FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION ACRES WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT HOW MUCH LAND THAT IS AND
HOW WHAT DEVASTATING YEARS AND
WE DON'T COUNT THE CARBON WE
DON'T TALK ABOUT THE CAR NO WE
REGULATE. CARBON THAT COMES
FROM. DIESEL TRUCKS AGRICULTURE
EQUIPMENT BOATS SHIPS TRAINS
AND WE TRY TO MANAGE THE SYSTEM
BUT WE DON'T TALK ABOUT THE
SYSTEM THAT IS REALLY IMPACTING
THE ENVIRONMENT BLACK CARBON IN
THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEVASTATION
FROM FIRE IS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE PUT INTO THE
SCOPING PLAN THIS BILL THIS
BILL DOES NOT ASK FOR ANY MONEY
FROM G. R. F. FUNDS. I STRIPPED
IT ALL OUT. THIS BILL SIMPLY
PASSED THE A. R. B. TO
CALCULATE EMISSIONS FROM FIRE
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES AND
FOR THE LIFE OF ME. I'VE TRIED
EVERYTHING AND I'M PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS IF YOU COME TO THE
FOREST AND LET THE FORCE TALK
TO YOU AND SEE WHAT HAPPENS OUT
THERE. THERE'S NO WAY AS
SOMEBODY WHO CARES ABOUT THE
ENVIRONMENT CANNOT. DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT IT'S THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM THAT
NOBODY. SEEMS TO. TWO ONE
ADDRESS. SO I GET OPPOSITION I
MEAN I MAYBE IT'S JUST THE NAME
ON THE BILL I GET OPPOSITION
FROM THE SIERRA CLUB ON ALMOST
EVERY SINGLE BILL I RUN HERE
I'VE INVITED THEM TO COME OUT
AND LOOK AT THE FOREST WITH ME
IN THE IN THE- IN THE- LANDS
THAT. ARE IMPAIRED I'VE TRIED
IT A GRAND MANY BILLS IN THE
AREA OF DOING STREAMLINING.
REGULATIONS SO WE CAN ACTUALLY.
GO OUT AND THEN THE FOR SO WE
CAN ALLOW FIRE TO DO IT
NATURALLY DID WHICH WAS BURNED.
IN A LOW INTENSE MOSAE QUA. TWO
MEMBERS. I KNOW I GOT
OPPOSITION I KNOW THIS BILL IS
TOUGH. AND I KNOW I PROBABLY
WON'T GET TO SPELL OUT HERE.
BUT I'M NOT GONNA GIVE UP ON
THIS BECAUSE IT'S RIGHT JUST.
IT IS VERY RIGHTEOUS. IN I
CONSIDER MYSELF AN
ENVIRONMENTALIST. I TOOK BY
TILL THE LUNATIC CARE LAID. IN
THIS FORCES ARLENA AND OUR
WATERSHEDS AND OUR WILDLIFE ARE
SUFFERING BECAUSE WE DON'T
ADDRESS IT IN THE RIGHT WAY I
JUST SIMPLY WANT TO. PUSH THE
POINT THAT. WE ARE RELEASING
CARBON. MILLIONS OF TIMES AND I
CAN PULL OUT OF THE NOW SAYS
THAT IT'S IN THERE IF YOU READ
IT HOW MANY METRIC MILLION
TONNES WAS HE MADE IT JUST IN
THE LAST CYCLE. SO I ASKED FOR
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL. I
KNOW IT'S TOUGH AND IF YOU HAVE
SUGGESTIONS IF YOU HAVE. MORE
DATA THAN I CAN THAT ANY
QUESTIONS FOR ME TO ANSWER I
WOULD LOVE TO ANSWER THOSE
BILLS FOR THOSE QUESTIONS SO I
CAN EXPLAIN. THE FLAWED
ANALYSIS I GOT. WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT YES TREES LIMBS FALL TO
THE GROUND AND THEY BECOME SOME
OF IT COMES BE PETRIFIED WOOD
THAT'S STORED CARBON FOREVER
THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT. BUT WE
HAVE TO GET ARE FORCED BACK
INTO SHAPE AND WE CAN'T DO THAT
UNTIL WEEK KNOWLEDGE THAT WE
HAVE A SERIOUS PROBLEM THERE
WITH CARBON OUTPUT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU FOR YOU
CENTER. THIRTY SEVEN DOLLARS-
LET'S LET'S GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- IF ANYONE WANTS TO.
PLEASE OPPOSITION SORRY BUT WE
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. WE DON'T
HAVE RICHER WITNESSES ON EITHER
SIDE. THE SHOW OF SUPPORT FOR-
I THINK WE'RE ON AS BEFORE
NINETY FIVE IS THAT CORRECT
YEAH THIS IS FOR NINETY FIVE
MOTOR. THANK YOU AND TO SHOW OF
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS. ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP EVERYONE IN
OPPOSITION. CHAU OPPOSITION
FOR- AS BEFORE NINE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
AGAIN I NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT
THIS TIME SIR OKAY PART. OKAY
SO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE LOOK I
WANT TO SAY FIRST OF ALL LET ME
JUST START BY SAYING AND- MY
APPRECIATION FOR THE FOR THE
AUTHOR- AND HE'S- ALWAYS
COMMITTED APPROACH TO I'M
ASKING TOUGH QUESTIONS AND
REALLY ASKING TOUGH QUESTIONS
OF OUR ENTIRE. APPROACH TO BIG
PROBLEMS OF. OF ALL SORTS AND
ESPECIALLY IN THE AREA OF
WILDFIRE AND I'M I'M PERSONALLY
VERY HAPPY TO GO TO WITH YOU
DID TO THE FOREST AND- KIND OF
WALK WALK A MILE IN YOUR SHOES
UP THERE- YOU KNOW THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT WE'RE LOSING OUR
GROUND THAT WE'RE LOSING GROUND
AND- IN OUR EFFORT TO COMBAT.
CLIMATE CHANGE WHERE WE'RE
WE'RE HAVING EVER MORE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES I JUST
YESTERDAY I WAS ON A CALL WITH
A BUNCH OF USC STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN HELPING ME THINK ABOUT
WHAT FAR CHALLENGES- WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT HOW THIS IS THE NEW
NORMAL I MEAN IT I THINK FOR A
LONG TIME WE JUST. KIND OF WE
ALWAYS KNEW THAT YOU KNOW WE
ALWAYS KNEW THERE WAS THIS WITH
FIRE. CHALLENGE THIS LIABILITY
THIS THIS DANGER. IS
VULNERABILITY- BUT IT WAS THE
KIND OF THING WOULD HAPPEN
OCCASIONALLY AND NOW IT'S JUST
BECOME A KIND OF AN ANNUAL
OCCURRENCE THAT TIME NOT ONLY
IN YOUR NECK OF THE WOODS BUT
MY NECK OF THE WOODS IN THE BAY
AREA- IN HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I
WE GOT LIGHTS FLICKERING OUT IN
THE MIDDLE TODAY BECAUSE THE
SMOKE FROM THE WILDFIRES HAS
GOT TO BE SO INTENSE IN THE IN
THE SMOKE THE WORLD READING IS
GOING TO BE SO INTENSE AND SO.
IT'S- IT'S AN ENORMOUS PROBLEM
NOW I DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THAT WE'RE JUST NOT DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT I MEAN WE
KNOW I THINK IT'S TAKING TOO
LONG- BUT OBVIOUSLY WE JUST
PASSED A MAJOR- BONFIRE
PACKAGE. ARE FOR FUNDING TO
ADDRESS- WILL BE A WILDFIRE
MITIGATION THIS IS OF COURSE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF THE BOND
DISCUSSION WITH SB FIFTY FOUR.
THERE'S A LOT IN THERE ABOUT
WILDFIRES- AND JUST A LOT OF
CONFERS OUR COMMITMENT EVEN
THIS LATEST PACKAGE AND WE DID
I THINK IT'S JUST THE START OF
WHAT IS IT IS CERTAINLY GOING
TO BE MORE AND MORE. RESOURCE
AND ATTENTION AND TIME GIVEN BY
THE EVERYONE FROM THE GOVERNOR
TO THE LEGISLATURE TO THE TOP
AGENCIES. TO START DEALING WITH
THIS ENORMOUS PROBLEM- THAT
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY. RIGHT TO
TALK ABOUT AND POINT OUT. AND
THEN THEY TRY TO JUST FOCUS ON.
MY ISSUE AND I THINK OUR
COMMITTEE ISSUE WITH THE BILL I
REALLY HAS MORE TO DO WITH THE
APPROACH. OF MUSIC THE D. V.
THE QUESTION ABOUT HOW THE
EXTENT TO WHICH WE CAN. PARSE
OUT THE COMPLEX INTERACTIONS
BETWEEN NATURAL CARBON CYCLES
AND HUMAN ACTIVITY IN GHG
EMISSIONS RESULTING FROM
NATURAL LANDS AND I GUESS THE
QUESTION THAT THAT IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO COME UP FOR US IS
HOW HOW WE CAN CALL FOR AN
ADMIN FOR THE PLAN FOR- GHG
REDUCTIONS FROM NATURAL
PROCESSES IN THE SCOPING PLAN
BEFORE WE KNOW HOW TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN IT
NATURAL PROCESS HE'S- AND THOSE
EMITTING CARBON AS A RESULT OF
HUMAN ACTIVITY WE MAY KNOW WHAT
IGNITES A FIRE FOR EXAMPLE BUT
WE YOU KNOW HOW DO WE DETERMINE
HOW MUCH THC FROM ANY GIVEN
FIRES NATURAL AND TO BE
EXPECTED. WHAT IS THE NORMAL
BASELINE WE DEVIATED FROM-
OBVIOUSLY WILDFIRES HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN A AN EMITTER- FROM LONG
BEFORE. YOU KNOW THE YEAR OF
THE- THE SPANISH- SO AND INTO
ACCEPT IT IS A FREE THERE IS A
NATURAL PROCESS ASSOCIATED WITH
FIRE IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
OUR ECOSYSTEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- OF COURSE YOU KNOW.
YOU POINT OUT EVERYONE KNOWS
THAT THAT HUMAN. INTERACTION
HUMAN ENGAGEMENT OUR
TRANSMISSION LINES THAT THAT
THE FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF WHAT
WE HAVE HAVE EXACERBATED THE
SITUATION. AMP AND PUT IT IN A
PLACE WHERE NOW WE REALLY HAVE
TO START TO GRAPPLE WITH
WILDFIRES AS HUMAN CAUSED-
POLLUTER AND IN ADDITION TO. NO
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT. SO NOW.
OF COURSE WELFARE SEVERITY
VARIES FROM FROM YEAR TO YEAR-
ANDERSON QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW WE
PLAN FOR EMISSION REDUCTIONS
FROM FIRE WE CAN ANTICIPATE
HOUSE OF YOUR SEASON WILL BE.
IS REMEMBERED SENIOR TO MORE
MORE SEVERE- WE KNEW WE KNOW
THAT LIMITING OFF I WAS NOT THE
CORRECT FORCE MANAGEMENT
APPROACH- BUT WITHOUT KNOWING
INAPPROPRIATE WILDFIRE
EMISSIONS BASELINE WITH. WITH
STATUTORY. DIRECTION TO
MAXIMALLY REDUCE EMISSIONS-
THAT COULD BE JUST FOR BACK TO
DOING. SO FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
STUDYING THIS ISSUE IS A BETTER
APPROACH IT ALLOWS US TO FIGURE
BEFORE POTENTIALLY SETTING BACK
OUR CLIMATE GOALS WRIT LARGE.
NOTS ON OF COURSE ANOTHER HUGE
PART OF THIS EFFORT WE KNOW
WITH PART OF CALIFORNIANS- THE
THOUGHT PROCESS HERE IS THAT WE
DO WANT TO CONTINUE TO BE A
LEADER. I KNOW IN IN IN IN IN
FOCUSING ON EMISSIONS REDUCTION
IN THOSE AREAS THAT- THERE
REALLY ARE ENTIRELY- AND- HUMAN
CAUSED- YOU KNOW I GUESS I
GUESS YOU SAID SB THIRTY TWO
REQUIRES CALIFORNIA TO GET 40%
NINETY NINETY. EMISSION LEVELS
BY TWENTY THIRTY ONE THE
QUESTION IS WHAT SHOULD OUR
WILDFIRE EMISSIONS BE 40% LOWER
THAN THEY WERE NINETEEN NINETY.
IS THAT IS THAT SAYS THAT HOW
WE SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT I
DON'T KNOW THAT IT IS. SO I'M
VERY SYMPATHETIC TO THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT I AGREE WE NEED
TO TAKE AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO
REDUCE THE SEVERITY AND
PREVALENCE OF WILDFIRES IN OUR
STATE. I'M A JOINT AUTHOR OF
THE SENATE'S CLIMB IN WILDFIRE
BOND OUT SB FORTY FIVE I WAS
VERY. SUPPORTIVE OF THE WELFARE
PACKAGE I'M ON THE WELFARE
TEAM. I'M VERY INTERESTED IN IN
IN WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR- ARE
YOU KNOW ON ON ON HOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE. IT'S NOT
JUST CONTINUE TO BUT REALLY.
CHINA GREATER SPOTLIGHT ON THE
CHALLENGES AND NEEDS- BOTH BOTH
FROM A PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE AND A FORCE MEASURE
PERSPECTIVE ALSO DECLARED
PERSPECTIVE. WHEN IT COMES TO-
TO ADDRESSING OFFERS I JUST
DON'T PERSONALLY FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH THIS.
PARTICULAR APPROACH- BUT I DO
WANNA SAY HI I DO SINCERELY
APPRECIATE. THE AUTHOR'S.
SINCERITY HONESTY AND A
COMMITMENT TO. TO ADDRESSING
THIS ISSUE- AT YOU KNOW I JUST
DON'T I'M NOT COMFORTABLE
SUPPORTING THIS PARTICULAR
PRICE TODAY- BUT CERTAINLY WANT
TO WORK WITH THEM IN THE FUTURE
AND OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW IF HE
HAS THE VOTES YES VOTES BUT- I
STILL WANT TO WORK IN THE
FUTURE- ON THIS ON WHAT IS AN
UNDENIABLE. UNDENIABLE MAJOR
CHALLENGE THAT OUR STATE FACES.
AND DONE SO WITH THAT HAPPY TO
OPEN UP THE FLOOR TO QUESTIONS
COMMENTS DISCUSSION FROM THE
MEMBER SAYS THIS AMERICAN
DOLLARS. S. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY I UNDERSTAND I KNOW
YOU'VE BROUGHT THIS ISSUE UP AS
WELL AND I- I HAD. THE
OPPORTUNITY WHEN I FIRST GOT IN
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TO GO
SENATOR NIELSEN UP TO PARADISE
TO SEE HIS COMMUNITY AND SO I
UNDERSTAND. THE AND I'VE SEEN
IT I DON'T UNDERSTAND FULLY
BUT- I'VE SEEN IT- DIRECTLY AND
IT'S- SOMETHING THAT I KNOW YOU
WILL CONTINUE WORKING ON AND WE
WANT TO HELP YOU WITH SINCERELY
I THINK I'M WITH THE CHAIR AND
THAT. IT IT IS THE APPROACH FOR
ME AS WELL- AND THE LAST
PORTION OF THE COMMITTEE'S
ANALYSIS EMAIL KIND OF STATES
IT ALL KIND OF WRAPS IT UP IN
IN TERMS OF. A STUDY TO
INVESTIGATE AND PROJECT HUMAN
BECAUSE VIRGIN VERSUS NATURALLY
BECAUSE I WANT TO CONTINUE TO.
BELABOR THE POINT BUT- I THINK
WE NEED TO START THEIR FIRST IN
ORDER TO. GET SOME
UNDERSTANDING ON ON WHERE WE
NEED TO PAY THAT FROM FROM HERE
SO. WITH THAT I'LL BE LAYING
OFF TODAY- BUT- I LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING. WITH YOU ON. THIS
SINCERELY AS WELL THANK YOU.
FORTY THE RECORD. FIVE BY A BE
DOWN HOUSING- I'M JUST CURIOUS
FROM THE AUTHORS BECAUSE I
THINK IT HEARING YOU MAY HAVE
SAID IT. WHY I MEAN I THOUGHT
THE ANALYSIS WAS VERY
COMPELLING WHAT MAKES YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE ABOUT TAKING THE
COMMITTEES- AMENDMENTS. WELL I
DID SOMEWHAT MAYBE ADJUSTED IN
MY OPENING REMARKS SO I WAS I
ASKED FIVE YEARS AGO ONE
SENATOR CHESBRO WAS THE CHAIR
OF NATURAL SOURCES AND I WAS
THE VICE CHAIR THAT WE DO WE
SCOPED IT PETITIONS COPING PLAN
FOR A R. B. NEVER HAPPENED. I
ACTUALLY WAS VERY KEY IN SB
NINE OH ONE WHEN I WAS IN THE
SIMPLY SIDE IT WAS ACTUALLY
REPUBLICAN LEADER AND I'M AND
JUST SENATOR WILL- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD NOT HELD OUT UNTIL
WE GOT THE LANGUAGE PUT IN.
THAT BILL TO ACTUALLY DO IT- IT
HAS A IT'S IN THERE BUT IT'S A
IT'S A- IT'S NOT QUANTIFYING
JUST FIRE. SO THEY DON'T DO THE
REPORT I GOT BACK IS A
CONVOLUTED REPORT IT TALKS
ABOUT. I WANTED. SO BASICALLY I
HAVE NOT GIVEN UP ON THE SIDE I
THINK IT'S A RIGHTEOUS THING TO
DO I THINK WE SHOULD. COUNT FOR
I'M NOT ASKING US TO FIND
SOMETHING I'M NOT ASKING FOR US
TO. TO TAKE ANY R. G. G. R. F.
FUNDS I STRIPPED ALL THAT ALL
THE BILL. DO I THINK WE SHOULD
SPEND MORE RESOURCE ARE
ABSOLUTELY AND WE DIDN'T GET
THAT DONE WE DID DO THAT AND I
DON'T WANT WE PUT RESOURCES IN
THERE. BUT SIMPLY THE FACT IS
THAT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT HUMAN
BECAUSE. AND NATURAL. YOU'VE I
KNOW THAT. SENATOR ALAN CENTER
SKINNER HAVE BEEN ON THE
FORESTRY TOURISM BEEN OUT THERE
TO SEE. ON THE GROUND AND I
KNOW THAT SUNDERLAND GONZALEZ
IS HOPEFULLY COMING WITH ME
SOON- WE CAUSE THE PROBLEM
THAT'S THE POINT WE TALK ABOUT
HUMAN BECAUSE YES THERE'S
DIFFERENT TYPES OF IGNITION
THAT HAPPENED BY HUMANS WHICH
IS EITHER TRANSMISSION LINES OR-
VEHICLES OR ARSON. BUT THE
RESOURCE ITSELF IS BEING
MANIPULATED FOR OVER THE LAST
HUNDRED YEARS BY MAN. IT'S NOT
IN ITS NATURAL STATE. SO WHEN
WE WANT TO IF WE WANT TO HAVE
THE DEBATE ABOUT. WHAT THE
RESORT WHAT HOW MUCH EMISSIONS
ARE GONNA COME UPWHAT WOULD BE
NATURALLY STORED WHAT WHAT IS
WHAT IS THAT BASS LINE WHICH I
THINK WHAT CENTER ALAN'S TALK
ABOUT THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO DO
A STUDY. HE YOU WE ASKED THEM
TO DO THAT AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
GAVE ME IF YOU LOOK AT THE
REPORT TO COME FROM. A. R. B.
IT'S PRETTY BENIGN AND PARTY
GENERAL AND NOT DOESN'T TALK
ABOUT WHAT THE- HUMAN CALL
HUMAN. INTERACTION WITH THE-
LAND HAS BEEN SO. THE REASON
FOR THIS BILL IS TO SAY THAT WE
PUT IN THIS POSITION. THERE'S
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT NOT I'M NOT
DENYING THAT. THE CLIMATE'S
WARMING. BUT WEEK WE CAUSED.
THE TO MEET THERE'S TOO MANY.
TOO MUCH FUEL. WHETHER IT'S IN
TREES OR BRUSH THERE'S TOO MUCH
FEELS AND WE NEED TO PUT IT
BACK IN THE STATE WORK FIRE CAN
ACTUALLY GO INTO THE-
LANDSCAPE. AND BE LEFT ALONE
AND DO WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO DO
WHICH IS. MOSAE CLEBURNE TO THE
FOREST AND WE HAVE ALL KINDS OF
DATA. THAT SHOWS US WHAT IT WAS
LIKE BEFORE WE MESSED WITH IT.
BEFORE WE EITHER CUT IT DOWN
AND LET IT GROW BACK AND THEN
STOPPED ALL THE FIRE OR
WHATEVER HAPPENED IN THE PAST
BUT I CAN TELL YOU. WHAT DID
HAPPEN IN THE PAST WAS WE'VE
MANIPULATED SO. THAT'S THE
REASON BEHIND THIS BILL IS TO
JUST GET THAT QUANTITY. TO TALK
ABOUT HATE LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE
DOING. ON FIRE. AND SKEWS ME I
RAN A BILL TO DO. THE ANALYSIS
FOR CREEK FOR WILDLIFE. THAT
BILLS ACTUALLY WORKING THROUGH
THE PROCESS WHICH I KNOW WHAT A
PROBABLY GET HELD UP. IN
APPROACH BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME MONEY BECAUSE I WANT
TO KNOW. WHAT THE KNOWLEDGE
THIS SO IT'S I'VE BEEN I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS WATERSHED.
CARBON APPROACH TO WILDLIFE TO
OUR TO OUR WATER SEQUESTRATION
IN THE FOREST AND TO THE CARBON
OUTPUT SO THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
THE THREE THE THREE LEGS OF
WHAT I THINK SHOULD HAPPEN WE
CAN WE DEBATE ALL DAY LONG
ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD SPEND THE
MONEY IN WHERE WE- WERE OR THE
RIGHT PLACES ARE. BUT I THINK
IT THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN MY
PHILOSOPHY AND SOME OTHERS IS
HOW WE GET THERE. WEEK WE CAN
REGULATE THE HECK OUT OF.
INDUSTRY BECAUSE WE GOT WE HAVE
A SOURCE WE KNOW RIGHT WORDS
COMING FROM AND WE KNOW THAT
WE'VE ACTUALLY TAKEN. CARBON
OUT OF THE GROUND AND WERE
MEDICARE. DEBATE BUT IN THIS
CASE WE'VE STORED MORE CARBON
IN OUR HAVING MASSEY RELEASES
OF IT. SO HOW DO WE GET HOW DO
WE ACTUALLY MANAGE THAT IN A
WAY THAT WE DON'T HAVE THESE
MASSIVE RELEASES. AND WE
ACTUALLY GO IN AND DO THE RIGHT
TO HATE WHICH IS STILL IN THE
DARK FORCED. AND THEN LET FIRE
DO WHAT IT DOES AND I RAN I
I'VE CHAMPION BILL AFTER BILL
TO TRY TO GET THERE AND I
ALWAYS HAVE OPPOSITION FROM
THIS PERSON THAT DOESN'T WANT
TO CUT A TREE AND THAT PERSON
THAT. IS LIKE. THE LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATION IS VERY HIGH AS YOU
CAN SEE SO I HOPE I ANSWERED
YOUR QUESTION. THE ONLY THING
THAT I WAS REALLY AND I KNOW I
APPRECIATE- YOUR EXPLANATION I
JUST WAS TRYING TO. UNDERSTAND
WHY. YOU KNOW IT IT SEEMED TO
ME THAT. THE WHILE THE
AMENDMENTS DID NOT ACHIEVE ALL
OF YOUR GOALS. THAT IT DID MOVE
THE BALL FORWARD AND DID. WOULD
PROVIDE YOU WITH SOME OF THE
INFORMATION YOU WANTED NOT
PERHAPS IN THE WAY YOU. THE WAY
YOU HAD HOPED. BUT THAT'S WHY I
WONDERED IF YOU WHY. YOU ARE
NOT WILLING TO TAKE ALL THE
COMMITTEES MINUTES BECAUSE I
COULD SUPPORT THE BILL. WITH
THE COMMITTEE'S MINUTES. YEAH I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT. IT'S KIND
OF LIKE SENATOR HUESO WAS BUILT
WAS KIND OF THIS IN THE AME
SITUATION IF YOU WATER MY BILL
DOWN TO OR I DOESN'T DO WHAT I
WANT TO GET IT DONE AND I
MUSCLE. YOU KNOW DO A BETTER
JOB OF EDUCATING I GUESS I
WOULD BUY WILL BUY WE HAPPY TO
SHOW SHARE WITH THE WHOLE
COMMITTEE WHAT THE A. R. B.
PUTS OUT RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS
WHAT THEY CONSIDER- THERE'S
THERE SCOPING PLAN AND IF YOU
READ IT. I HOPE YOU JUST AS
JUST AS JUST AS DISAPPOINTED AS
I AM AND THE RESULTS WERE
GETTING. SO ANYWAY. MISTER
SINISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- THANK YOU SENATOR DOLLY
FOR YOUR OF YOUR CONSISTENT
PASSION ADD BECAUSE HERE OF
I'VE BEEN THROUGH- THESE
DIALOGUES WITH YOU PRIVATELY
AND PUBLICLY FOR YEARS NOW- I
IT MIGHT MY CONCERN IS THAT IT
FEEBLE CATION IS THAT SOMEHOW
WE'RE IGNORING- THE CARBON
INTENSITY OF WILDFIRES AND THAT
THAT'S- THAT'S THE- PROBLEM
WITH THIS BILL HERE. THANK THE
INSISTENCE ON TRYING TO ADD TO
IT. EMISSIONS TO THE SCOPING
PLAN ITSELF. WHICH IS ABOUT
ANTHROPOGENIC HUMAN CAUSED
EMISSIONS FOR WHICH WE HAVE A
40% REQUIREMENT TO GO BELOW
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY
TWENTY THIRTY IN A REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE FRAMEWORK. WHERE
CARS AND TRUCKS IN POWER PLANTS
AND FACTORIES ARE ACTUALLY
REGULATED FOR THOSE EMISSIONS
IN THE SCOPING PLAN. TO PUT A
TREE. AND SAY THAT WE HAVE TO
NOW REGULATED TREE. LIKE WE
REGULATE CARS. IS I THINK YOU
MIGHT EVEN ADMIT SEEMS LIKE AN
AWKWARD FIT SO YOU KNOW IF WE
WERE GOING TO ADD THESE NON
ANTHROPOGENIC SOURCES THESE
SORT OF NATURAL THESE NATURE
BASED SOURCES. TO OUR SCOPING
PLAN. SAY IT'S ABOUT DOUBLE THE
EMISSIONS OF WHAT WE'VE GOT IN
THERE RIGHT NOW. YOU CAN NOW
JUST REDUCE THE COMPLIANCE
BURDEN ON THE REST OF THE STATE
BY HALF SO YOU'VE TOLD CONTROL
IN WHICH IS THE LARGEST SOURCE
OF EMISSIONS IN THE STATE YOU
KNOW IT. AFTER OBLIGATION HALF
LET'S NOT WORRY BOUT PETROLEUM
WE CAN HIT THE 40% BELOW
NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS JUST BY
ADDING THIS FOREST CARBON IN
AND DOING SOME FORCE
MANAGEMENT. IF THERE'S A WAY TO
BUILD THESE EMISSIONS IN SO
THAT YOU'RE NOT LETTING
EVERYONE ELSE OFF THE HOOK FOR
A VERY CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED
AGREEMENT AROUND. OUR CLIMATE
POLICIES IN THE STATE THAT WAS
NEGOTIABLE I PARTISAN BASIS AND
AS A HUGE INDUSTRY BEHIND IT.
AND IT'S A IT'S A LOT TO JUST
THROW IN THE WHOLE SOURCE THAT.
ISN'T AGAIN IS A NATURE BASED
SOURCE. THAT'S THE CAN. COURT
HERE I THINK IF YOU HAD TO
EITHER. A REQUIREMENT TO
INCREASE THE ACTUAL EMISSIONS
TARGET BY TWENTY THIRTY. WHICH
I KNOW YOU DIDN'T VOTE FOR OUR
OUR LEGISLATION THAT WOULD HAVE
DONE THAT SB FIVE EIGHTY TWO-
BUT THAT THAT 80% TARGET WOULD
ALLOW FOR SPACE FOR THIS KIND
OF FORCED REDUCE CARBON OR IF
WE WERE ABLE TO MOVE TO GO MORE
SENATOR SKINNER'S ROUTE AND
HURT SB TWENTY SEVEN WHERE
SHE'S ALSO TRYING TO GET. AN
ACCURATE INVENTORY AND REALLY
GET THE MATH DONE BEHIND
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS BUT
NOT TRYING TO TREAT THAT AS A
MARKET BASED COMPLIANCE
MECHANISM FOR THE REST OF THE
MANMADE EMISSIONS. THEN YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE THE CONCERN THAT
PEOPLE LIVING IN LONG BEACH ON
THE SEVEN TEN CORRIDOR OR WHO
WERE SUFFERING FROM POLLUTION
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY ARE
SUDDENLY GOING TO HAVE TO SEVER
JUST AS MUCH IF NOT MORE
POLLUTION BECAUSE- WE STARTED
COUNTING FORCE AND THAT OFFSETS
ALL THAT OTHER POLLUTION. SO I
THINK I MIGHT BE YOU KNOW IT'S
PROBABLY TOO LATE TO ADD THAT
KIND OF AMENDMENT OF AN 80%
TARGET TO YOUR BILL OR TO TRY
TO TAKE THESE EMISSIONS AND PUT
THEM WHERE I THINK THEY BELONG
WHICH IS IN A- COURT A NATURAL
WORKING LANDS FRAMEWORK THE
RESOURCE AGENCY COULD LOOK AT.
IF. YOU'RE OPEN TO THAT- I
THINK WE WERE COULD SOMETHING
HERE AND MAYBE NOT TODAY BUT
MAYBE THIS SESSION TO PUT THAT
ALL TOGETHER BUT- IT'S TOO
NARROW TO SIMPLY SAY NO NO
WE'RE TRYING TO IGNORE. THOSE
EMISSIONS- AND YOU'RE NOT
PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS A. R.
B. A. R. B. IS PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE CHALLENGE WE SET BEFORE
THEM WHICH IS TO GET 240% BELOW
NINETEEN NINETY. OF
ANTHROPOGENIC EMISSIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE WANNA
DOUBLE THAT THE LET'S DOUBLE
OUR COMMITMENT. SO I'M UP FOR
IF YOU WANT TO ADD THAT TO THE
BILL I'D BE GLAD TO SUPPORT IT
OR TO TAKE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS- I'M GLAD TO SUPPORT
THAT BUT I. I THINK WE'VE GOT
TO JUST HAVE AN APPLES TO
APPLES KIND OF CONVERSATION
ABOUT ALL THIS YEAR. I'D LOVE
TO RESPOND TO THAT. PERSONALLY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL.
ANALYSIS BUT I JUST WANNA MAKE
ONE COMMENT. THE CLIMATE
DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER YOU
BRING THE- CARBON OUT OF THE
GROUND OR YOU MINUTES SOMEWHERE
IT DOESN'T MATTER AT THE END OF
THE DAY YOU STILL HAVE A CALL
USED TO HAVE A CARBON PROBLEM.
WHETHER YOU WHETHER YOU HAVE A
SOURCE FOR FUNDING OR NOT OR
SORCERY WANNA LET SOMEBODY OFF
THE HOOK OR NOT IT ENDED TODAY
HI I THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY-
INTERESTING THAT TO THE EPA
DIRECTOR SAID HE WAS WITH THE
GOVERNOR IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
THE SKY WAS ORANGE IT WASN'T
FROM CARS. IT WAS FROM THE
FORCED BURNING THE HECK DOWN SO
LOOK I'M I KNOW I'M NOT GOING
TO GET THIS BILL OUT HERE TODAY
BUT I CHALLENGES. BY CHALLENGES
EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
LEGISLATURE. TO HELP ME FIGURE
OUT A WAY THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY
DO THE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE BECAUSE IF YOU TRULY CARE
ABOUT THE DARN CLIMATE. CAN YOU
REALLY WATCH OUR WATERSHEDS GET
DESTROYED. CAN WE REALLY IT'S
BEYOND MY COMPREHENSION THAT WE
FOCUS ON SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE. AND THERE'S THIS
THERE'S THIS GIANT OUTPUT IT'S
LIKE FOR ME IT'S LIKE DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE AND AS I SAID
EARLIER I'VE TRIED ALL AYE
BRAND BUILT TO TRY TO. CORRECT
THE REGULATE REGULATORY
PROCESSES. IN THE FORCE TO GET
US TO DO IT. ON ON WITH ITS
OWN- PAYMENT SCHEDULE BUT I
JUST WOULD SAY THAT IN AND THE
OTHER THING THAT I WANT TO ADD
IS THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS NOT AT THE TABLE. WHICH IS
VERY FRUSTRATING THEY HAVE 60%
OF THE OF THE LAND MASS IN
CALIFORNIA IS OWNED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHICH IS OUR
WATERSHED. ARE WILDLIFE. AND WE
DON'T WE DON'T WE ARE NOT THE
TABLE AT ALL AND YOU KNOW. I
WENT OFF ON TRUMP'S SITTING
WHEN HE SAID YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S PROBLEMS ARE
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA DOESN'T DO
THE RIGHT THING INFO AND TRY TO
BLAME GOVERNOR NEWSOM NOW.
BUDDY YOU REPRESENT 60% OF IT
AND YOU'RE NOT MANAGING YOUR
LAND AT ALL AND IT'S DISGUSTING.
WELL WE'RE WE'RE HOPING- THAT
THE FEDERAL WILL COME TO THE
TABLE- SO I WILL TELL TRY TO
MOVE BASIC TENER BATES. WE'LL
TAKE THAT AS CLOTHES APPRECIATE-
I KNOW AND I SAY CHALLENGES IN
TERMS OF PARTNERSHIP WORKING
TOGETHER ON THIS ISSUE- SO
BECAUSE OF HIS COLOR. HELLO
ITEM NUMBER NINE S. B. FOUR
NINE FIVE BY SENATOR DOLLY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE ALLEN.
ALLEN BATES RIGHT BATES I'D
DALLY DALLY I GONZALEZ. SKINNER.
STERN YOU'RE NOT VOTING OR NOT
VOTING BY CAL SKI. OKAY WILL
CLOSER ON THAT TIME THANK YOU
OKAY LET'S GO TO YOU CENTER
STERN NOW TO PRESENT YOUR BILL
THIS IS OUR LAST BILL ON THE
AGENDA. YOU MAY PERCEIVE AN
RARE NUMBERS I'LL TRY TO BE AS
BRIEF AS I CAN HERE WE'RE WE'RE
BACK ON THE TOPIC OF CLIMATE
CHANGE- AND TRY TO TAKE AN
HONEST LOOK AT THE FINANCIAL
RISK. THAT CLIMATE IMPACTS NOT
JUST THE WILD FIRES WE WERE
JUST DISCUSSING BUT- THE
OVERALL IMPACTS IN THE STATE
ARE ADEQUATELY DISCLOSE AND
ACCOUNTED FOR- BY OUR MAJOR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS- THERE
BEEN EFFORTS BOTH IT. WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS WELL AS AT
THE SEC- UNDER WAY IN THE NEW
BY NAY MINISTRATION. TO PUSH
OUR LARGEST FINANCIAL-INSTITUTIONS TO START
DISCLOSING- THE FINANCIAL RISKS
ON THEIR BALANCE SHEETS AROUND
CLIMATE CHANGE. I THINK THAT.
WE'VE GOT TO DRIVE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT AND WE NEED THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AS OUR PARTNERS
IN THIS BATTLE BECAUSE AS WE'VE
HEARD TODAY- THE PUBLIC DINING
AND PUBLIC DOLLARS AND POLICY
CAN'T DO IT ALONE. SO FOR ALL
THE SHAREHOLDERS AND OTHERS
INVESTED ALSO IN THESE FUNDS.
WE THINK THAT THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF ASSETS RT AT LEAST
LOOK FORWARD AS THE FEDERAL
RESERVE IS RECOMMENDED AND- IT
GERRY GANSLER THE- NOT MANY
FOR. SEC IS RECOMMENDED IN HEAD
OF COUNCIL ECONOMIC ADVISERS IS
RECOMMENDED IN. NUMEROUS
INSTITUTIONS AROUND THE WORLD
HAVE ALREADY COMMITTED TO
INCLUDING SOME OF CALIORNIA'S
LARGEST BANKS AND INVESTMENT
INSTITUTIONS THANKS AMERICA
WELLS FARGO PRUDENTIAL
INSURANCE. SO TODAY WE'RE
PRESENTING TO U. S. B. FOUR
FOUR NINE. TO HOPEFULLY- BRING
SOME MORE TRANSPARENCY TO THE
PROCESS AND- LET THESE
INSTITUTIONS MAKE SMARTER
FIDUCIARY RESPONSIBILITY
DECISIONS FOR THIS THE
RESPONSIBLE TO I WANT TO
CLARIFY- THAT I DID MAKE
COMMITMENTS TO ADDRESS SOME
OPPOSITION CONCERNS AMENDMENTS-
AND GIVING THAT GIVEN THE
TIMING OF THE COMPRESSED
COMMITTEE SCHEDULE. WE'RE WERE
WE HAVE TO GET THOSE.
AMENDMENTS DONE IF THE
COMMITTEE GETS AT THE BILL GETS
OUT TODAY TO TAKE THIS ALL IN
APPROPRIATIONS- BUT JUST
OUTLINED IT FOR THE
STAKEHOLDERS OUT THERE WHO I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
ENGAGEMENT ON- I THINK WE'VE
BEEN MAKING A REALLY GREAT
PROGRESS- THE AMENDMENTS
INCLUDE TO THE CLARIFICATION OF
THE DEFINITION OF A CLIMATE
RELATED FINANCIAL RISK. TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- THE CLARIFICATION
THAT ONLY ONE. METER IS
DISCLOSURE IS GOING TO BE
REQUIRED FOR INSURANCE ENTITIES
THAT MAY BE COVERED BY THIS
LEGISLATION. AND THAT WE'D LIKE
TO SEE THAT REPORTING NOT GO
THROUGH- DO YOU HAVE P. I. A
SEPARATE INSTITUTION BUT BUT
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE WHERE THEY'RE DOING
THEIR EXISTING REPORTING THAT
THAT- BUT THAT REPORTING WOULD
WOULD SATISFY. THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THIS BILL. AND THEN ALSO TO
ADDRESS THIS QUESTION OF
LOOMING FEDERAL ACTION AND WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THIS COMPLIANCE
FRAMEWORK IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACTS AND TO MAKE
SHOULD MAKE CLEAR THAT. SHOULD
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. REQUIRE
THE SAME KINDS OF- T. CFT
REPORTS THESE CLIMATE FINANCIAL
RELATED DISCLOSURES THAT HAVE
BECOME THE INTERNATIONAL
STANDARD FOR THIS CLOSURE WHICH
IS LOOKING LIKE WHERE THEY'RE
HEADED- THAT. THAT THAT
COMPLIANCE WOULD SATISFY
COMPLIANCE WITH THIS BILL WE
WOULDN'T WANT TO HAVE A
DUPLICATIVE ENFORCEMENT OR
COMPLIANCE FRAMEWORK PUT IN
PLACE. SO WE'RE TRYING TO SORT
OF ANTICIPATE WE HOPE WILL BE
FEDERAL ACTION WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY A LOT OF
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS ACTIVELY
LOBBYING AGAINST THAT ACTION
BUT SHOULD THAT COME TO PASS
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO TRY TO
IMPOSE SOME DUPLICATIVE
OVERLAPPING OR PREEMPTED
FRAMEWORK HERE IN CALIFORNIA-
SO. THAT'S THAT'S AND THERE
THERE'S ALSO A COUPLE- NEED
THESE COMMITMENTS ALSO NOTED
PAGE NINE INTENDED TO COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS TO IF YOU GUYS WANT
TO. TAKE A CLOSER READ IT THAT.
I'M SO. THE BILL WOULD BE WOULD
SPECIFICALLY ONLY ADDRESS THOSE
FINANCIAL INSURANCE AND
CORPORATE INSTITUTIONS WITH
OVER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR IN ANNUAL
REVENUE TO PREPARE CLIMATE
RELATED FINANCIAL RISK
DISCLOSURE REPORT AND SUBMITTED
TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE- IS
THIS STANDARD- THE TECH BY THE
TASK FORCE ON CLIMATE RELATED.
RISK DISCLOSURES BEEN ADOPTED
BY OVER SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS WORLDWIDE AND I
THINK CALIFORNIA OUGHT TO BE AT
THE TIP OF THE SPEAR. I WE'VE
CROSS REFERENCE NUMBER THE
EFFORT BY THE GOVERNOR. AND
THEIR NEW CLIMATE RELATED RISK
DISCLOSURE ADVISORY GROUP
THAT'S CO CHAIRED BY OPR
DIRECTOR KATE GORDAN. AS WELL
AS SOME FOLKS AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY ARE HELPING SO WE
WANT TO LINK TO EXISTING
PROCESS EASIER AS WELL AS WHAT
IS GOING ON OVER AT CDI. AND
WOULD SINCERELY APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY I THINK
THIS IS GOING TO BE. A CRUCIAL
PIECE OF LEGISLATION MOVING
ABOUT FOR NOT JUST IN
CALIFORNIA BUT HOPEFULLY
SETTING THE STANDARD FOR THE
NATION AND THE WHOLE WORLD AS
WE DO HERE IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU SO MUCH. FOR TO MY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO EIGHTY WONDER FROM V.
TWO AND THEN A KID. MONAGHAN
CENTRAL MASS MEASUREMENT. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN IN ON
THE TO BE TO IN STRONG OF US
BEFORE NINE YOU TO THE NATIONAL
NONPARTISAN GROUP OF BUSINESS
LEADERS AND INVESTORS WHO
ADVOCATE A POLICY THAT IS GOOD
FOR THE ECONOMY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT TWENTY SIX HUNDRED
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS UNDERSTAND THE
CLIMATE CHANGE THE BUSINESSRESCUE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY IS
INCREASINGLY VULNERABLE
SEALEVEL RISE IS IMPACTING
COASTAL BUSINESSES ONGOING
DROUGHT AFFECTS AGRICULTURE
DISRUPT CORPORATE SUPPLY CHAINS
AND WILDFIRES ARE DRIVING
ECONOMY WIDE IMPACT. IT'S
CLIMATE RISK REACHES DEEPLY IN
OUR FINANCIAL MARKETS YET DOES
NOT ADEQUATELY UNDERSTOOD BY
INVESTORS WITHOUT TRANSPARENT%
AND RELIABLE INFORMATION
FINANCIAL MARKETS CANNOT GAUGE
INNKREIS CLIMATE RISK CORRECTLY
SB FOUR FOUR NINE FILL THIS GAP
BY REQUIRING LARGE CORPORATIONS
AND FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
INCORPORATING CALIFORNIA TO
DISCLOSE THEIR CLIMATE RELATED
RISKS IN THE STEPS THEY ARE
TAKING REDUCE THEM BY
LEVERAGING ESTABLISH FRAMEWORKS
DEVELOPED BY THE TASK FORCE ON
CLIMATE RELATED FINANCIAL
DISCLOSURE THIS BILL FURTHER
INSURANCE THE DISCLOSURE
PROVIDE ACTIONABLE INFORMATION
SB FOUR FOUR NINE ALSO PROVIDES
INFORMATION NEEDED TO CATALYZE
CORPORATE ACTION BUSINESSES
NEED TO ADAPT AND EVOLVE TO
COMPLY WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICY AND THE TRANSPARENCY
DRIVEN BY THIS BILL WILL SHIP
MARKET REWARDS. COMPANIES THAT
ARE ACTIVELY TACKLING THEIR
MISSIONS AS THE BUSINESS ADAGE
HOLDS YOU CAN'T MANAGE WHAT YOU
DON'T MEASURE A CRITICAL STEP
TO SAFEGUARDING OUR ECONOMY
AGAINST CLIMATE RISK IS
MEASURING AND UNDERSTANDING IT
AND MAKING THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE FINANCIAL MARKETS AND
REGULATORS SB FOUR FOUR NINE
PRESENTS CALIFORNIA WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SET THE STANDARD
FOR ASSESSING CLIMATE RELATED
FINANCIAL RISK IN ADVANCE ARE
WORK TO CREATE A SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMY THAT CAN MEET THE
CHALLENGES OF THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU THANK.
YOU NO ONE IS GOING TO KEEP ON
HAND. THANK YOU TO ON AND- OF
THE COMMITTEE THE OP. TO TODAY
ON MY NAME IS KEEP ON AND- OF.
AFTER I. AND THAT MANAGE. AND
TODAY I. IMPACT AFFECT. LLC AND
CHILEAN BUT MANAGEMENT LLC.
INDEPENDENT INVESTMENT ADVISERS
WITH A COMBINED FORTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
UNDER MANAGEMENT. AND TODAY WE
OFFER TESTIMONY INTO COURT AND
ASKING FOR FOUR NINE WHICH
WOULD THAT STANDARD REQUIRED.
UNDER THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO
BETTER MEET OUR- FUTURE OUR
CLIENTS. IMPACT UNTIL YOU'RE WE
SERVE CLIENTS TO BELIEVE THAT
INTEGRATING ENVIRONMENTAL
SOCIAL AND GOVERNANCE FACTORS
INCLUDING CLIMATE RISK INTO THE
FINANCIAL ANALYSIS I THANK. CAN
HELP IDENTIFY THE COMPANY BACK
POSITIONS IS A LEVER AT LONG
TERM RISK ADJUSTED PERFORMANCE.
IT IS A FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR
MISSION AND FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITY TO UNDERSTAND
ANY MATERIAL YET YOU. TURN OUR
OPPORTUNITY THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL HELP. PROTECT OR ENHANCE
SHAREHOLDER VALUE. THE CHANGING
CLIMATE QUE AND- RIGHT AND I.
FURTHER WARMING THE PLANET
EXPECT TO LEAD TO DOWN ECONOMIC
INTO CONFLICT. POSSIBLY
APPROACH WALKERS AS 5% OF WHAT
GDP BY TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. WELL
INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
TECHNOLOGIES OFFER A PATH
TOWARDS MORE SUSTAINABLE GROWTH
AND JOB CREATION. CALIFORNIA
HAS CONSISTENTLY LED THE
COUNTRY IN RECOGNIZED RECORD
OPPORTUNITY. PORTANTINO
UNDERSTAND THE NATURE OF
CLIMATE RELATED RISKS AND
OPPORTUNITIES IN ORDER TO
EXTRACT MANAGE AND CREATE THEM
TRANSPARENTLY AND
COMPREHENSIVELY. BERMAN DOCTORS
LIKE I ASKED YOU THE AVERAGE
CONSUMER TABLE PER TIRE MEANT
HOPE YOU'RE CONSISTENT EXPOSURE
WILL ALLOW FOR BETTER DECISION
MAKING. FOR INVESTORS IN
PARTICULAR UNDERSTANDING
CLIMATE RISKS AND OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE FINANCIAL TORN BACK AND
WE CAN EITHER UNDERSTAND AND
PREFERENCE CORRECTLY OR WE CAN
WAIT FOR A THEORY THAT
INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT WRITER
MISTER DICKEY ISSUES WITH OUR-
HIS. ARE DONE I'M WE'RE WEIRD
WERE UP. FIVE YEARS ACTUALLY.
AND SO IT ISN'T BY THERE'S
UNIFORM. MOMENT AND WE SUPPORT
YES FOUR FOUR NINE AND A LINE
WITH CITY. YOU CALIFORNIA SET
THE STANDARD I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE- PRESIDENT YOU THANK YOU-
THE MEMBERS JUST FOR TO KNOW
THAT FOR TECH. SUPPORT WE DO
HAVE TEN LAMB WHO'S RESEARCH
FOR WITH THE C. CENTER. THE
SUPER OF A LOT OF IS A- FOR
TALKING QUESTIONS THE BILL.
LET'S GO TO ON THE PHONE LINES
NOT USING NO ONE IN HERE IN
PERSON IN THE CAPITAL ON THE
PHONE LINES ANYONE WAS. RICHER
SUPPORT FOR US BEFORE FORTY
NINE. SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR FOUR
NINE- PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. SURE
WE'LL START OUT WITH ONE
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SURE SURE SURE AND MEMBERS
NEED. HELP WITH YOUR MANAGER
WITH THE- MAJOR COMPANIES AND
OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MAJOR INVEST ADVOCATE. JERRY SD
NINE ALL SHE EARLIER TODAY A
LITTLE LETTER ON THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WITH OVER
SEVEN BILLION NOW IN A CHECK WE
STRUGGLE. BEFORE THE JOB THANK
YOU. PINE NINETY NINE PLEASE
CALL. THIS IS GOING RATE ELDERS
BECAUSE ACTION CALIFORNIA
NORTHERN CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT.
MY. ONE NINETY FOUR. BOB JANET
PROSPER TRIGGERED NUCLEAR
BALLET AND I WANT TO READ THE
NAMES ARE GROUP. CORKER BURKE
WERE NOT NOT HE INCLUDE IN THE
AND NOW. AS YOU SO TENDER
INTERNET AND BY LAW. PUBLIC
CITIZEN. THREE COLORADO THREE
FIFTY HUMBOLDT. BAN SINGLE USE.
HELLO THIRTY NINE INDIVISIBLE
CALIFORNIA GREEN TEAM
INDIVISIBLE MORAN INDIVISIBLE
KANYE HOLD FOREVER MORE
INDIVISIBLE LOS ALTOS HIGH
SCHOOL GREEN TEAM NORTHRIDGE
INDIVISIBLE. WHAT COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL COMMITTEE
ZERO WASTE SANTA CLARITA THIRTY
THIRTY COALITION AND EDGE
CALIBER THANKS VERY MUCH. AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FOUR.
S. B. FOUR FOUR NINE AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE. ONE NINETY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB. PLEASE
PROCEED. WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TAKE HER AGAIN I THOUGHT SHE
WAS OVER OKAY LET'S GO TO THE
NEXT CALL PLEASE. MY THOUGHT
ABOUT NINE TO TEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS THE LEAD
SPONSOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. MA'AM IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RE PROP COLLEGIATE ONE ZERO
AGAIN I APOLOGIZE- NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE TWO TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ALL MY
FRIENDS ON THE HOUSE OF. SO
SHAREHOLDER ADVOCACY GROUP AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NINE TO TWENTY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SURE
NUMBERS THIS IS JAMIE GO ON
BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
ONE NINETY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES THANK YOU-
I'M JACK **** I'M CALLING FOR
THREE FIFTY SO I CAN VALLEY AND
I'M GOING TO READ THE NAME OF
THE GROUPS THAT ARE SUPPORTING
THE BILL BUT WERE NOT INCLUDED
IN THE ANALYSIS WE HEARD THAT
WE HADN'T DONE IT YOU HEARD IT
YES WE CAN RIGHT NOW AND SO
GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE BUT BUT
WE DO WE DID HEAR THANK YOU. I
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING ON.
THANK YOU COULD YOU. NINETY TWO
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALAN JACKSON ON BEHALF OF
ENERGY PRODUCTS SPONSORED IN
SUPPORT. AND THE FINAL REMINDER
ONE ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT FOR SB
FOUR FOUR NINE. AND NEXT WE
WILL ALIGN TO THIRTY SIX. HI MY
NAME IS DEBBIE MIGHT TELL HIM I
REPRESENT PENINSULA INTERFAITH
CLIMATE ACTIONS WERE EIGHTEEN
CONGREGATIONS BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND SUNNYVALE AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU SO MUCH BY. ONE TO
THIRTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN.
THREE THIRTY EIGHT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JIM WEINBERG ON BEHALF
OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION TO CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE QUEUE.
RIGHT LET'S GO TO OPPOSITION
WE'VE GOT DE DANIELLE READER
FROM AMERICA PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURERS ASSOCIATION FOLLOWED
BY MELANIE CUEVAS FROM THE
COMPANY BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MANAGER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI
MY NAME IS DANNY WRITER AND I
AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN PROPERTY CASUALTY
INSURERS ASSOCIATION. APCA IS A
NATIONAL TRADE WHOSE MEMBERS
RIGHT ABOUT 60% OF THE PROPERTY
CASUALTY INSURANCE MARKET WHICH
AT THIS POINT OUR ASSOCIATION
CURRENTLY HAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON SB FOUR
FOUR NINE. WELL WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE WHAT THE ATHORS
TRYING TO DO AND WE BELIEVE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION WE REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THE BALLOT CURRENTLY DRAFTED
BECAUSE IT CONTINUES TO OVERLAP
WITH THE REPORT THAT WE ALREADY
FILED WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE SH.
BACKGROUND THINK TWENTY TEN
INSURANCE HAVE BEEN COMPLETING
THE CD I ADMINISTERED CLIMATE
RISK DISCLOSURE SURVEY ANNUALLY
AROUND ONE THOUSAND INSURANCE
COMPLETE THE COMPREHENSIVE
MANDATORY AND PUBLIC SURVEY BUT
AFTER ABOUT A NUMBER OF TOPICS
INCLUDING EMISSIONS INVESTMENT-
IMPACT MITIGATION AND RISK
MANAGEMENT THE SERVICE
CURRENTLY UTILIZED IN. OTHER
INTEGRITY TOTAL AND CAPTURES
MORE THAN. 70% OF THE ENTIRE U.
S. MARKET- IMPORTANT. MARKETS
IMPORTANTLY- THIS WHY CREATED
THROUGH PROCESS- BETWEEN OUR
CAL REGULATORS TI AND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS THE
YANKEE. THAT WAS DELIVERED IT'S
LISTED IN INDUSTRY IN FEEDBACK
AND ENSURE THAT RECORDING COULD
BE HARMONIZED AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL. THE ENERGY CLIMATE AND
RESILIENCY TASK FORCE CONTINUES
TO WORK ON THE SURVEY MEET
REGULARLY TO DISCUSS POSSIBLE
ON A VACATION TO OUR SURVEY AND
WE BELIEVE SB FOUR FOUR NINE
SHOULD BE AMENDED TO ACCOUNT
FOR THE CONTINUAL NATIONAL
OVERSIGHT FIRE STATE.
REGULATORS THERE SEEMS TO BE NO
CLEAR PUBLIC POLICY RATIONALE
FOR SETTING UP A DUPLICATE
PROCESSES ARE COMBINED OUR
SUCCESSFUL MODEL OF NATIONAL
COORDINATION- WE'RE PLEASED TO
HEAR THE AUTHOR REITERATED
COMMITMENT TO AMENDMENTS MADE
DURING LAST WEEK'S BANKING
FINANCE COMMITTEE HEARING.
INTENTIONALLY JR'S NOT HAVE TO
USE THAT THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT BY FILING
THE NHC CLIMATE RISK DISCLOSURE
WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONERS- INSURERS WOULD
HAVE SATISFIED THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THIS BILL THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE'RE SEEKING. WE HAVE
DRAFTED AMENDMENTS THAT
AFFECTING SHARE THEM WITH THE
AUTHOR- SHOULD THE COMMITTEE
TODAY DECIDED TO MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD WE WOULD HOPE THAT THE
COMMITMENT- ANY COMPANY
AMENDMENTS WILL BE HONORED AND
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. AGAIN IN
CLOSE WE APPRECIATE THE INTENT
OF THE BILL BETTER STILL
SEEKING AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
ALLOW THE CURRENT NXT CLIMATE
RISK DISCLOSURE REQUIRED TO
SATISFY THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
CELL AND GET DIFFERENT CHORE
CURRENT REGULATOR AND ALL THAT
TIME. WE CONTINUE TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE SB FOUR
FOUR NINE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY THANK YOU SO. MUCH THE
NEXT MELANIE CUEVAS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS NON
GREATER FOR THE- BANK AT THE-
THANK YOU FOR THE ARE. TO
PARTICIPATE IN TWENTY HEARING
OTHER VIRTUAL FORMAT. ALTHOUGH
WE AGREE THEY ARE WILLING
SHOULD THE- CONCERN. CAME THE
AUTHOR MEAN. BEFORE FOUR NINE
AS AMENDED WE ALSO HAVE THE
MISTAKEN AND CONCERNS THAT THE
FIVE EXPLICIT AND SPECIFIC
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE AGREED
UPON. DURING THE MEASURES PRIOR
POLICY COMMITTEE HEARING HAS
NOT YET BEEN FOOTBALL. AND
REMAIN INCOMPLETE. TIME AND
WHILE THE BOTH OF THEM IN OF
THE AGREEMENT FOR TO BE HOW
HERE WE CAN TO ESTARá FIGHT
AND HEREFORD MINISTRY. WILL
APPROACH AND VIGOROUSLY
ADDRESSED THE NATION'S RESPONSE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
GOVERNANCE AND CLIMATE RELATED
RISK DISCLOSURE ADVISORY GROUP.
I'VE ALREADY BEEN ATTACKED THE
COLLABORATIVELY GENERATE
ANYTHING RESOLUTION
REQUIREMENTS WE LONGER WE'RE
ALMOST AT THE FEDERAL. LEVEL-THE DISCLOSURE POINTER AT WORK
AND YET I'M SORRY WE WERE JUST
WHERE DOES AGAINST THE- BECAUSE
IS IT IS SHE- TO TIME FOR THE
FOR THE SPEAKER SO. AND FOR MS
RITTER I GUESS TO GO BIT EXTRA
SO HE COULD FINISH YOUR FINAL.
SHE NOT SURE I'M HITTING THE
PAUSE BUTTON ON AT THE FOUR
FOUR NINE TODAY WILL ALLOW THE
RIGHT IN HERE SAID
MINISTRATIONS AT THE BILL THEIR
PROMISES. AND WILL ALSO ALLOW
THE GOVERNOR'S ADVISORY GROUP
SHE'LL ACCOMPLISH THE TASK IF
THEY HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO
DEAL. AND AT THE TIME WHERE
RESPECTFULLY URGING A NO VOTE
CONTACT. E. PAR PAR NINE.
REDUCE MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR
YOUR ANDERSON THANK YOU. OKAY
LET'S GO TO THE PHONE LINES-
OPPOSITION FOLKS ONE RAISE
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
MODERATOR. IF YOU. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHARE YOUR
OPPOSITION FOR SB FOUR FOUR
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN I'M ASKING. ONE
MOMENT WE ARE HAVING A COUPLE
PURCHASE BUT KEEP UP. MR GERARD
FIRST PARTICIPANT IS GOING TO
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD TO
THIRTY NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SEVEN
TAYLOR FOR THE PERSONAL
INSURANCE FEDERATION WE ALSO
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS THE
UNLESS THE AMENDED POSITION ON
SB FOUR FOUR NINE. UNTIL WE SEE
THE SPECIFIC AMENDMENTS WHICH
WE ARE OPEN ASSUME WILL REFLECT
THE DISCUSSION AND SENATE
BANKING COMMITTEE AND
APPRECIATE THAT WORKING WITH
SENATOR STERN- ON THOSE AND
THEN IT JUST THANK YOU GOD JUST
REMIND FOLKS THIS IS A JUST
NAME AFFILIATION PLEASE AT THIS
POINT. NEXT CALLER PLEASE BUT
IT'S- THANK YOU ONE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
EMELIE DALAM THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
IN OPPOSITION. YOUR FOUR POINT
TWO THIRTY SEVEN YOUR OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON VALERIE NERA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR FOUR NINE
THANK YOU. AS A FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO TO SHOW OPPOSITION FOR SB.
FOUR FOUR NINE. MISTER CHAIR
ANOTHER PARTICIPANT QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE ITEMS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
THOUGHTS CONCERNS. CENTER OF
SERVICE JUST A QUICK QUESTION
FOR SENATOR STERN I JUST WANT
TO I KNOW YOU SPOKE TO THE FACT
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON. THE
AMENDMENTS I JUST WANT TO KNOW
ARE YOU STILL COMMITTED TO
MAKING THE CHANGES YOU AGREED
TO IN THE BANKING COMMITTEE. I
THINK YOU WENT THROUGH ON TWO
OR THREE OF THOSE BUT- I THINK
WE NEED YOU ON THE RECORD JOB
THAT YOU ARE STILL COMMITTED TO
THOSE THAT WAS A VERY LENGTHY
DISCUSSION AT THAT TIME. FORTY
MINUTES. YES- BSP CENTER SHE
COULD. THE REALTORS ISSUE THE
INSURANCE SECTOR REDUNDANCY
ISSUE MAKING COLLUSION AND
CONNECTION FEDERAL ACTION I
THINK WITH THE- FORT. TO
REITERATE WHAT I SAID AT THE
OUTSET. YES PLEASE CLARIFY THAT
AGAIN JUST I WANT TO BE
RESPONSIVE HERE. IF YOU COULD
JUST CORPORATE JUST REITERATE
YOUR YOUR DOCUMENTS ON THIS SO
WE WANT TO CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF CLIMATE RELATED
FINANCIAL RISK TO MEET THE
CONCERN FROM THE REALTORS- WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. THERE'S
ONLY THERE'S NOT GONNA BE A
DUPLICATIVE SET OF DISCLOSURES
FOR COVERED INSURANCE ENTITIES-
AND- TO BE CLEAR I THINK THERE
WERE SOME IMPLICATION THAT I
HAD. COMMITTED TO A SPECIFIC
KIND OF REPORT THE AND A IC
REPORT AS I NOTED DURING THE
LAST HEARING WHEN I HELD UP
BOTH THE NHC REPORT AND THE- T.
CFT REPORT THAT THERE ARE SOME
SUBSTANTIVE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THOSE SO WE HAVE TO. RECTIFY
THOSE DIFFERENCES- HI BEFORE I
CAN COMMIT TO- JUST ACCEPTING
WHATEVER IS WHATEVER SURVEYS
CURRENTLY BEING FILED THERE'S
SUFFICIENT. I'M SORRY. I
SUPPOSE THAT. WANTED IT W.
REITERATE OR CLARIFY THAT- BNA
I SEE REPORT FOR INSTANCE
DOESN'T DEAL WITH ANY REPORTING
OF. ASIANS IN SCOPE IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS- THE METRICS USED BY
THE ORGANIZATION TO BRING THEIR
CLIMATE RELATED RISKS IN LINE
WITH THE STRATEGY FOR THE
COMPANY IT DOESN'T- IT DOESN'T
ADDRESS THE RESILIENCY
ORGANIZATION'S STRATEGY- SO
THERE'S A FEW GAPS SO I'M
LOOKING FORTY CONSULTING WITH
THE- IT CONVINCED THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER ESPECIALLY WHAT
THEY HADIN MIND THERE BUT-
AGAIN WE WANT ONE FILING
PATHWAY. ONE DISCLOSURES- AND
THEN THE LAST PIECE IS THE
BETTER THAT WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
APPROVED THEIR OWN CLIMATE RISK
DISCLOSURE PRODUCT. PROCESS
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY HAVE.
THIRTY TO PREEMPTIVE HERE TO-
IF THEY SO CHOOSE BUT IF THE IF
FORCED TO ALLOW SPACE TO
REGULATE IN THE FIELD THAT-
THESE THESE KIND OF DC FTA
FILINGS WITH THE FEDS WOULD.
SATISFY OUR STATE REQUIREMENT
TO THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA TRY TO
DUPLICATE IS FILING
REQUIREMENTS HERE- WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
STATE GOVERNMENT- SO STILL
REMAIN COMMITTED TO ALL THAT
AND- HAPPY TO TAKE ANY FURTHER
INPUT OR STRUCTURE TO WORK
THROUGH THE DETAILS BUT- YES
YEAH. SAME SAME COMMITMENTS
BEFORE. YEAH AND I AM A STAR
DOING SOME. DECEMBER BANKING
WILL OF COURSE IT BACK OF THIS
GUY GOT SO CLOSE THANK YOU
SENATOR STERN I THINK THE NEW
THAT YOU'RE STILL WORKING ON IT
IS. OUR FIRM- OF LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE FOR THOSE WHO RAISE
THAT ESPECIALLY THOSE TODAY ALL
ON THE LINES WITH THEIR ON
OPPOSITION SO I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT-
COMMAND YOU FOR OUR YOUTH
COMPLICATED ANY AND YOU'RE
STILL ARE WORKING HARD TO.
RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES. I'M OF
THE BILL AND SAID IT'S GONNA OF
THE BILL BILLS A MOVE TO AND.
MY LAST QUESTION MISTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU- CINDERELLA I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR BRINGING FOR.
I THINK THE GOVERNOR FOR
SETTING UP. THIS WORKING GROUP
AND I THINK IT'S- IT DID HAS
VALUE TO GIVE IT SOME. HELP
GIVE ITS MORE DEFINITION OR FOR
SOME MORE- A CHARGE TO- AND
THIS IS OUR CONSISTENT TRENDS
THOUGH I WILL. THE WHOLE ISSUE
OF DISCLOSURE OF FINANCIAL RISK
RELATED TO CLIMATE THE CLIMATE
CRISIS HAS REALLY BEEN ON GOING
SINCE THE NINETEEN NINETIES
AND- IT'S- I SUPPOSE I SHOULD
NEVER BE SURPRISED BY HOW LONG
SOMETHING STICK BUT I FOUND IT
VERY INTERESTING IN ONE OF THE-
ENTITIES WHO CALLED IN TALKING
ABOUT- YOU KNOW THIS MAYBE WE
DON'T WHY DO WE NEED THIS LIKE
EVEN AN A I SEE NOW THAT'S THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS. IT
REQUIRES YOU KNOW THIS-
DISCLOSURE WELL RETAIL YOU
ALONE HAVING BEEN THE PERSON
THAT INITIATED THE N. A. I. C.
TO EVEN BEGIN CONSIDERING THIS
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE
SO I SPENT 200-032-0004 TWO
THOUSAND FIVE ATTENDING ANY ICY
MEETINGS AND INTERACTING WITH
INSURANCE COMMISSIONERS FROM
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AND THE
MAIN RISK MODELLERS IN THIS
FIELD TO TRY TO GET THE ENERGY
TO PAY ATTENTION TO THIS AND IT
WASN'T IT IS ONLY I THINK THREE
OR FOUR YEARS AGO BEFORE THE
ANY ICY SO. WHAT'S THAT YOU
KNOW FIFTEEN YEARS OR SOME
LATER BEGAN TO PUT SOME THINGS
INTO PLACE AND STILL NOT THE
TYPE OF COMPREHENSIVE
DISCLOSURE THAT MANY
INTERNATIONAL AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN ASKING FOR AND MODELING
AND- SOME HAVE PUT INTO PLACE
SO. AT THIS I THINK THIS IS THE
KIND OF- AS WE MOVE FORWARD
LOOK WE'RE ALREADY IN DOOR
KNOCK AND REVERSE. FIVE CLIMATE
CHANGE WE MAY BE ABLE TO AVERT
ITS WORST CONSEQUENCES BUT
WE'RE NOT GONNA TO GET RID OF
IT AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO
UNDERSTAND. THE FOR ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT RISKS MUCH BETTER AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WE MAKE A LARGE
INVESTMENT SO. I THINK WHAT-
WHAT SENATORS. IS WORKING ON
AND TRY TO CALL HERE GOOD BY.
THE COMMITTEE MM AND I KNOW
MISTER WORK OUT ALREADY MOVE TO
BUILD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR SKINNER-
CERTAINLY THIS ISSUE I'VE BEEN
VERY INTERESTED IN DID SOME
BILLS ON THIS TOPIC SO I'M I'M
DEFINITELY SUPPORTING THAT THE
SENATORS BILL TODAY. SUCH A
MOVE BY CENTER TASK IF YOU LIKE
TO. FIVE CLOSE CENTER WESTERN.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU THE
ROBUST CONVERSATION TODAY AND
KIND OF FOR THE WORK LIES AHEAD
I WOULD JUST SAY IN CLOSING YOU
KNOW I HEARD A- WE FOR PRESSING
PAUSE. ON THIS LEGISLATION OF
FROM THE BANKING INDUSTRY. AND
YOU KNOW CLIMATE CHANGE IS NOT.
PRESSING PAUSE ON THIS WILDFIRE
SEASON IS NOT A PAUSE THIS
DROUGHT IS NOT CAUSING- AND TO
DEFERRED TO WASHINGTON AND WAIT
FOR THEM TO ACT WHEN AGAIN
THERE'S ACTIVE LOBBYING FROM
THE FINANCIAL INDUSTRY AGAINST
ALL THOSE EFFORTS TO TRY TO
STOP THAT IN CONGRESS- TO TRY
TO STOP THIS NEW STC FROM
ADOPTING ALL THIS WORK. AND
TELL US TO PAUSE WHAT ADVOCACY
CONTINUES- TO ME SEEMS LIKE A
MISGUIDED EFFORT- IF I HAD A
SENSE THAT SAY THE BANKING
INDUSTRY WAS GONNA SUPPORT
WHAT'S HAPPENING AT THE SEC
RIGHT NOW AND THAT THERE REALLY
WAS NO NEED FOR CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATION AB ONE THING BUT
I'M SEEING. QUITE THE OPPOSITE
SO I THINK THIS BILL IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT KEEP
MOVING- AND KEEP PUSHING MS AND
BUILDING ON FOLKS LIKE SENATOR
SKINNER'S EFFORTS FROM BACK IN
THE NINETIES SO- WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO WAIT EVEN THOUGH
WE'VE BEEN PATIENT THIS LONG SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THE SO MUCH ALL RIGHT MOVE BY
SARAH CALCULUS A BOOK PLEASE.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN S. BEFORE
FOUR NINE OR SENATOR STERN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ALLEN BY. I
BATES. BATES NO DALLI DALLI
KNOW GONZALEZ AND SALAS I
SKINNER SKINNER AYE STERN.
STERN AYE EARN AYE WHY CASKEY
HI CASKEY I OKAY THAT IS A VOTE
TO GET OUT WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN THAT LET'S REOPEN THE ROLE
FOR THE OTHER. ITEMS MEMBER
SAYS WE CAN WE CAN. BE DONE
LET'S LET'S START WITH SB SIX
SIXTY TWO ARCHULETA. I ITEM
NUMBER ONE AS THREE SIX SIX TWO
ARCHULETA THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED BUT FIRST RE REFER.
AMENDED RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS-
THE VOTERS THREE ZERO WITH THAT
CHAIR VOTING ARI IN THE
VISSCHER VOTING HIGH. GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I SKINNER. SKINNER AYE
STERN. TURNING STERN AYE WHY
CASKEY THE VOTING. KASKY NOT
VOTING. OKAY MOVING CLOSER ON
THAT LET'S GO TO ITEM BY. HI
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST BE REFERRED
AMANDA RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS THE
VOTE IS TWO TO ONE ALAN HI
ALLEN AYE BATES BATES NO
THERE'S A LOT OF STERN. STERN I
WHITE HOUSE AYE MY CAN I. OKAY
WE'RE CLOSER THAT WAS DUE S. B.
T. THREE AND THREE. SB TWO TWO
THREE THE MOTION IS DEEP AND
BUT FIRST OF RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROACH. THE
VOTERS TO ONE WITH THE VOTING I
AM THE VOICE OF NO. DALLY DALLI.
STERN. RIGHT KERN I WHAT KASKY.
OKAY THE TO DO THREE YEARS OR
OKAY AUG ARE I CAN I ARE CLOSE
THE ROOM OUT THAT'S GOING TO
ENFORCE FIVE FIVE BUT RUSSELL.
THE MOTION IS THE DEEP BUT FOR
BE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE A
PROBE. THE VOTE IS TO ZERO WITH
THE VOTING I'D- BATES. BATES
DALLY DALLI NO. SKINNER I
SKINNER I STERN. NINE EARNED
WORKED SCHEME CASKEY I ARE ON
THE LET'S GO TO MA'AM I NUMBER
SB FIVE NINETY SIX BY. I STERN
YOU'RE NOT TURN IOWA CASKEY HI
S. CI. OKAY GOOGLE ZERO ZERO ON
THAT LET'S GO TO ITEM SIX THIS
IS SB SIX NINETEEN BY LAYERED.
EMOTIONS DO PASSED THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE VOTERS THREE
TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
HIGH BATES RIGHT BATES I DALLI.
DALLI AYE STERN. STRAIGHTAWAY
LEARN I Y. CASKEY BY ASKEY I'M
MARIO BECAUSE ROLE IN THAT
LET'S GO TO ON THE CONSENT
COUNTERS ADAM SEVEN WEST SO SIX
TWENTY FOUR- THE VOTE IS FOUR
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR AND VICE
CHAIR VOTING I'D DALLI. DALLI
AYE STERN. STERLING KERN I Y.
CASKEY BY THE ICE OKAY THIS
GETS A CONSECUTIVE- OF ITEM
EIGHT SB SIX NINETY SEVEN WEST
SO. MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS- THE VOTERS
THREE USER WITH GERMANY I
BATES. HEALTH BATES NO DALLY
DALLY NO STERN. RIGHT KERN I Y.
CAO SCHEME BY ASKI I'D- RIGHT
NEXT TO ITEM NINE DOLLY THAT
ONE I THINK EVERYBODY VOTER ID
OKAY. AND THEN ITEM TEN. I
DON'T TEND SB EIGHTEEN-
SKINNER. AND LET'S OF NORTH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE VOTERS
FIVE ZERO WITH CHAIR VOTING AYE
BATES. NOBODY BATES NOT VOTING
FOR CASKEY I AYE CASKEY AYE
OKAY. BECAUSE ARE ON THAT AND
THEN OF COURSE EVERYONE VOTE ON
THIS ON STERN BILL- WITH THAT
THANK YOU EVERYBODY THANK YOU
STAFF. THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED.